[Music]
do
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
it's round six day six here at the
palacio de satonia there we see the
spanish commentary
i think they're already live as well the
live audience will be coming in
very very soon as they do every single
day a chance at an autograph a chance to
see
one of their chess heroes in person
these are the reasons they gather the
players gather to throw down
on the chess board
every single day and uh we gather
we gather upstairs here
we sit in our comfy chairs and then we
just judge no i'm kidding
here with almira scripchenko robert hess
danny wrench and we're looking forward
to day six round six elmira we got
another rest day coming but
we gotta not yet right you excited for
round six well i'm so excited ready to
ramble and well i promise they have to
sing once again you know sunshine is
here
there it is here
i would ask if you were looking forward
to the rest day but you just got here so
yeah but i was really worried about i
had to sit next to you so yes i'm
looking forward okay well then robert's
looking forward to the rest day as well
uh but until then we have a round ahead
of us an epic round it will be and we
need to remind everybody of where things
stand of course yonder palmishi is
leading the field right now he's he's
driving the bus and everyone else is a
passenger on his on his joyride through
the candidates at this time
uh elmira again just after round five
looking back at yanapanashi how
impressed are we right now
well of course we are very impressed and
i'm glad that you said that he's driving
the bus because i was looking for
another analogy this looks like a nascar
race you know he's certainly reading
legion that he's this crazy pilot who
doesn't let anyone in but you know
everyone is very close you know it's
like and how many laps do we have to go
we have nine more laps yes great a great
analogy right he moved over a few times
yesterday to keep hikara nakamura in the
rear view how impressed were you with
yonder palmishi's defense versus hicario
yeah it was almost a self-induced crash
because he played too quickly in some
critical moments right it was kind of
the yawn that we thought he'd put behind
him that allowed him to win the
candidates the last time around but it
reared its ugly head and almost cost him
but thankfully for him and his
tournament standing he's still in the
lead
great great breakdown way to set the
tone for what that was a self-induced
crash but
grab control of the wheel at the right
time and as we've been continuing to do
for the community putting together a
highlight recap breaking down the
critical moments describing what's at
stake and so another reminder about just
how epic round five was between nakamura
and upon dashi is here for your viewing
pleasure right now
with the white pieces for only the
second time in five games hikaru
nakamura was on the hunt for a precious
full point against the candidate's seoul
leader yan nipomnishi
needing only a draw nepo selected the
solid petrov defense and nakamura almost
immediately began to think seemingly
mentally reviewing his opening options
at the board
i think he actually did not expect it
the way he's using his clock right now
yeah is not somebody who's just
verifying their lines making sure that
they're not going to make a mistake i
really don't believe he had this mapped
out for today's game
nakamura's chosen variation one he'd won
with brilliantly before in the u.s
championship paid off surprisingly
quickly as nebo danced with his queen
first to a dubious square on e4 and next
to a nearly losing one on g4
it looks like a mistake right i mean
queen g4 h3
and then where's this queen going
i just don't like how this game is going
it feels like it's playing a bit of
carter's hands without any counter
punches
hicaro found the right moves to continue
harassing the queen and as nepo realized
how great his troubles were his
competitors began to hover over the
board anticipating the possibility of a
shakeup in the tournament nepo appeared
to be pleading for aid to higher powers
nepo's pleas were granted as hikaru
twice misstepped with his knight
heading first to d2
and then later to a5
if that bishop gets a c5 it could be the
white king that's suddenly in some
danger
his advantage largely gone and his time
dwindling nakamura's frustration was
evident for the second time in the game
he began to repeat the position
this time not to gain time on the clock
but to repeat three times and agree a
draw
and that's such an important save for
young yeah very important
if he goes on to win this we might be
talking about this game as one of the
early games that that really uh
influenced his 2022 candidates victory
for hikaru missing a major chance to
press the leader shirley stings though
there are many rounds yet to play
for nepo perhaps this will prove one of
the lucky breaks that tournament
champions invariably need to secure
victory
elmira have you ever pled to the gods in
the middle of a chess game for your
opponent to go wrong
well i truth if it's all they did
yes because during those moments see
well well eventually during the chess
game you're always alone this is the
feeling that you have maybe also like
tennis players but
sometimes you do appeal you know to
to some forces
yeah
have you ever had someone hovering over
you like fabiano caruana maybe fabi
himself being like robert what's going
on bro yeah all the time because i'm
making all the mistakes but i mean it's
a nerve-wracking situation to be sure
yeah great great highlights there from
the team working super hard
and we appreciate it but let's talk
again about the highlights that has been
yonder palmishi's five rounds up to this
point
no losses of course and uh that draw
yesterday was a big one looking ahead to
what he will do with the white pieces
against young christoph duda he's in the
lead elmira so will he will he be
aggressive with the white pieces
well i don't think that jan
he has
well he needs an extra incentive you
know to be aggressive with white pieces
i would simply say give him an opponent
you know he has a complete opening
repair to her and he will certainly try
to win today but it will not be an easy
task because dude hasn't lost a single
game in this tournament yeah that's a
great great cue for robert then so so
what's duda going to do right we saw
that ali reza perugia did not have a
good game in choosing the night or
sicilian
but judah likes himself on night or
right is he going to avoid that do what
he did yesterday with the pet truck your
thoughts on what's going through his
mindset yeah it's a really difficult
question to answer because these players
they mix and match their openings we saw
duda play in the black side against
caruana he played a sicilian yeah then
when he played against alareza fruga he
chose the petrov now alireza chose the
sicilian against yanuponzi it didn't
work out very well so for duda i think
it would be wise to choose the more
solid opening and that typically is the
petrov but then you remember that jana
palmache just played the petrov
yesterday right and he played against
magnus carlsen so he has world
championship preparation up his sleeves
from the black side which also means he
studied it from the white side so it
could be a dangerous choice by duda i
mean there may no be no right choice and
how he plays today how he meets jan upon
when she's opening that's what's going
to tell the story yeah picking between
poisons no one wants an open sicilian
with jan right now but great point on
the pet drop with prep from magnus
carlson of course so that is that is one
big matchup but it's not the only
matchup we have in round six of course
so let's dive into the other
head-to-head battles that will ensue
starting right at the top i'm going to
let almira weigh in on rajab report
because robert already said how excited
he is for this so elmira your thoughts
on what will happen there
well
robert gave a very extensive i think
preview of this game and
i'm excited about this game because i
think that uh richard well he's a player
who is certainly going for a win once
again with black against timur ajaba as
difficult as that that might be because
sir jabez has a very solid opening
repair tour but we're certainly going to
see some fireworks today yeah
well
i guess we do have some time so i'll let
you weigh in again i know you want to i
i stole your thunder your java report
stylistic differences so your thoughts
on that battle yeah complete stylistic
mismatch yeah and for report he had this
quote yesterday
after playing five minute carwana where
he's like people praise my brilliance my
creativity but he's like i have no
choice because my openings are very bad
so
the thing about this game and where this
is such a tricky moment for rapport is
that if he plays the way he did against
duda where on move seven it looked
terrible for rapport the end game was
clearly better for duda in that one
rajaba will punish him the jabba has
that style that end game precision that
technique that experience that will help
him seize a full point given the
opportunity so that's where i worry for
report okay we're going to skip perugia
karwana because we all have some
thoughts we want to weigh in there and
jump to nakamura ding hikaru has won the
only decisive game between the two of
them elmira what do you think he'll be
doing with the first move his second
white in a row
well it's almost uh well the same is
true for hikaru as it was for yan you
know i think hikaru is well he
well prepared very intelligently for
this tournament so once again he uh he
well his repair tour has many new ideas
and he needs to be aggressive today okay
especially with white and then
napomnishi gets the white pieces against
duda
we uh as we said that's that will will
it be a sicilian will it be a patch off
dude is in control of that so we'll
we'll talk more once we see pieces being
moved on the board so faruja caruana we
want we want to talk about this one
because it's it's one that a lot of
people have circled you've got uh the
youngest player in the field a lot of
fire right a lot of people saying
farouja is the future right now he's at
the bottom right of the standings but he
does have the white pieces so how
aggressive do we expect him to be
against
fabiano
well i think that eliza
doesn't know how to
well to be careful especially in such a
critical situation this is the first
critical situation in the tournament for
him where he desperately needs a win
and especially against fabiano where as
we see the score shows that uh well it's
he's not his nemesis yet but uh well
he's beaten him with white pieces
to two times so far so he needs to find
what a strategy which allows him well
not to crash
today but play for a win
maybe he doesn't know how to be careful
but should he be careful against fabiano
yeah he needs to be careful but i also
think that you know as i was
highlighting yesterday that fruit just
pummeled a lot of his opponents right
you don't get to 2800 as a teenager by
just slowly making progress like you
just you ascend it's a meteoric rise and
unfortunately for ali reza the players
he's facing here they're not going to be
pushovers not in any single game we've
seen players get bad positions even
rajab of yesterday or beyond the promise
yesterday and they put up this
resistance right that is like you have
to play perfectly if you are going to
win with your advantage so i think for
ali reza you know there's a lot at stake
here he's at the minus score he wants to
win with the white pieces but you can't
just go all in against five under
carwana because he is perhaps the most
objective player there is he doesn't
take speculative risks and you mentioned
that sometimes that's to his detriment
but he's not going to just you know meet
a speculative decision by making one in
return he's going to calculate and if
you're making these kind of questionable
choices like alerisa did against report
in that rook end game he went for
activity rather than passively defending
fabiano he punishes people for that but
you also made the point that even though
bobby has the two wins of the two
decisive games
that because rouge is so young and he's
ascending so fast is ferocious the same
player now that he was in the grand
swiss when fabiano beat him right it's a
very fair question because every you
know month i'll raise a different player
right because he you're that young
things are changing
we can talk about certain players and we
said they've been playing the same way
for 15 years right ali rizzo hasn't been
playing chess for 15 years and his style
is evolving he's getting new coaches
right that changes your style he's
playing new openings he in fact is
learning openings in a much deeper level
for the first time in his career that
sounds wild to say because he's 2 800
but now he's finally playing 14 super
grand masters top 10 players
in a row right that just doesn't happen
in most events when you're ascending so
it's a very different field a different
atmosphere and a different all areas
every day all right well and it's a
different set of games for us to vote on
every day so before the players come in
it's time for us to remind you that
you've got to cast your vote use the
command guess and head over to chess.com
events you'll get a direct link so it's
super easy barely an inconvenience type
command guest right now i'm going to run
through the games here napomnishi versus
young christoph duda i'm going to
predict a draw precisely because of what
almira said regardless of how aggressive
yonda pomnishi has been duda has been as
solid as anybody five draws in five
games thus far hikaru nakamura and
dingley ren i'm also gonna predict the
draw i think akara will get off to a
good start but ultimately this game will
also end peacefully i know what people
are saying like what are you doing danny
you're predicting draws the opposite of
your three decisive predictions
yesterday well look what happened i
predicted three wins and we got four
draws so you're welcome world uh against
uh with farouza taking the white pieces
against bobby no caruana i'm also going
to predict a draw because i think that
the players playing black today are
super solid and just not going to give
way with the one decisive victory i'm
going to shock the world here and say
that i think richard report is going to
get the w as black in a game and a clash
of stylistic differences i think report
finds his initiative late in the middle
game takes this thing to a time scramble
and bob's your uncle there he is sitting
down adjusting the black pieces turning
his knights forward you all need to
adjust your schedules and head over cast
your vote before it's too late you can
actually do so before move 10 so that's
a fun thing to know in case you're
someone who wants to wait for the
openings to finish but there's cash
prizes on the line bragging rights with
your friends you can talk about things
and give you more of a reason to play
along and if you do get a get a perfect
day you get to tell people i guessed all
four games correctly today and they're
like okay you're in last place who cares
and that kind of thing so anyway take
take uh take a moment to head over and
cast your vote uh you don't want to wait
right right robert because if you wait
to move seven thinking that you might
sneak it in then the players blitz out
moves and now you've missed your chance
right yeah you have to be careful about
doing that but there is that point
around move seven move eight where
players really start to think and yeah
if we get the game that we saw yesterday
between car one and report they start
thinking as early as move five and we're
in for a new battle a new battle yonder
ponies a couple of blue jackets couple
look at did these guys coordinate their
dress code today
i'm calling uh like hey like you texted
him like hey man i'm thinking about
wearing a white a white uh dress shirt
with some blue pants and a blue jacket
you down
i mean i
i don't i don't want to move on from
this board it's like can we get a
spider-man meme on the uh on the
broadcast please or on maybe maybe
photoshop they're gonna start pointing
at each other like hey you meet you
anyway but when i wanted to say i love
danny's predictions because for once he
went against all his natural instincts
that may be the day that he actually can
win something you know every once in a
while i have to prove people that i can
put to people i can hold back um maybe
this guy
uh this guy needs to stop holding back
maybe you can get even more aggressive
alireza for russia looking for his first
win also with the white dress shirt and
the blue jacket
fabiano of course sporting the chess
club and scholastic center of st louis
black jacket
these guys are focused not a lot of
smiles at each other across the board
here robert yeah i mean these players
are locked in and they all are in their
own ways but you know these players in
particular i don't think that they're at
the point where they have this
blossoming friendship there's a huge age
difference but that does play a part in
chess sometimes it's really
uncomfortable to play certain opponents
because you've worked together or you've
played in the same league game or you
just you know have known each other for
a long time so having a friendship with
somebody can actually be uh really bad
for your chess game
now we have tamorba jabot and richard
report the jury's still out on how to
spell taymor we have
t-e-i-t-e-y behind it i mean
are we allowed to send our love by the
way because you mentioned you know saint
louis chess club and i wanted really uh
well to send all my love to
just complain to anybody on the
broadcast you know we can always send
love to mom and
everyone at home um hi grandma on
facebook you log into your third account
thank i'm glad you remembered your
password um
anyway tamora java and richard report a
battle of two very different styles and
now he karnaka moore versus dingley
render predicted a draw hicaro has a 1-0
lead against dingley brand in their
all-time career it is not for java
versus report we're all over that uh but
dingley wren almost won with black
yesterday so if he can if he can find
his mojo right
dr evil can give us mojo back robert
maybe maybe even he has a chance to
strike well i'm curious even how this
game's gonna start we see they just
shook hands the clocks have been pressed
and yeah dingley wren can beat anybody
with any color and yesterday he showed
some great
chess
until move 39-40 where he just made his
move 39th move then thought for five
minutes almost lost on time and then
kind of freaked out and made a mistake
but dingley ran he's going to be a new
player today uh he's got the black piece
in the car very difficult opponent
especially the confidence that hikaru
has in recent
times you know he's been winning every
single event online and also in person
he won the grand prix so
it's going to be interesting to see that
battle it's funny because i think ocaro
is a good example we've talked about the
community he has but the other word
confidence that he has right it doesn't
matter whether you're winning online or
over the board if you're feeling good
about your chess that translates across
platform as they say right and that's
one of the reasons maybe hicaro
continues to just play such high level
chess wow
yeah i was looking at the openings yeah
yeah big time switch up look at yonder
palmish in the bottom right he didn't
play e4
against duda so i'm talking with the
petrov and ceiling and he did play
catalan
style positions in the last candidates
right he beat carrillo alexianko in a
very nice game from the white side so
there is some history there but i'm also
looking at the top right danny so we'll
notice that in the both the bottom right
and the top right this move g3 by weisen
played so both players are fiancing
their bishops but this is farouza opting
for a
start a closed catalan we'll see how
fabiano takes this on here because he's
experienced in both colors he plays the
main line here we're going to start to
focus in a little bit for the first time
on one game which will be the farouza
caruana battle
not the not the sharpest variations with
d takes c4 on the board yet although
don't be surprised if bobby plays it i
guess later black already had the option
to do so here as one of the main lines
uh but
fabi castles farouza back on the clock
if avi going to take his first walk
big opening decision by farruja because
this is not an opening that just like
easy to play there's so many branches in
these cattlemen positions and a player
that we know magnus carlson in the world
championship but behind magnus carlson
is daniel dubov is his second one most
creative players that the chess world
has and he's shown that there's so many
different possibilities in this
variation and the main thing as you're
pointing out danny is that white gives
up this pawn on c4 in many positions and
doesn't necessarily aim to win it back
although alireza says i'm i'm going to
protect my pawn immediately so if you
take i get to recapture but you usually
give up a pawn for central control
although we're seeing a different trend
in this game i i backed it up just to
show yeah active just to show that
and we should we should pull up the
analysis board as soon as we can because
queen d3 if it's not if it's not a
novelty it
pretty close to it especially as far as
high level chess goes we'll get some
stats running in the background but it's
never even
it's been played two times according to
just our initial opening explorer we'll
run some deeper database searches to to
confirm but almira your thoughts on this
i mean i mean there's so many other
moves here castles knight c3 queen c2
knight bd2 and b3 all these moves have
been played literally hundreds and
hundreds of times but not queen to e3
yeah we've seen so many games in in the
catalan opening and i think that one of
the ideas behind the move queen d3
if
fabiana doesn't switch to the line with
d takes c4 then you simply play knight
c3 and e4 you prepare e4 immediately so
your c4 pawn is protected
so you don't play knight queen c2 or
knight c3 in order to play e4 so that
that might be the idea that's that's
really interesting i want to i want to
show what you're saying because
first of all if dtx c4 is played
that is that is just a direct
transposition to to a lot of the lines
so before we all freak out you can see
the eval bar switched from being on its
own to being in a position that uh is
back in the opening explorer so it goes
back to percentages but almeira's point
is if you play the queen to c2 and black
doesn't play dc4 it's harder to play
knight c3 in a lot of positions without
the complications of d take c4 because
the queen doesn't protect the pawn so
this the subtle idea of putting a queen
on this square
is to is to play knight c3 if i'm
translating correctly and i think that
uh
why
queen g3
well hasn't been played before for so
many times which is because the most
natural reaction would be to play b6 and
you're looking for this bishop a6 next
okay
robert what do you
think well there are a couple things b6
was one of the two moves that came to my
mind the other is the move c5
immediately because when i see someone
bring their queen out so early i want to
take advantage of that the reason why
beginners are told don't bring your
queen out is because when it's attacked
it has to move so let's say you take on
c5 here i'm not just going to take back
with my bishop i'm going to play knight
a6 and then when i gather that pawn
right back and i take c5 your queen has
to move so it's costing white some time
so that's why i'm looking at queen d3
like hmm this looks kind of suspicious
but there must be specifically some kind
of pawn structure change that alireza is
looking for for example if we go back to
the live position and play the move b6
after queen d3
um maybe there's something that c takes
d5 and alireza wants this type of
position where sure at some point bishop
a6 will come with the tempo even now but
that's not so important it's a closed
position so a single tempo doesn't
change the nature of the game its
entirety we get the structure where
instead of a symmetrical pawn structure
if we cut the board in half along the d
file white has an extra pawn towards the
king side black has an extra pawn
towards the queen side and so you get
this position where that bishop on c8
where's it really going does it have a
great diagonal sure a6 is fine to start
with but uh this kind of structure that
might be what alireza specifically is
looking for i was actually thinking you
know about our confession yesterday when
we were comparing chess to art and the
ideas this is actually one of the
perfect illustrations to
to this topic because queen d3 is
new subversive it's uh
it's a show it's showing a skeptical
approach you know to well all the
dogmatic you know uh ways that we
used to see chess and the positions but
on the other hand like if he will win
this game that's what you will call a
masterpiece and
you will call it
an art so queen d3 is a super rare move
it's only been played 17 games even even
in our most robust database where we
don't you know sometimes there's
different filters you have where you
only have games where both players are
about 2200 or you cut out some different
short draws but 17 games in our maxed
out database however it has been played
a couple times by strong players gelfin
and zhong have both played it jeffrey
john now a commentator for us regularly
on chess.com
uh it was also there was also an online
game between
dingley wren and anish geary where d lee
ren played this move so that that sounds
like where this uh opening might have
come to pleasure from well shout out to
the team thank you so much for that
little stat little nugget for the maybe
more advanced viewers out there kind of
curious
what ali reza might be trying to improve
on so maybe that's partly what bobby's
thinking about it's not just that the
move order surprised him but uh
maybe trying to recall what happened in
those games and
see what see what kind of position he
wants so i think he's surprised do you
think he's surprised yeah but what's
funny is there must be something that
ali reza
knows maybe fabi doesn't want in just
the main line because even if you're
surprised there is a bailout to just
take on c4 and you're in that a very
popular line right but maybe maybe they
they both know something we don't which
is that those lines are trending
positively for white or something so
bobby's like huh i don't really want to
bail out maybe he doesn't want to play
this particular line yeah exactly their
preferences right yeah and fabiano has
had some nice victories from the white
side of catalan positions where his
opponent has taken on c4 right and that
bishop on g2 it's clearly better than
his counterpart in ca and that's one of
the main dynamics of this opening so
that's something to keep in mind and
that's i think why fabinho is not taking
on c4 he's thinking do i play almira's
b6 does he do i play c5 just to strike
the center right away because this queen
move doesn't exactly help white in many
ways it puts the queen in a vulnerable
spot so it's just a very interesting
choice and we'll see how fabi eventually
responds all right well we'll back out
real quick uh we've uh we've kind of
laid the groundwork for the foundation
that will be a very interesting battle
between for rouge and caruana uh we're
gonna we're gonna bounce another game
first before we do is we take in the
bird's eye view all four games i want to
point out another fun stat
the pandashi has only played knight f3
and eight percent of his games in the
database and he has he has like more
than a thousand he's got a lot of games
that's not like you know someone who's
played 25 games so knight f3 i would
wonder if if judo was prepared for that
at all that's my point from yawn we of
course we were all talking about e4 from
the pawn to shield but okay let's head
over to reports battle because that
position already looks uh bananas
uh are we sure roger has the white piece
in this game i told you so
wow
okay there's you mentioned robert the
beginners aren't supposed to bring their
queens out too early um so and and rajab
is this old school classical very
technical
player what's going on here there's a
weird line well i think he knows these
positions very well because he plays it
from time to time and especially he went
for knight c6 on the move six i think
this is considered to be well among
other variations the lines which gives
white an advantage
so he went for a different structure and
fabbed it against richard airport and
this move queen d3 once we again but
with another idea that uh you will go to
the king side and provoke some
weaknesses
still playing very quickly too so very
surprised and the reason why i'm most
surprised is rejava typically doesn't
strike me as a player who likes forcing
variations he likes to build up his
advantage outplay people um when you
know he's going for that and right now
this is like a very force look at this
like queen d5 was just played which puts
pressure on the e5 pawn in addition to
protecting the knight so clearly rajubov
has studied some of the predecessors you
know maxine bashir lagrav has games in
this line and so i mean this is a very
dynamic position right now where bishop
d3 already looks very tempting just to
attack this knight on e4 we like
advanced pieces but sometimes pieces go
a little bit too far and they're easy to
kick around and it should be three looks
like the start of a plan to go after
that knight you mentioned maxine by she
the grave plays this line is white this
game is still actually following the
game mvl versus napon rishi from croatia
rapid 2021 let's back up and show the
opening just because we don't we jumped
right into the
the nuttiness let's just show how we got
here it was a sicilian a time on off to
be exact knight c3 a6 uh we saw report
played this just yesterday against
fabiano remember carwana took a while
and then played the move order g4 if you
didn't tune into round five shame on you
but okay we forgive you thanks for being
here we love you okay knight takes c6 b
takes c6 instead of what fabiano did
queen d3 this move is in increasingly
popular yeah and magnus carlson himself
has chosen this line it gives white a
good deal of flexibility because where
that white king goes isn't abundantly
clear at the start you can cast a queen
side but you've opened the b file so
castle and queen side may walk into a
potential attack with some open lines of
course black with taunton c6 and e6 aims
to play the strike d5 just to gain space
in the center that's not the end of the
story as you know we'll see in this game
but also this idea of queen sliding the
g3 is important in many positions just
to keep that bishop out of fate honest
stuck to that pawn on g7 well we saw
that already happened in the game after
d5 queen h3 h5 h4 so this is all again
we already established this is theory
yeah you're you're countryman maxine
bachelor i see you nodding over there
plays these positions as white
d4 knight to b1
this is
i want also to underline that it's very
important to play knight b1 here yeah
let's talk about that go ahead if the
knight goes anywhere else well you can
see that it's deprived of well
many possibilities while when it goes to
b1 then you have a very natural maneuver
of plane knight d2 knight c4 or knight
f3
knight g5 at some point so
it's uh it's very important to play
knight b1 in this position it's funny
because it feels like you're
undeveloping but you're actually in a
much better spot here uh precisely
because as you said the knight on d1
just puts itself into a spot where he's
controlled by a pawn three squares away
as robert has often likes to point out
i don't know if you guys know robert
house
he's a friend of mine
i do think it's important to visualize
where your pieces need to go or what
squares are ideal for them and so almira
pointing out the c4 square you know
people think a bishop goes in c4 right
that's always where we go no here the
knight is so perfectly plays in c4 can't
be kicked out of that square knights
like outposts yep i think that yeah
stainless said that give me a knight on
the sixth rank and i will win any game
yeah
and then here you go knight g2 94 96
yeah he was prone to exaggerated
but it is a good point and i like the
instructor point that you said uh robert
that it's it's about where your pieces
need to go right i think sometimes when
people look at positions like this if
you didn't know the opening you would
just dismiss a move that undevelops on
principle right but if you think about
how a structure has changed precisely
because black is overextended that's
when you recognize the goal right so
when you have a goal you can make a move
like this because you have a future and
uh that's exactly what white's trying to
do this is as we said though all theory
queen of three queen d5 bishop d3 and
bishop b4 check on the board uh rapport
is is still at the board even though
it's it's not his move he's just
thinking hard and
tamor i can't tell if he's there or not
but yeah he's out so he's gonna play
king f1 he's not castling this game
after bishop before check he's going to
move his king i don't know if it's f1 or
e2 but the point is that knight on e4 is
now under attack and if you just move
your knight away like knight c5 i guess
it's the only square i don't even want
to trade queens i want to go back to g3
because the g7 pawn is loose and you
this looks just absolutely berserk like
what is white doing you haven't castled
you're not developing your pieces but at
the end of the sequence after you know
even taking on d3 at some point you have
a oh my gosh you just played f5 yeah he
played it right away they they are both
clearly this is buckle up everybody
something is something is about to
happen here that surprises the other in
terms of prep and we'll probably know
the moment it does because one of them
will start slowing down
but they are both clearly pulling on
information that they cooked up in the
home kitchen
wow and you were talking about the
lyrica ferruga how different well player
he is probably now than he was but maybe
the same is true now for taymor you know
maybe uh these five round five rounds of
the candidates show that well he needs
to change something yeah so here it is
i have not hasn't won a classical game
in three years so if that's not like a
memo that you need to change something
if you're gonna get a victory i don't
know what it is i was gonna say i don't
think i've seen him a job of this
aggressive since 2019 when he won the
world cup yeah and look at this game
there's a king on d7 like that king just
walked out into what would seem like the
open but the position is closed and
something that's about to happen there's
a queen stare down here and a lot of
people would think i don't want black to
take me on f3 because that doubles and
isolates my pawns but actually the g
file being open is really nice for white
so i believe that timor will allow the
queen trade on f3 even though that looks
counterintuitive because of the opening
of the fight anytime they're double
pawns they're open files the rook on h1
will gladly slide to the g file and that
g7 pawn surprisingly gonna be difficult
to defend plus another idea would be
that you you would never want to trade
here if you were white and help
blackbring upon either pawn to the
square because that again would really
limit the future of white's knight
bringing a knight to d2 is probably an
option here and so in this situation you
have both c4 if the queen were to move
as well as b3
trying to develop within the current
structure is likely what white's going
to do here not not look to change it
there's also c3 like if you c3 also yeah
if you don't mind the queen capture on
f3 because i mean if we just put the
resulting queenless position quickly
this looks really weird and not good for
white but you actually see the eval
saying that white's like half a pawn
better because that king on d7 is not
well placed the g file being open very
nice for white and so black's pawn
structure is not really better than
whites despite having those double
isolated pawns
well two games have been looked at both
games were exciting we're gonna back up
and make sure we touch on all four
before we get through this first hour as
we always do we want to make sure that
we understand
uh the uh the starting point so that as
the story of each game develops we know
how we got there and
we can follow along with the journey so
let's choose a different adventure
nakamura dingley ren and napashi duda
have both not been looked at um
let's have a look
yeah let's do let's do an apology dude
especially because i want to correct a
stat i said earlier i said that only
eight percent of uh nepo's games were
knight of three it's actually only eight
percent in the last three years okay so
the the search was just for the last
three years still basically the same
thing he's played e4 78 of the time in
the last three years i would say that's
that's more important yeah it's even
more important if you say somebody's
played uh knight f3 fifty percent of the
time but they haven't played it they've
played 20 in your career it's yeah
exactly it's not that important but he
has not played it in recent times but he
has shown me plays on occasion and he
plays it well so i mean where 9 moves in
and it's duda who spent a little bit
more time maybe a little bit of a
practical surprise it's funny because
nobody here talked about what if yon
plays anything but e4 we were debating
what we'll do to do against e4 it was a
foregone conclusion but not so fast as
nepo well but he goes for the ratio
opening from time to time and i wanted
to come back to
the move to the fourth move knight g7
okay to show a small difference because
here of course h3 is a very precise move
h3 bishop h5 oops sorry
h3 bishop h5 yes because at some point
you will you also want to play if you
play with d3 you play g4 and knight h4
and you want to take this bishop
that does uh duda starts with knight d7
so he doesn't allow you know this
maneuver it's also he tries he's trying
to avoid some
some variations in this line and you can
even go after d3 uh f4 queen of one
knight h4 and try to win this bishop you
know
very strange
so like if black already plays knight f6
for example you're saying h3 bishop h5
g4 will and here white might have both
95 or 94 but you well you can still play
d3 these refers to guard e4
and then when i teach four f4 you know
some okay crazy ideas
so judah plays knight d7
yawn still plays h3 but now giving up on
a traditional sort of king's indian
attack structure if you will often in
these positions you see d3 and white
plays for c4 or even e4 but here plays
d4 going back into a double queens pawn
transposition
knight gf6 c4
it's a
semi-slav structure now with the bishop
outside of the pawn chain and we should
point out that d-tix c4 was possible but
just like in the game between farouza
and caruana we're talking about the
promise of the bishop on g2 and that
pawn on c4 is not going to be on the
board for very long so yeah this is like
the worst possible scenario bishop is
better on h5 and c8 but your queen side
will be in trouble in these positions
it's funny how what you just said is
really clear i think that's an
instructive takeaway for for viewers
because the bishop itself is better
right but you have more on the board
than just a single piece of feelings to
worry about right so the bishop feels
better about his life but the light
squares on the queen side without this
bishop are often the main target for the
catalan beast on g2 so i think that's a
really important thing to understand
about your pieces being a part of a
greater formation a greater purpose than
just an active spot and so that's why
you don't take on c4
c6 instead but one of the most important
things in this opening as well is that
you very often you would sacrifice upon
because you are striving to have a very
strong center so
in this variation actually after c takes
d5 uh it takes d5 one of the white's
main ideas is to play knight c3 rookie
one and e4 yeah
yeah i was only back included because i
was gonna i was gonna double down on
your point that if d takes c4 happens in
addition to getting the pawn back and
the bishop white is also eventually
going to get a big center which is a
typical problem but of course yeah great
point that in this structure
white's going to play for e4
and black just had a pretty interesting
decision and e takes d5 is not forced
right you keep taking with the c pawn
because you want to control the center
uh but the problem for black is this
knight's already on d7 that knight is
dominated by the pawn from three scores
away you mentioned that i loved him
you're gonna say it i stole your thunder
you did but it's true and white very
quickly plays movies like knight c3
queen b3 bishop f4 rook c1 all of these
moves come in uh and very with force
because you have to watch out for knight
coming to b5 and the b7 pawn and rook
taking over the c file and the white
king is castled the black king is not
and white is going to be ahead in
development so that kind of scenario
could be very difficult for black to
deal with so that's why i took with the
e pawn but i love nepo's response of
knight to e5 because
not only are you galloping forward into
the center f4 g4 and that bishop on h5
that we were happy about being outside
the pawn chain
that bishop could get trapped if you're
not careful
i love that that's why the move orders
are so important this is a very precise
move order so nepal only played d4 after
black played 97 and after c4 c takes d5
of course uh what robert says said that
knight is on d7
sort of a very strange slav you know
with the bishop which is out but
white's play is
very simple in this position there are a
lot of natural moves here i love it
the uh i'm starting to wonder whether or
not this is the kind of thing that maybe
jan
thought about playing against magnus
carlsen in dubai or just for whatever
reason never went for this is different
than what we've seen from him as we said
78 of the time in the last three years
he's an e-4 player right but he's
playing it incredibly well you both just
did such a great job of pointing out the
little details that meet the eye
especially waiting to take on d5 until
after the knight is on d7 this is how
you you get an advantage right even
against
the world's best players like a young
christian christophe dude i have to give
props to jan and pam she's team of
seconds yeah you know himself of course
he when you work with a team of seconds
you know ultimately you make the call of
what you're going to play but if they
said against duda let's not worry about
the sicilian let's let's not worry about
the petrol if he plays e5 let's go for
something that gives you a stable plus
where you don't feel like you're on edge
and you were saying how jana pomshi
doesn't need an invitation to play
aggressive chess and to go for attacking
lines and sometimes he goes a little bit
too far how is he going to go too far
here right it's a very solid foundation
he's done nothing out of the ordinary in
fact he's played just good move after
good move principal chess and it's
leading him to a position where i really
like his chances because
even making a single move here for black
isn't easy if i were at the board
playing against yonder palm tree i think
well i want to develop my dark square
bishop but i see that f4 is about to
come to reinforce that knight and then
g4 is going to come and my bishop on h5
might get trapped so i'm already looking
at this position as one that's not easy
for black to play it's only move nine
but this move is really important yeah i
also
wanted to say something about
narrowing down down
how they narrow down their the
preparation because you know the
spectrum of young schistos do this
opening with black against e4 is um much
larger so not only will they have to
worry about the sicilian or the petrol
but there is also karakan sometimes a
few other openings so i think that's
exactly what uh jan's team did and i
really loved robert's comment it's a
great point and i'll add one more just
in thinking that young christoph isn't
the youngest player in the field but
he's one of the youngest right and we
know that sometimes the way that even 2
800 players despite how strong they are
they're young and that they haven't
played as many openings you said ferrous
is still becoming the player he'll be
and i think john christoph too and
sometimes it's the wrong approach
against a younger opponent to go with
the theory you know that they've played
and spent more time with than anything
else right like a petrov or a night or
playing things that are slightly obscure
right to maybe trick them in terms of
transpositions and move orders is often
it's what was done to me when i was
younger by players and i know it's a
thing regardless of how good young
christoph duda is it's often a strategy
but all right we just talked about some
ways that young christoph might go wrong
we just said that despite how good young
christoph duda is but he is very good
and let's remind everybody of how he got
here how he became poland's number one
in our next chess.com player profile
although saddled with the lowest rating
in the field janukshistov duda has been
playing well heading into the candidates
the 24 year old from poland also brings
a solid record against magnus carlson
should duda manage to win it all here in
madrid and challenge for the world title
the second youngest player in the field
duda defeated carlson at the feed a
world cup to secure his bid here at the
candidates
i think he must have resigned yep
it's over jan christoph duda beats
magnus with black in the tiebreaker what
a performance
duda enters the candidates with some
steam recently taking both the oslo
esports cup and the grand chess tour in
poland
his success against carlson makes duda a
pretty interesting story to watch
especially should he get through madrid
amongst his triumphs duda stopped
carlson's
125 game undefeated streak two years ago
in norway
he also beat carlson in his world cup
victory that punched his ticket to spain
with some momentum and big match
experience duda is looking to become the
first player from poland to challenge
for the world chess championship
time will tell if he can pull it off
[Music]
time will tell
not just in young christophe dude's
career but in this game here how how
comfortable he feels in this very
interesting choice from janupombashi
that we've been applauding uh as we said
coming in though he's been a tough nut
to crack so even if john gets an
advantage we'll see if he can convert it
duda has not lost so far in his
candidate's debut and then he gets white
in the next round versus nakamura so
speaking of that man it's the last game
we haven't touched on yet we need to
back out and get to that game because
hikaru nakamura's position
right now versus dingley brand uh is an
interesting one it's it's a little bit
of a of a repeat we have to start with
the fact that they repeated the opening
from round two in this event where duda
was white against dingley ren
the novelty came on move
queen to a7 was not what ding played in
that round two battle versus young
christopher but okay regardless of that
small shuffle the structure and the
thing that people were applauding
dingley run for this really interesting
position that we got with the closed
center and eventually the long-term
relocation we'll see if we get some sort
of deep maneuvering by dean lemon in
this game as well
no no all i wanted is to point out that
here we have a completely different
structure there you have the maruti bind
uh and especially in this game ding
opted for d5 hmm instead of c5 it's a
very important change in this position
here
in black strategy
yeah and it's also just interesting that
dingley wren would repeat exactly what
he had in the previous game because this
rook a3 move played before that he
chooses queen a7 which is undoubtedly
the top engine line right there's a
reason why dingler and deviated and is
because he found the better move
according to the computers but
hikaru nakamura throughout his career
has had chris littlejohn as his main
second who goes through all the engine
lines and looks at what might be a
playable and strong opening so we know
that chris as soon as he saw that round
two game you know you look at your next
opponents for sure but you're looking
ahead can i use this against dingley ren
and as we continue down this variation
queen a7 makes perfect sense you're
aiming at the d4 pawn and behind it
towards the king on f2 and beyond so uh
the move knight f1 makes perfect sense
defending d5 e5 and knight e4 so this is
where things are getting really
interesting because this pawn d4 is kind
of a target stuck in place and a way to
defend it is bishop to e3 at some point
but just like in the game between the
job and report look at that b file right
they're double pawns for black but that
means there's an open file so at some
moment using the b file is what ding
will want c6 to c5 also looks like it's
in the cards and from white's
perspective i would love to play knight
g3 and if you take on g3 play rook a3
jumps overnight to take back right i
want that rook lift that's not a legal
thing to do robert
can't jump over your pieces come on well
let me let me try it but that's the
essential point that that rook on a3
would love to participate in the king
side and if i'm being honest i don't
love the foundation of white's position
like i feel like in the long term things
could get problematic but in the current
dynamic with that king and jake feeling
a little bit lonely i could see a future
where hikaru just goes after the king
side
do you think he was inspired by yan zero
k3 against favi you know yeah rook left
rick
it's uh
it's a great game to remember not a bad
idea although icaru has already moved in
this position as we see he brought the
knight back to d2 rather than g3
probably because like you robert he
fantasized about the idea that a rook
could hop over a knight realize that's
not the rule so instead of going knight
g3 plays the move knight one back to d2
where we stand
again i want to go back to elmira's
point while we're analyzing that the c5
structure not going to be something we
get here because we're already in a very
different game thing played d5 so both
of your points were kind of adding right
obviously chris little john hey carl
look at this game hey let's go back for
this line the ding played against duda
maybe hikaru was packing some some
gunpowder to this game right a little
bit not in his wallet don't worry they
checked his wallet no gunpowder
nicaragua's wallet but no but seriously
packing some ideas to maybe improve on
dude's play and as good players do
dingley wren tries to improve on his own
play first before someone can catch him
in any kind of line right there was a
really nice game that hit car won
against magnus carlsen the champion's
chess tour yeah where it was a position
where the engine initially says this
isn't that good for white and you know
you just kind of let the position sit
and you look at it and it just becomes
hard for a player to make a move and
we're about to see this because what it
caro has done here after knight to d2 is
saying if you take me on d2 i'm gonna
take back with the queen presumably
because i want to keep my d4 pawn look
at this bishop on b6 queen on a7 i want
to attack i want to play the move c5 but
c5 i don't think is a viable option
because you
if you put the move on the board here
it's a situation where no no you're not
laying that bishop out that the whole
point is look at the king side now i'm
going to go knight h4 then i'm gonna go
rook g3 and that rook lift that i was
you know clamoring for rook takes g7
queen takes h6 all this stuff
and that king is in grave danger
that's a great line just if some random
okay you can't play a random move
because queen's threading h6 but just to
show how bad is even if you move the
king here comes the sack as robert was
saying let's check mate because you
cannot stop mate after bishop g5 and
bishop f6 so you just you don't you
don't let the queen side pieces out of
the box that is what a car is aiming for
which is why ding does not want to take
on d2 this is actually a very clear
illustration showing that i don't want
to allow hikaru to easily
keep these pieces locked in the queen
and the bishop so if we just go back
before knight takes d2 what ding ideally
want is to play bishop f5 so that when
you take on e4 and i take back now i'm
getting after your knight on f3 and
finally my queen and bishop yeah hitting
that d especially if you take this way
now i now i have a real problem okay
yeah that makes sense that's such a
great point by robert i and i just
wanted to add a small thing because when
you're thinking about taking an
initiative or launching an attack a very
simple thing would be you simply count
how many attackers do you have and how
many defensive pieces you have there so
here you have this bishop on b6 screen
on a7 volcano eight so you just count
knight on f3 probably on a3 bishop on c1
queen d2 here you go you have all the
premises of a very successful attack
yeah
it shows you black is sort of all in on
the fact that
that what you just said is not going to
happen right because if anything like
that happens where these pieces are are
on the other side of the board and the
script flips to this side it could be
over in a miniature fashion right so
that's
really interesting to see
what being placed here because like what
you said in young chris of duda's
approach is black this might already be
a very critical moment for dingley run
and we were joking right you know robert
you can't bring your rook to g3 but we
want to think about what i call
realistic dream squares that g3 square
is the dream for my rook and it's not
realistic with a knight in the way but
that's why once that knight clears the
third rank we go for the attack and
honestly if i had this position i would
even think about just leaving my knight
on e4 so if you take and i take back on
e4 with my pawn i may lose a pawn in
that variation but at least i have
you're showing bishop d5 rook d8 i'm go
i'm i have a target so often the way to
deal with an impending attack is to
target a different part of the board to
essentially distract the enemy forces so
if i can play in the center white will
have to tend to that center i can't just
go knight h4 and go for the king side so
i do think that this is a really
critical moment and i'm sure hicaro has
more and we see that dingland did just
play bishop f5 so he survived the first
i'd say real challenge of this game but
this is not over right this isn't just
oh i played bishop f5 i'm okay it's like
well what's going to happen from here
well the most dramatic response
especially after d5 the most magic plan
here for black is to play c5 you don't
have to take on d2 of course in any case
you have to play c5 then take on d4 and
you use your second c phone wow rookie
two that
is an interesting move he's preventing
the fact that he played it so fast has
ding
thinking how much prep did hikaro bring
to the table here right now you already
mentioned carlson uh
nakamura winning a game not not exactly
in the structure i remember the game you
were talking about it was a position
where it seemed equal for a long time
but hikaru's
depth of understanding of the type of
ideas that were going to occur for white
ultimately paid off with a rare loss for
the norwegian final boss
hashtag rhyme time right in magnus
carlsen so this is this doesn't look
great for dingley ren we see him down
almost 30 minutes on the clock
hikaru
doing what hikaru does playing moves
quickly when he knows what to do rookie
too i mean that's a move there's no way
that's not prepared you know that is
yeah i mean look how quickly he's
playing it's 100 preparation but rookie
2 just seems so strange in front of your
queen and the question is what does that
rook really do there like what is the
benefit of having the rook on e2 bishop
takes d4 everybody is not possible yeah
let's show it real quick because you
take your first you take on e4 you open
up the queen to the bishop on d4 and
then at the end of this after rook d8
this is the importance of the rookie 2
you've rooked d2 so you protect your
knight and block the pin at the same
time so rookie two
stops black from ever taking on d4 so
it's one of those clever moves and
the real question that in the game is
revolve around this move black c5 so i
would imagine c5 is still not possible
because if it was possible it just looks
really good for black and as we see here
knight h4 now comes the tempo then we
have the same exact attack knight takes
e4 rook g3 and so on oh you see
something robert because of course
aruconi 2 protects on f2 but in case uh
you would play let's say knight h4 here
is rook e5 possible if the rook would be
on e1 interesting question i mean just
because
just
knight h4 of course the g4 is but this
is possible
it looks spicy
but then there is something
that we don't see you know i just want
to show the idea of what we figured out
because that's a really great idea by
elmira you take here obviously if white
takes the bishop the whole point is the
rook was protecting the bishop
uh if you take here the idea was bishop
takes f2 check and i don't even know
what you would do next but you might
just take the knight and say i've got
tons of compensation here the dark
squares are an absolute train wreck so
the computer's saying not so fast you
human beings there's a win for white but
i love your move so forget the computer
element that is just
i love rookie fun
what what is the move though jokes aside
we have to figure it out um
there's so many pieces hanging there has
to be d2 to f3 looks pretty good
okay
and if the rook moves you know you win
the knight yeah that does look like
still very good for weapon not the
optimal move but still good enough to
show that it's a little too
on pre right the pieces are all on bad
squares it's in there i was thinking can
i just take with the knight though
because if you take with the rook i take
here oh i take with the bishop on e4
okay and i still can't take
wow what a yeah rook 65 was not on my
radar but it's a good thing to point out
because at some point this queen and
bishop
they're lining up towards well it also
shows another sort of subtle
prophylactic purpose of rookie two right
it wasn't just a move that stops bishop
takes d4 over protecting this pawn on f2
might be tactically threatening knight
h4 suddenly this move is immediately at
least open for consideration right we
know that it comes with risk
but robert has pointed out how dangerous
those ideas are that if again i don't
know if it works i'm just pointing out
that if if something happened to allow
the rook to come to g3 and there were
threats like this and
white's piece is coming to life here it
doesn't work as black it's just crashing
through too quickly but that very quick
flipping of the pieces to this side of
the board could be absolutely nasty for
dingley rice but what you just showed
about why it doesn't work it's a really
good illustration of the point i was
talking about that when someone's trying
to attack you if you can attack
somewhere else yeah it's hard to go all
in to bring all your pieces to king side
if your whole center is collapsing so
rookie two is a really good move knight
h4 comes with tempo and that's going to
be annoying for black in many positions
so i could see an argument for rook a to
d8 that move that you just point out
kind of your little flip in but you're
like oh let's do it it actually looks
like a decent move and another idea is
at some point just tuck my bishop away
like hide it on a square like h7 so
knight h4 never comes with the tempo and
that way it takes one more turn for you
to launch that attack while my bishop is
safe and sound near my king most of the
good moves i played in my career were
rather flippant without what i thought
so but
this move
proves that hikaru is going for the kill
yeah oh yeah well
ricardo had a has a plus one score
against england coming in not enough
games to really draw any major
conclusions but at least enough to say
that hikaru has no reason to be
uh to lack confidence in this battle
versus dingley wren right and he does
have the white pieces he knows he's
playing well
let john off the hook yesterday but
let's back up again and just take a look
at where all four boards sit what the
time situation is in each particular
battle
this is a
beautiful little multi-colored board
scene it's kind of like candy it's like
edible like what flavor do you like you
like cherry do you like blueberry you've
got that made up flavored circle k which
is like root beer and dr pepper in the
corner there are three things i want to
point out and they're not actually on
the board okay look at the clock top
left for
half an hour for report dingly red half
an hour for hikaru duda half an hour
right so these three players rajab of
dingley red and yanches of duda they're
spending a lot of time whereas the
karwana farouza yeah already has 10
minutes more but he's the white pieces
that's pretty standard but there's a
widening gap on the clocks in those
three games and shown great preparation
by the players and rajab in particular
like he kind of volunteered to get to
that line yeah and now he's frozen
because he's out of his prep like this
is clear that he had his prep to this
moment and then he's like uh oh i don't
remember what i'm supposed to do here i
think i mean we could choose between
that game as well as the ferruga caruana
game but i'm with you we got we got raja
on camera that looks like a spicier
battle we'll catch up with what's going
on between one of the youngest players
and one of the most experienced in
perugian car one in a bit so back back
to where java report we go
uh and
bishop g6 king d7 okay he's been
thinking for 20 minutes since we left
25. actually i wanted to ask robert
does he find the square d7 a little bit
artificial and that's why uh taymor is
puzzled because maybe king d8 you know
it's possible with the same idea
interesting so you think that you're
usually wondering he wasn't expecting
king to d7 and now he's like okay maybe
i should change my plan
what is the difference between king d8
and king d7
that's a very good question i mean okay
so usually we just start with the
literal differences it blocks the bishop
right it also puts the king on a
diagonal where maybe
you think about tactics
but it also develops faster right the
rooks are connected the moment the
bishop develops so
sorry i was doing what i would ask i'm
the weakest chess player here that's how
i was i was doing what a student should
do and that's true often when someone
plays a move you don't expect it
actually really is a good critical
thinking muscle to develop before you
try to decide is that move good or bad
which is really an abstract subjective
evaluation you should start with i was
literally expecting this they played
this let's unpack the differences and
see if there's an opportunity right yeah
and he just played bishop g5 but and
apparently that's not the best move so
you predicted report would win this game
your prediction
off to a pretty decent start but yeah
king d7 and then bishop g5 so
is there something
something feels wrong here something
feels really off i mean rajab was
playing so quickly and then k7 happened
so if we go back to that moment if we
just actually put that on the board
danny yeah where like let's say king to
d8 was played maybe bishop g5 was his
preparation yeah
directly attacks and black can play rook
f8 just like in the game but
unlike in the game
here the knight would not be able to
move because it's pinned whereas in the
game knight g4 is already right
goodness i found it because you coached
me to it coach which was that the knight
was pinned and that allows bishop e4 so
but what did we say before we left we
said these two were playing so fast we
were all getting kind of excited on the
spiciness of f5 but we called it then we
said hey at some point one of these
players is going to go into the think
tank and that's going to tell us all we
need to know and it looks like report is
the person bringing a little more ideas
to the table here almira with this king
d7 that surprised for java dania look at
how unbalanced this position was before
uh well it still is but before timor
played bishop g5 yeah he still has the
rook on a1 the knight on b1 the bishop
on c1 the king and f1 rook and h1 is
like only two pieces developed and uh
richard has a great center i love this
uh well his
the center's potential you know
it's an avalanche of the bounce and if i
will be able to move e5 e4 that's why
actually uh black shouldn't take on f3
because uh
black should keep this possibility
in the position
uh
well richard will be unstoppable wow
yeah i mean i like it i was suggesting
c3 there and said yeah it just looked
like it helps that queen side
development that's lacking and we're
never afraid of queen takes f3 i mean i
just i i think your idea was probably
the best in hindsight opening the g file
okay we'll help we have the eval bar off
to the side we always like to mention
that it's much easier to play when you
know the evaluation whereas after king
of d7 i'm guessing which i've knew was
better for him because he went into this
line very quickly which means he looked
at it with a engine and if that wasn't
the first move he looked at that means
the second move which means it's still
better for white but here after bishop
g5 i think black's play gets much easier
like rook f8 is a very natural response
as you point out there's no bishop e4
because the knight on f6 isn't pinned
and rook f8 not only defends the knight
in f6 it puts immediate pressure down
the f5 where knight g4
could be as a tremendous threat
that shirt is tremendous from richard
report by the way apparently the feed a
dress code as long as you wear a jacket
you can wear hawaiian casual friday
shirt under it so um
but uh yeah zoom in on that thing that's
something he stole out of grandpa's
closet fashionable both in the 70s and
now
well no we're talking about defense i
think that players are using now the
backdoor entrance because there are a
lot of hysteric fans waiting for them
you know like beetles
well just last night when i was walking
up from dinner
this young woman stopped me i was
walking with dina uh bill and kai and
dina
and dina kind of like turns around and
there's just someone who is a fan of
dinos and actually came to madrid from
another city in spain just for today's
candidates so wow there are a lot of
fans out there um and just we stumble
into one no one's recognized us yet
though yeah no this is all dina tina the
streamers the streamers are the rock
stars of the chess world dina bell and
kaya karnakamoroso anyway um all right
this is this is fascinating i'm not just
hoping report wins so that i go four for
four in my guests to move uh but no i'm
not i i i think this is the kind of
battle that you you preface what would
we get a technical
battle right of of uh not necessarily
anything dry but you know real accuracy
required with some grind it out or would
we get a slugfest i think we would we
would take report in a game like this
against for java yes although i i do
want to say one thing i was just saying
look at fate because it looked very
natural but i'm now realizing that that
could cost
black a pawn so moving the rook away
from the h-pawn let's say we take on d5
in a situation like this i mean that h5
pawn likely can be captured so we can
see here that okay it's terrible for
black that's nice
assuming for white of course it's
terrible for white so don't go for that
pawn but the player is they need to
calculate they don't have the engine
eval off the side saying ah that doesn't
work so don't worry about it shows the
importance of the center of the central
bones yeah yeah this is i don't even see
you don't have to see a concrete mover
for black you just this feels like
certain variations of the night earth
that are used to play and some of the
bishop g5 knight c6 knights were like
black is down a pawn but has the bishop
pair in these dominant structures where
it's just
you you feel like black is just winning
the game right this is just like yeah
like black is so yeah
sometimes if you if you can make an
analogy also with the kalashnikov
sicilian yellow you sacrifice or
swashnikov you know we sacrifice your
viewpoints even your apron and you have
this powerful center yeah and you see i
mean at this point white's not even
developed the knight can't get out with
any if you play c3 you put the bishop on
a diagonal or maybe you have other
tactical problems
so i mean just like
we get it's it's black to move which
makes it even better i wasn't thinking
about that i mean anything like bishop
b7 e5
so many easy moves for black to play
here so all right we're probably not
going to get that type of end game but
it is important to point out why you
shouldn't go for that one yeah and also
point out why report isn't immediately
playing rook fade because it's a very
like natural move yeah just bring your
rook to a semi-open file but there is a
pawn h5 that you might have to look out
for so he's just going to be checking
his calculation instead of just assuming
that it's good
okay
oh well let's back up again all four
games are looking exciting um
i know we say that at this stage of our
coverage pretty much every day in the
round and we're not lying every day we
are excited we're lucky we love what we
do and it's fun to see what the players
bring to the table even if uh even if
some of the games eventually i would
argue a draw is perfect chess so let's
let's change the story line right um but
don't look at me like that well
yesterday's game between caruana and
reports of greg that was a great example
that was a hard fought draw that wasn't
just we don't want to play today that
was like we're both going for it and the
way it happened was a repetition with
the bishop chasing the queen so yeah
oftentimes great chess ends in a split
point that doesn't mean the games are
not exciting in fact that game was more
exciting than some of the decisive
results we've had
i i feel like we should go back to
perugia garwana because we started the
day with that and and so just in terms
of how we normally rotate but i will
admit it it hasn't had a lot of progress
um we'll check in on just a few moves
when played napomneshi and duda as well
as nakamura and dingley wren i feel like
are getting us close to some potential
action given that there's a half an hour
advantage for both players playing white
there and i also like
both positions for the for the players
playing white although although the
dingley one is a mess so all right okay
we're going to go to puja
caruana
and um
and where do we stand well even though
they're still in the opening uh phase i
i feel that already this position is um
very important because uh here if russia
is faced with a dilemma should he give
us give up his bishop and go for the
position or with an isolated pound but
a
very good chance he has very good
chances of winning it and also
uh this is a very interesting uh
positional idea you give up this bishop
but you play then on dark squares with
your knight and your bishop you play
knight c3 maybe knight e4 or you simply
uh you can try to exchange the dark
square bishops and this will be a much
better position for it much easier
position for white to play
so let's let's look at that so
even right now is this already a move
that white can consider is that what
you're saying
yeah and the idea would be like if an
end game occurs
you're playing on the dark squares
you're
you're playing knight like bishop out
you're trying to play against the
isolated pawn was this sort of the theme
you were saying
exactly maybe it doesn't work
immediately you know that's why fuddy is
feeling so confident he stood up
immediately and maybe white
will even have to deal with a middle
game where i think there's an important
inclusion that after bishop takes d5
black can play bishop f6 first
and that that bishop wants to be there
whether the queens get traded on d5 or
not yeah and that means knight c3
won't really be a possibility and you
protect the d4 square you always want to
protect the square in front of your
isolated pawn so i mean
this changes everything actually yeah
that makes it better for black the other
is just fine for black but what i was
going to say is if we just actually go
back like two moves right here after cd5
um and if he wants to avoid isolated
pawn altogether he could have played
knight to b4 and take it on d5 with his
knight and that way there never would be
this possibility for white to saddle
black with an isolated pawn uh we just
showed why the iceland pawn situation
isn't a problem to begin with but here
this actually is an issue because your
knights for black are fighting for the
same squares the bishop on g2 is very
powerful e4 at some point will come with
a tempo and then maybe even e5 to follow
a rook to d1 so white just feels a
little bit more coordinated even though
the queen side isn't developed so i like
what fabiano did in this game starting
when he went c5 and then just starting
to trade pieces like this i think he has
a good handle of the position
you called it you said the move you were
considering on queen d3 was c5 almost
like you know fabiano so well
you know maybe he prepared this
variation that would be the stupidest
bleeping bleep i'd ever heard
robert has preparing fabiano caruana no
um
okay but no it's a it's a principal
thing to do right because you said when
the queen comes out early let's get her
more in the mix because then every piece
you develop comes with tempo because
you're attacking the most powerful
piece on the board so this is where we
left it everyone we didn't know what
fabi was going to play he played c5 we
saw the trade
and then after knight c6 and cd we just
looked at the line to avoid the isolated
pawn if you want but actually this is a
more
straightforward thing to do because
getting a pair of knights off the board
is much better than those two nights of
wrestling for the square and i'd argue
this is not an alireza frigid type of
position like even if there's a small
little advantage for white this is not
what we're used to seeing him turning
this kind of edge into a win actually
his game yesterday against duda became
quite like sharp at some point right
when white had the d-pawn and black had
the two queen-side pawns but here this
is completely symmetrical if you try to
make it a position that's not
symmetrical we just showed that's gonna
be good for black so i think faviano has
zero problems a very successful game
from the black side for him thus far
robert i think
one important thing about this position
that we should mention is also that why
shouldn't russian play e4 you know to
close the bishop this is uh this
this is not easy to understand because
you want to play e4
and to chase away this knight but
actually positionally this would be
considered the mistake
yeah nice night before is looking
there's also knight f4 funnily enough
it's a it's a tactic regardless
regardless of the detection
first yeah and then you just take on d8
but this is the essential point right
that white
doesn't control many of the squares this
actually is kind of like the java game
against dingley run yesterday where
you know it looks like white has
impressive pawns but black controls all
the squares so regardless if we can put
the tactic back into a knight b4 like a
normal human being um but the the c2
square as you're pointing out just to
control the c5 once the bishop moves out
from
c8 i mean black is better developed and
has great control of squares and the
pawn structure right for black f7 e6
nice and tidy whereas white this e4 pawn
leaves behind some squares like d3 in
addition to c2 and you're also
you close to your own bishop i was just
going to say one of the other common
themes in the catalan is you really
don't want to put this pawn in front of
your own bishop unless it's coming to e5
with purpose right it comes to e4 to go
to e5 immediately whether it's attacking
a knight or opening up lines but this is
exactly the opposite kind of structure
that white would want in a catalan the
uh but then what should we consider
because the most natural knight c3 is
probably met with robert's bishop of six
yep
knight c3 bishop of six
this
to my eyes looks like a whole lot of
nothing from whites person maybe a small
little plus i mean what does it say 0.2
better for white that
feels like in particular in this
position it feels very level um
i'm trying to have other moves like rook
d1
right that's a very logical move just to
pile up more pressure i'm not even sure
bishop takes d5 is a serious threat
because i feel like
even if that wins white upon the bishop
pair off compensates for equality yeah
but after rook d1 i can still play
bishop f6 to start with and then figure
out what to do with this d file
what's interesting favi seems to have
neutralized so far this awkward queen e3
move and now fabi seems to be enjoying
enjoying the uh the art in the palacio
de centonia he's uh walking around kind
of pacing bobby has a pace he has a very
deliberate pace and now we see
his uh deliberate walk back to the
chessboard uh returning returning for
the move and uh
we're gonna take our very first break
when we return we know that we have a
lot of exciting chess ahead here four
games before we before we do we want to
give you one reminder that you can join
our discord community we recently
reached 25 000 members go to
go.chess.com
discord and uh join us simul
with elliot papa diamandis uh he's gonna
be playing 30 people at the same time on
june 5th at 7 p.m pacific time
uh
sorry 10 a.m pacific time central pm
european time to celebrate 25 000
members in our discord community so all
right we're going to be back with plenty
more to come
here from madrid
some shots of el retiro the beautiful
park here in madrid a simul that took
place earlier this week don't go
anywhere it's chess.com coverage of the
2022 feed a candidates returning in a
few
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing the chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important part in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a
maybe best one in madrid
puntos
[Music]
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomashi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo were not
particularly high this time around
however is confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well nepo has competed
against carlson for decades ever since
the two prodigies were 12 years old
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com
events
[Music]
we are
back in
madrid jan napomnishi
is back on the clock
here in round six
his battle versus young christophe duda
has only just begun and uh the battle of
the outfits
began the moment they sat down they both
brought a very similar look
to round six
really did they first time i'm hearing
that first time you're hearing that um i
missed that here to see it from this
angle i had to bring it up again um you
wanted to make an instructive point
about the game in the upper right corner
before we move into
nepam nishi versus duda go ahead yeah
just as we look at it from this bird's
eye view here you know bishop f6 was
played but the major point is it looks
like in that ferruga caruana game that
alireza is going to win a pawn by taking
this knight on d5 but the compensation
that fabiano gets with the pair of
bishops should offset the material
deficit so i do believe that fabiano
feels like he's firmly in control of
this position that even if he goes down
that pawn he's not worried that he's in
danger of losing and i think that was
fabiano walking right from the camera as
we were talking about him but it's kind
of a theme of the position it's the
battle of the bishop on g2 versus the
bishop on ca right the monster of the
catalan versus a bishop that unless
white changes the structure is always
going to be fighting a little bit for
squares there so it's kind of a key
theme as to why farouza doesn't want to
take the knight
and he looks like he was a was about to
do something very different so i have a
strange thought you know because
robert was talking about danielle dubois
you know a lot of specialists in this
line but i was thinking who was working
with alireza and one
one name comes to my mind is vladimir
kramnik who knows these lines and who
feels them very well is it possible that
vladimir
you know was training
i don't have any insight into that so if
you do let us know no i don't know
you know yes that's uh because we
haven't seen him in a while as well he
didn't play anything even the
any of events like we have no
information for example now we know of
course we know for a while that uh do
the seconds we we have gayevsky and uh
mitten who are helping him for a while
but who is helping alive zafaruzo that's
still a mystery so when i'm looking at
this opening i'm trying to find out
because i'm trying to think of games
play
so yeah i know he's worked with yvonne
chaparrinov
before and i think he still works with
him and divan so andy von sokolov so i
don't know i guess a couple yvonnes
there but i don't know uh who he's
working with specifically for this event
oftentimes uh these players want to keep
that secret right you want their secret
second so
you travel with one of your seconds but
then you have the rest at home a
different time zone so that while you
and the person you travel they're
sleeping the people back home or around
the globe will work on the chest so it's
a 24 7 endeavor 24 7 machine to play
chess at the 2800 level yeah everyone
observed ali reza traveling to the grand
chester events with the bon chip arena
off so um that that information as far
as what we know is known even if there
are other secret seconds and just to put
some context on who yvonne cepherino is
formally over 2 700 raided himself so
he's a top say 30 or so player he worked
with um vessel into paulov who was the
fiji world champion so
has a wealth of experience working with
elite players and he's very well known
for his opening ideas and we'll see if
uh but i like your point about about
kramnik an interesting one i mean if ali
reza continues to come back to some
obscure catalan move orders then we
might have uh the opening repertoire for
white according to chromic maybe hal
leafman is there as well speaking of a
book series we haven't referenced in a
while but all right let's back let's
back out because uh this this game
hasn't changed too much since right
before we went to the break the game
that we haven't had a chance to look at
in a while is yonder pomnishi versus
young christoph duda and we're going to
head over there
head over there right now as napoli just
played the move rook to c1 on the board
the structure has changed with that
capture on e5 and so we should
definitely highlight that if it wasn't
for the fact that that bishop was
pinning the f2 pawn you would already be
seeing
g4 and f4 and here we go right you're
pre-moving for me king h2 king h2 you're
gonna you're gonna i mean if you're
attacking a bishop in bullet in this
position king h2 is not the worst
pre-move supreme yeah and um king h2 is
actually
a good-looking idea because you want to
push those pawns and oftentimes black
deals with the pawn push f2 to f4 with
f6 to challenge this setup in the center
but i don't think that black necessarily
has the time because
we need to take care of our bishop first
so
can we play bishop b6 or is that running
to bishop b4 like that also looks really
annoying the more we look at this
position we observe the time on the
clocks
we know
that young christophe duda is clearly
more uncomfortable than yon right he's
he's not sure
about this line and especially if we've
talked about the time the time pressure
that happens in this new time control is
very real right it's no increment
these guys are not sitting down with the
idea that i'm just going to take my time
today right when they when they take
their time it's because they need it
wow actually yeah what do you do with
the bishop yeah bishop bishop goes here
bishop b4 and you're not castling
and if the bishop goes back i think my
idea of f4 might be played before the
premium of king of two
just play it
you're unpinning my pawn then absolutely
you know this
looks highly suspicious for duda i mean
look at him on screen here he's got his
head in his hands maybe you have to
defend but the thing about queen e7 i
still play king h2 because you can't
take my e5 pawn because your bishop
needs the queen's defense right okay so
i have this king h2 move making h1 is
better i don't know but i'm just putting
my kings let's play it over here
and i'm going to play
g4 and f4 and actually this is very
direct let's say you castle for black
which looks like a reasonable thing to
do and i play g4
and you retreat and i play f4 and you
play f6 the move that i said you want to
play
you have a big problem here and it's
that white just plays f5
and i don't think you're going to be
very happy when my pawn reaches e6 and
this hangs a piece because
everything is hanging here but if i go
e6 next that's a pawn chain connect four
i win
go for it connect four
is that actually the theme song that's
the theme song i was just playing
connect four with my six year old i did
a little better at that than chess uh
connect for a great game no that's
that's a fantastic idea in fact quick
information so as uncomfortable as young
christoph judah has been in this game
the reason yon has been playing so fast
is he clearly knows the games in the
line uh nepo's rook to c1 was officially
the first novelty on the board previous
to that peter spidler played the move
king to h2 versus carjacking in viking z
2018 so this game very well known to
napolishi a couple of his countrymen
svidler and karyakin played it uh guys
that we know that he's also worked with
right so he's he's in his comfort zone
and duda is not
and
jan has just played the first novelty
with this move asking a very tough
question
extremely logical move yeah
uh but
maybe i should wait for you to play a
four let's say at some moment so i could
meet it not with f6 but f5
so you will no longer have the
possibility to play g4
e4 in the center is also close so you
will i will force you to take on f6 yeah
let's look at that so let's say the same
idea queen e7 king h2 let's start with i
don't want to castle
that's exactly that's why you want to
play f5 right now that's why i think
that uh
jan uh
changed from
king h2 to rook c1 is well because he
considered this option because maybe i
will not castle maybe black has to go
linen castle long
yeah i think there's a problem though
specifically because the bishop on c5 is
loose and once i take ompassant e takes
f6 you have to take with the pawn and
now your pawn structure is not ideal i
mean maybe it's playable but we actually
see evil as i'm plus two wow that's
way more than i thought it would be but
i guess the king being in the center
i move my queen away i play e4 and yes
but i was looking at this option with
bishop b6 actually uh i don't want to
play king of queen e7 bishop b6 so i
want to force you
i want to force king h2 so
bishop b6 mm-hmm h2 to unpin the pawn
and then well i was gonna play bishop b4
you should be six i want to play bishop
yeah that's the thing
i would still go for something
yeah this is this is a big problem no
more castles for black
but do you want to meet my f6 with the
e6 here
i haven't decided honestly
maybe maybe anything and the problem is
the key i mean i like the idea of
getting e4 now that that king's in the
center i'll move the queen to some
squishy which is really nice because if
f takes e5 with queen f5
ooh
oh oh i'm forced to play bishop g6 for
with me here originally i even wanted
queen b3 just to like get e4 and open
that but this whole position just feels
so scary for black
i mean it seems like a simple obvious
move robert you observed rook c1 it
feels like a logical move a logical
improvement over svidler cardiac in 2018
but now that it's played it feels like a
much more powerful move it's just like a
forcing question that is a pain in the
neck for black and another problem is
bishop d4 looks like it hits two pawns
at the same time so you're going to win
material right but queen a4 was my
response and you don't really want to
take on b2
because here i just play rook to b1
and you're going to lose a piece after
bishop takes e5 i can take b7 but i have
f4 g4 f5 and your bishops are just hit
in all directions this is borderline
even better with the threat of this
because if you have to defend it then
you might win the piece anyway
just you know we're just going to attack
all your bishops it's it's a problem
we've established that uh poland we have
a problem
for jkd we'll call him
we'll call him nepo versus
jkd from now on every time i say yawn
and yawn it's like which am i talking
about jay or the ah
yawn chest off never goes by on
its yanchez
yeah oh okay
lesson learned so ground control ground
control to major tom
poland we have a problem
but
jkd plays queen to e7 defends the bishop
and will we see the move we uh we
anticipated just put the king on a on a
square that unpins the pawn you pointed
out king h1 is also possible right maybe
long-term effects of being on this
diagonal are something that king chooses
to avoid by going to h1 what i don't
like about queen seven even though the
young sister did the plate because i
wanted to keep the option of playing g5
that's how you also keep your bishop
alive you know play g5 on g4 bishop g6
and then if your king is on the h file
then i will play h5 but somehow
everything seems too slow here i cannot
create
the counter play i want to
yeah i really don't like do this
position it just seems very
uncomfortable and we'll see how quickly
napashi plays here because
a king move
is not forced but it feels very likely
right because you want to play g4 you
want to play f4 so
i'm stuck on that maybe there's a
another idea that i'm just not giving
enough credit to but
just putting that king to the side and
then pushing g4 and f4 looks very nice
for white
agreed town population us
and uh
i'd like how young is
slowing down even if he knows the move
sometimes when you've got a big
advantage on the clock
you can take a moment to breathe make
sure you go deep into your prep right
don't do what you did yesterday where
you think you know you they're both
nodding at me off camera which means i
said something good chad they're both
smiling at me because i said something
good yesterday so far away well
yesterday seems so far away uh but the
uh yeah i mean you you might as well
slow down when you have this big uh of
an advantage on the clock to just just
make sure that you don't confuse your
variations and uh or
or possibly sometimes the first move
that your opponent plays that isn't a
part of your prep is a bad move and and
that's why you didn't have it ready
right and so you make sure you slow down
to remember your lines that you ever
have that scary moment where you've been
playing moves and your opponent's
playing instantly right and the moment
you play a move that makes them think
you go oh crap what did i do i'm clearly
not playing into his prep anymore so
that must have been a bad idea
seriously that's the thing
definitely has happened to me numerous
times yeah because you expect to be
playing the best moves when they're
responding instantly because they've
looked at it with an engine and king h2
by the way has been played and
nepo has left his chair
you you're comfortable in the silence
hey finally because i think
anything what is going
well you are going so fast that i think
the only thing which is going faster is
is the light you know the speed of light
is you know the only thing which is
going faster than you guys you know so
i'm going to rebel you know
i need time to think
would you start with g4 or f4 for
example if i castle g4 g4
let's look at the move i was suggesting
which was after castles if you play g4
first in here is there is there any idea
that i can get out this way or is that
just terrible
i think i can just take it and
now we both have weirdly placed e pawns
yeah on the other side of the position
but yeah what if i just go after your
pawn like queen a4
you'll push it to e3 at some point i'll
just put my bishop to c3 go this way
baby i could that's true but i was just
gonna go bishop c3 and then maybe like
f5 and f6 or oh wow that's even better
yeah it just feels like white has
complete control over this board i felt
like when i'm about to get rolled
obviously trading off one of the pieces
behind my opponent's kingside structure
feels a little better i get rid of my
piece that might be trapped and you've
got some open squares but
yeah i hear you though the concrete idea
is that you're just you're just about to
get crushed i mean here come the pawns
it doesn't look very pleasant it doesn't
look pleasant at all
let's back up and take a look at the
other games because uh there's another
thing that isn't so pleasant right now
and that stingley runs clock
oh wow shenanigans is the word for that
shenanigans now they've played many
moves right they were getting yeah we're
going to have to catch up on that one
for sure because cars of an hour hikaru
has still
he's he's basically still in prep
right i mean clearly at this point
whatever him and chris littlejohn looked
up at home there you go twitch
twitch.user first of all great username
twitch.user
i love that chess.user twitch.user
hikaru bluff or prep i don't think
hikaru hikaru's bluffing at this point
um
given that there's evidence to say we
know dean plays this line it was a
direct improvement or at least an
adjustment from game two versus duda
and i don't think his karo's position is
bad at all right so it's not like
there's evidence of a bluff there but
okay should we analyze how we got here
because we left it a little bit ago yeah
we're just trying to count the material
we're even okay that's
important take stock first thing so we
left on hikaru's um
mysterious rook move
as is often a term used in chess not not
for not for brook moves like this
normally but this is a mysterious work
move played instantly by nakamura
after that
okay we looked at this move rookie to d8
just very natural
and then knight to b3
that okay there's no way we're not
impressed like you don't just play moves
like that instantly what are you doing
you don't like making sure that your
rook on a3 camera is going on here this
is take a take a snapshot everybody with
your with your face camera because this
is how modern neural net prep jet engine
goes these days
this is this is crazy
c5 played
it makes sense right i mean you know
that c5 is black's only move in the
position there is no other way to free
the problems of the queen and bishop so
knight b3 actually makes sense
takes takes
a big trade that ensures the dark square
bishop belongs to white but that was
interesting right very important bishop
black took on c5 with the bishop because
normally you would take with a knight so
you trade knights but white isn't in the
business of trading nights but knight b
to d4 hitting the bishop on f5
threatening knight c6 with a fork so
bishop d7 is the only move and now i'm
already looking at that king side like
can i just start going for some attack
can i take on h6 you have no pieces over
there are you going to take on h6 you
have no pieces in front of your camera
that's a piece though yeah quincy wanted
quincy
oh wow
this is crazy right and then you just
like inchworm your way over
well i i think actually knight g5 check
is lights out
you've no pieces in front of your king
crazy crazy tuck
that's what happens when your queen's on
a7
hanging out
seriously but the engines agree with you
which shows how deep the prep was here
for how dangerous it was so you you need
this knight on e4 as a defensive piece
is what you're saying i've seen games
just not just like this isn't you know
the exact replica of the position but
similar games where black is distracted
over on the queen side and that allows
you to make moves like bishop takes
hatred i think there was some linear
dominguez game where he played like this
and he just shattered black absolutely
defensive resources um so yeah this is a
relatively common motif and it's taking
advantage of the fact that black's
pieces are not near the king
digly wren looks nervous elmira
i know he broke your heart yesterday you
wanted to win really bad
this is not the mojo
the dingley run is looking for
coffee coffee is what the car was
looking for yeah and exactly and like
how great it would be also for the
tournament if hikaru wins this game yeah
i mean
hikaru let let nepo off the hook
yesterday okay nepal gets sent to credit
we can look at that storyline different
ways right but but again we always said
that hikaru is resilient he moves on
very quickly he's already done it before
losing to caruana in game one and then
striking back against her jabba so
hikaru playing quickly
up more than an hour on the clock
dingley wren's struggling
because of variations like this that
could have happened and where hikara
might have absolutely blown ding off the
board instead of taking with the knight
he took with the bishop
the curious decision was maybe forced to
give up the dark square bishop
ikaru loves it
he plays knight to d4 to gain a tempo
bishop to f4
okay queen e7 makes a lot of sense
because you played c5 to get out of the
bad position but the queen is not really
healthy there so she goes to a safe
square prepares to strike with the pawn
structure right makes a lot of sense
i'm just still shocked about how fast
hikar was playing he just still just
plays knight to b5
and after bishop takes b5 he sits down
and
giving a give a bit of a curious
hikaru okay looking up remembering the
theory yup
and uh
takes right back and knight g5 quickly
played by dingler so we have to give
ding a lot of credit yeah because he
knows he's facing some kind of
preparation and he has made 26 moves so
he's got 45 plus minutes for only 14
moves left so he's got plenty of time
right yeah he's doing okay despite being
down an hour on the clock and he's
playing the best moves like look at the
eval bar of the side of the screen it's
still saying that there's a slight
little advantage for white but he's
holding on and he's simplified the
position not that the position is simple
but there's no bishop takes h6 and
checkmating tactics anymore he doesn't
have to worry about many of the things
he previously did yeah so i think that
while we praise hikaru's preparation and
has been excellent dingley ren deserves
a lot of credit for handling
all of that stuff and now being in a
pretty decent spot
also you should mention that this is his
second
game with black in a row he played a
very difficult game yesterday against
timor he
tried to win desperately so
and today he had to prepare against
hikaru
and he's faced with a theoretical
novelty a very
interesting one because you have to
understand all the nuances and maybe you
don't have the time
to know that
but he used this time to make sure he
could catch up on whatever nuances he
didn't
understand he's i think you're making a
good point robert to give credit today
because
yes he's used more than an hour than
hikara but it's one of those openings
where they played a lot of moves right
so there's only 14 moves to make
to get to time control now that could be
a lot of moves or little but still i
think the more we look at it it's more
that we're super impressed with how fast
the car was played then then dingley
rent is really in bad time pressure
right in fact i i think his position
looks very decent here yeah and hikaru
was surprised by bishop takes b5 yep and
now he's gonna spend some time thinking
because what has a takes b5 done once we
just saw the trade there it gives white
a bishop for a knight
it gives white these double isolated b
pawns but also opens up the rook to the
a5 pawn but rook takes a5 like that just
wins one pawn and it's not like
white's pawns are here to stay for
various almost like a useless pawn right
you could take it and then your rook is
out of play i mean black might have a
queen before or something but even even
if not right it
like black could black could justify
something else the rook takes a5 doesn't
feel like in the spirit of the position
what feels in the spirit of the position
is like rook g3
right trying to trying to move the
bishop
then maybe playing f4 we've got a
comment here from chad ding is going to
be exhausted after this game yeah
i think we're all going to be exhausted
after this game but dingo particularly
the longest game last round and then
here he's like it's
not been that long into the round but
it's been very stressful right when
you're dealing with that kind of i
forgot to say a hilarious quick
conversation i had with bobby at
breakfast yesterday after the game with
with ding
he was like he's i'm like you tired or
whatever and i said you remember what
you said during the world championship
we asked you whether commentary or
playing was more tiring and he's like
did i say commentary i'm like you did
say commentary he doesn't feel bad for
me
he's like well i changed my mind playing
is more tiring too late bobby you can't
take it back no take backs you know
there's one little thing here that we
haven't mentioned black has a past pawn
and they must be pushed
if hikaru you know
still is going for this mindset of let
me go for a win somehow i had all this
preparation
that pawn can march up the board a
little bit and can cause some discomfort
and uh of course white is doing
perfectly fine here but it just all is
about the the mentality that car has
because you know he's an objective
player he's a fantastic player but
sometimes it happens even the best of us
where we're like well i had all this
preparation i'm 26 moves deep i've spent
less than 10 minutes my opponent's been
struggling move after move to come up
with the right plan and so you think
that your position is better than it
actually is and so instead of playing
the position you start playing for like
how can i win and that is something that
the best players there are able to push
aside
but it does get to even the best
well it's definitely true and i wanted
uh to make a simple observation that uh
hikaru post like just the seconds when
uh dink played bishop b5 and
i think i know why because when well we
definitely have this double bounce but
now your b5 pawn is simply uh not
allowing you to play c5 you know to have
once again
this past pawn and protected past pawn
so it's also a very important
element while you're assessing this
position that's why i think uh computer
likes it a little bit more for white
still
yeah the pawn d5 doesn't give this
helper that's
true well karo is
thinking in
for the first time really in this game
by the way some extra extra scowls there
from the car he's really trying to think
about where he wants this game to go
because he's finally on his own maybe no
longer using uh using home prep
rook g3
can we simply look at this rook g3
knight e4 i think that's why he's
puzzled
if rookie 394 yeah we can visualize that
on the board that's maybe why he's not
just instantly coming over
to g3 but uh
on that note
of uh
taking a look at all four games and
choosing which direction we want to go
i'm spying i somewhat i want to go back
to napalma she dude again it's going
exactly how we thought duda could be in
big trouble but the report game
that's that's the one that's the one
that's got
well it's got rajab off nervous or he
wouldn't be fiddling the pawn a million
miles an hour um he's got a bit of a
poker tail there
let's let's dive in to that game and and
see what java was thinking about the
move rook f8 was played
so we can just quickly set we don't even
need analysis yet we'll just say we left
it rook f8 was played as robert
predicted c3 comes next
then on bishop d6 we see cd4 queen d4 so
the position is opened up if you could
just make like two moves for white right
like knight c3 rook d1 it's over
here we come
but black has his own things coming on
the f-file and that's why roger's so
nervous and actually just even a moment
ago c takes d4 by rajabov he could have
taken the queen on d5 this is not the
first time we've looked at a variation
in this game where
black sacrifices a pawn because instead
of c takes d4 just uh a second ago okay
you could take on d5
right queen dixie five right and then
after black takes back with
some pawn i play c takes d4 that's
that's a pawn right so report has shown
a fearlessness
to this point saying material is not as
important as the initiative and moves
like rook to b8 and maybe eventually
rook to b4 are coming so it does feel
like black has a lot of activity and
should be fine but
there have been pawn sacrifices
well i think that he's trying to find
the most uncomfortable move you know for
timur you know he wants to keep the
position imbalanced there is no way to
stabilize things here so that's why
one thing to note though is that the
clocks have evened out
in the uh
live position as i look back i can see
that
report used 18 minutes on rook f8 and
then another
12 minutes on bishop d6 so
just
i i don't know neither player playing
instantly right but it also looks bad
for white
i see the evo bar for the side saying
point one better for black they always
do this right you're like wow this looks
like it's going to be over in a few
moves and it's like no it's about equal
but this position
amir was mentioning from the beginning
white's queen side doing nothing there's
a king on f1 it's not going to be
happily met by this rook on f8 here as
required the b2 situation so with all of
these threats in particular knight to g4
coming your way
yeah let's say you make some random move
just show knight g4
is rover
here comes f2 crushing
that's actually a really good point we
should just start making moves to show
just how bad white's position is so if
you develop a piece to stop
the very clear threat
you lose if you
defend the pawn
with the queen
again knight g4
is just crushing
in fact
oh my god what
okay i didn't really appreciate how
sensitive this i'll be honest
what can white do here there's one
really important detail so knight c3
okay knight g4
queen takes f8
looks like it takes care of the problems
because if you take back on f8 i have
rook to d1 and i win your queen right
back in fact white is better because the
pawn structure okay so queen c4 check
intermezzo is essential here getting
your queen off the same line as the king
and that way you can take back this
queen so this is something that players
often miss from a distance like now that
we're here there's no way that java is
going to play knight c3 and missed that
but when you're calculating
six moves ahead calculating all these
different branches and you get to this
one you're like okay no i have knight c3
because i'll take on f8 and go rook d1
at the end to win the queen back and
then you get here like oh shoot what i
was relying on doesn't work that is
something that happens to everyone and
you start being like oh gotta find an
alternative well but what alternative
are there you know i was thinking about
bishop b3
but then maybe quincy for check once
again and then knight g4
there's problems everywhere
wait was there a better movement b2 has
been hanging yeah i was going to do this
yeah bishop we should we should just
yeah just take this take okay
yeah no it's so we've established queen
e2 or knight c3 run into knight to g4
you made a really good point robert and
in fact i want to talk about that point
because a lot of times it's easy to
judge when the position is right before
us oh they made a mistake right but like
you said it was probably eight moves
earlier in a variation that had multiple
trees right multiple branches and that's
where you can like quickly dismiss oh i
know i can defend this position because
of this trick where i take and go here
and that's uh
not possible because of the little in
between move there so
i think that
i'm just maybe painting the picture it's
possible maybe that's what was missed i
mean i i don't know but rajab doesn't
feel comfortable at all and i still
haven't found a good move here for white
and how clever was the move bishop d6
because if the bishop would be on c5 i
could trade queens and play queen d3
at least you know it would be the safest
option probably here in norway yeah
takes takes and get the queens off the
board maybe you're saying yeah something
yeah we need to trade queens here i
would love to meet you but i can't okay
but it it is fair that this position is
still just like because the b2
got this position just i mean what is
going on where java was hanging on by a
thread but it is still true that bishop
b6 feels really accurate to to close the
d-file yeah because that bishop c5 yeah
once you take on d4 you can then play
knight c3 for the exact reasons we've
been highlighting the queen and the king
are on the same line so you have enough
time to develop the knight play rook d1
next pretty much no matter what black
does that probably is a possibility but
the point is that bishop d6 closes down
the file
and i think that java's gonna regret not
trading queens because his king on f1 is
really in harm's way and we haven't
found a move this is what's so
misleading about having the eval bar for
the side like if i were commentating
without this eval bar i'd be incorrect
but like okay black is just gonna win
this game right that's sort of how you
think about it but we know that there's
something rajab you look at him on
screen he doesn't know that he doesn't
know but and we will we we say we know
there's something but we still haven't
found the right move i mean how does
white deal with two concrete threats
queen takes b2
and moving the knight
for a discovered attack yeah so maybe
queen c3 you know like i i wanted to
trade queens but
ding ding ding is this evolver says yes
this is the only move although it's
still
i can't play knight g4 because you win
my queen but everything else loses
yeah and queen d one check is mate
except for queen to e1 right so
you escape this way
okay so that makes sense so queen c3
might be the move that roger finds it
stops queen takes b2 no checkmates as
long as my queen is hanging
i want to just protect my queen sorry i
mean not two moves one move
and just like go to an end game where i
have two two pass pawns that's one
option feels like c5
or bishop e or c5 bishop somewhere
bishop c5 oh that looks even better now
we hit f2
and if you take we're right back in that
same spot where you have to guard this
and maybe i'm playing knight g4 so you
play bishop d6 and then bishop c5 you
know how yeah that's how chess should
work yes how it just should work yes
exactly
actually instead of knight g4 is also
looking at knight d5 just to close the d
file and you're still hitting f2 you're
still hitting b2 like that's the thing
about this position is simply trading
queens doesn't tell the whole story it
doesn't end the game yeah so rajab like
he's thinking okay first of all how do i
not get checkmated how do i survive this
and then how do i survive in a way that
continues to keep me in the game versus
just trading the queens off like we saw
in some of these other variations you
get the queens off but then you lose the
rest of the house
[Music]
well raja has his work cut out for him
you know what i've always wondered this
is kind of irrelevant to the
board itself but
do the players like do the cameras
change position
because if i were playing would
physically change or we just oh do we
have like yeah do we have like cameras
that move because there's there's one
person down there running back and forth
with a cam right now they get automated
i'm kidding but my point is look you
know now it's just the camera's moving
but if i were a player and the camera
started i could like feel or see the
camera it's like oh they're watching me
well they're watching me for a reason
yeah and that's actually but that's
actually kind of a tell yeah so i've
always wondered that because i haven't
played over-the-board chess in a long
time yeah but i'm wondering like you
know in events okay we could just be
focusing on their game all of a sudden
they're you know they're used to that
but they're moments like this where it's
like wait are they now suddenly focusing
on me because i'm gonna make the right
move or lose this game situation
i don't know if they adjust physically
at all we there is a camera on every
player
so
got it that's definitely yeah it doesn't
that's better and i know for sure like
let's back up to our bird's eye view
and uh
kind of look at some different yeah i'm
pretty sure that that is adjusted by us
in studio
but there's no there's nothing
physically moving
but that's a big difference than if you
have like a camera yes just that's
rotating yeah right because then you're
like wait a second why are they coming
to my game all of a sudden leave me
alone yeah yeah um but are you sure
you're noticing the camera when you're
having this position
well i just you saw which i would look
kind of right at the camera so it felt
like he you know he probably doesn't
there's one camera player it's like a
you know far away but i don't know the
reason i i was i was backing up to the
bird's eyes because i wanted to go over
to perugia caruana and observe that like
in that board for example we have the
extra cameras which is that
there's
they're they're right we don't have the
extra cameras on this board right on the
there you can see the uh the extra
camera for we're also being told by our
producers that this question has been
asked and the players say they never
noticed the camera okay that's good
that's that's a great thing that's good
i'm very happy to hear that
they notice a person and they're going
saying like hey like you know you're
doing good
camera there's one of our camera
camera guys right in the background hey
chandler we love that guy that's one of
the guys working super hard filming
stuff around the whole city of madrid
adding b-roll to all the videos that
we're doing so we love that guy chandler
on the left with the mask
um all right
well uh
looking at all four games
we haven't had progress uh nakamura
dingley ran hikaru is still on the clock
um
duda did just play h6
so that game is uh
still hanging by a balance
but hit the balance is hanging by a
thread i guess you could say that's one
where i also look at the eval bar and
just kind of called bs i feel like white
is just about to crash through and i
don't care that it says it's good look
at john he's rolled up his sleeves he's
ready to crash
through
um
do you think he has him on the ropes
here or where he
i look at the clock i look at the
position
i don't think that you know i'm anywhere
near counting dude out of this game but
it just feels like one of those games
where if you told me this will be done
in 30 minutes and nepal will win i'll
would not say yeah well let's head over
to that game there is a small difference
between king h1 and king h2 though you
know you would be able to play five you
know in this position so
because if if f5 is played
well maybe even not right away if you
take with shaq white has bishop before
but i wonder
i wonder if you can play five anyway
like okay engine's gonna yell at me but
i don't care i'm gonna do it no then
it's actually
so
the point is you can't take with the
queen because we have bishop of four
gaining a tempo and actually
you have multiple bishops hanging so
that's that's a problem and if you move
i just i just wanted to like keep going
you can start with bishop f4 just to
defend your loose pawn and then try to
play f6
but my idea was this because if you took
here i thought i could play here and
then how do you defend the bishop
and i'm taking so i don't know there's
four queens
oh okay i didn't see this one
that makes sense that's essential
because if you turning the queens off is
obviously not what white wants without
that move white is actually winning okay
so that's why i was regretting king h2
because i wanted to do the exact same
thing but yeah
yeah we earlier asked whether the king
should go to h2 or h1
yon commits the king to h2 and
now he's in a position where he has to
kind of think twice
before playing f5 because of the check
so
you know i kind of want the key on h1 as
well
can you just play king h1 now
it's a little too late but that feels i
think you can play f5
and the bishop as we showed has to move
back to h7 like bishop f4 uh the it's
gonna be very difficult for black to go
and win this pawn e5 it's with bishop b6
to c7 it takes a little bit of time and
white at some point will probably throw
an f6 i mean this is now getting very
complicated so
while i
was really liking yan's position i still
kind of do i also could see this being a
position where if you're not careful
when you are throwing all your pawns
forward pawns don't move backwards and
they can become targets yeah five is a
very committed like responsible move you
have to think twice
but here i really like your plan bishop
b6 and bishop c7 because what else do i
have
yeah extremely
concrete there just you can always put a
rook on e8 as well to pile up more
pressure
is it possible i mean we keep we were
saying it in just
but is it possible that jan is
regretting that he didn't play king h1
did he for you know just because of what
happened yesterday he confused his lines
he was playing fast like if we go back
to that moment where king h2 was played
let's say let's go king h1 let's just
try to see the difference right okay why
do we want the king on h2 instead
and what's the the benefit of it being
there
and
if we go
if we just play the same yeah castle
g4 there's no bishop takes g4 i don't
think
well that is a funny
little difference is that in this line
with queen h4 check there's no bishop h3
to block but yeah this still just seems
like a piece of wait the mission take it
okay again even without that is even
without that but yeah okay so so not
that but if g4 bishop g6 f4 and the king
is on h1 if you played h6 now just to
draw the literal
uh difference out f6 you're actually you
can't take on e5 because your bishop
with c5 is hanging yeah this is the line
we wanted and there's no check but can
you meet now at 4 with f5 you know i've
been looking for this idea for a while
and i was trying to make it work maybe
here you can do this
i like that actually
it looks good don't understand
no
i'm wondering what the big difference is
the king being on h1 versus h2 like
f5 was possible i've got you right here
you ready
king g3
you asked and i answered
it's actually it's not the worst no it's
not the worst response it's a completely
possible sequence like you play g5 put
the king on g3 yeah start pushing your h
pawn like that's a
viable g5 e3 h4 h5 yeah you don't need
to play g5 it's such a beautiful move
you know king
following my uh my buddy uh you know
short tim and not necessarily of a
friend short or chairman don't know him
that well but nigel short versus yon
timmon if you don't know the legendary
king walk
okay so i guess king h2 gave black an
extra option to play h6
h6 not possible with the king on h1
so
from that perspective maybe it was an
inaccuracy
yeah because h6 in the game you know as
we see on the bottom the live position
there like that's
nice for black to have where you don't
have to commit your f pawn and give
white like potential pawn storm and
leave that pawn on e5 forever so by
having the pawn on f7 rather than on f5
now black still can challenge the pawn
e5 with an eventual f6 so that's a
pretty important difference that's a
perfect illustration of computers retro
analysis you know right
[Music]
yawn hasn't moved yet but he's getting
up for a walk
he just remembered that he left the sink
running back at the hotel
he's got to go make sure he turns off
turns off the heat
you might just be using the restroom i
mean sometimes you mismanage your body
and just okay i'm sorry but we all have
bodies
sometimes you
have you ever gotten up to use the
restroom on your own turn
i thought you're like not allowed to i
mean of course if you have to go to the
bathroom in the bathroom but i thought
like you're supposed to be at your seat
when it's your turn
no you're allowed to use the restroom on
your own chair can you just okay the
rest i'm sure but can you just go like
walk around on your own turn
you could you can think in your head
i guess it's not it may be frowned upon
and it certainly draws attention for all
the right reasons because especially
with these days any mobile device
but
uh thank you for being here love that
you're watching the candidates
um glad you understand what the
tournament's about
the commentary but seriously i have used
the restroom on my own turn guilty at
the board here's what happens you're
drinking a ton of water i get out right
i don't need that you only explained the
body thank you for this lesson okay
drink a lot of water but you were
walking around and your opponent took a
long time they moved and you sat down
and you go oh man this is actually a
really long thing and now you're
committed you don't want to draw
attention but you have to use the
restroom and you don't want to make a
bad move so you get up and you go look
i've been at tournaments where people
don't actually go to the restroom when
they need to go to the bathroom chess
can be wild i get it but
let's say the bathroom is off the table
you don't need to go back you just walk
around and pace while it's not your move
i never know the etiquette alexander
ibonov has been doing that for decades
in the us chess scene right he's just
like he knows it's his move and he's
just pacing right by the board because
he thinks better when he's not looking
directly at his opponent it made me
think of
tony miles you know who once played his
game while he was lying you know because
he he had some health issues but he
needed to play this game so
but
in that situation uh should jan be
accompanied by an arbiter that's i think
that's the question that i wanted to ask
like if there would be a question to ask
i think in an eight player field it's in
like a small confined setting with like
very strict observation probably not but
in danny's open tournaments yeah he
should
well should be observed luckily i have
not played competitive chess um
at a level where
since devices had you know engines
better than all of us like that it
mattered you know but as like a
youngster playing tournaments
mismanaging not not aware of my own body
and how it feels
all right here we go let's go back to
the bird's eye view and take us a
different direction while yon is back at
the board whatever he had to do he took
care of business so to speak and now
he's back hey carlo took care of
business on a5 he decided i was wrong
and took the pawn and there's ding's
passer
there's ding's passer push him baby
and it looks like rajavo still hasn't
moved
in the top left
so he i mean he's he's stressed right
now there's no way you're not just like
kind of freaking out because you'd sense
this is a critical moment and your king
is in danger
and he needs to find an only move
right being told that fiji wants to
scold me about my references of the
restroom so we're going to take a quick
break
when we come back
when we come back uh we'll be diving in
all these games exciting and we'll try
to keep the uh
the conversation focused on the chest
speaking of being focused on the chest
everyone will be during the 44th chess
olympiad it is in chennai india july
29th
through august 9th it's going to be
awesome we're going to have coverage
right here on chess.com you can already
read all about it go to go.just.com
olympiad2022
mark your calendars for the next the
next biggest otb chess event really
being played around the world after the
2022 feed of candidates because that is
the olympia all right we're gonna leave
you taking a look at hikara nakamura as
we back this thing out taking a quick
break when we return it's more of round
six live here from madrid at the 2022
feed a candidates
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates every
local madridian visits the chessboard
on a daily basis i hear they visit and
kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is a
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah
we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
our man on the inside danny wrench who's
been with the players a lot going to the
players meetings and he's here to tell
us about some special requests that a
few of the players made danny what have
they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the uh the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can defeat a okay but the
first one was
a lot of bonus requests if you play and
win with the spanish on either side
makes sense right makes sense um
there was a uh
a suggestion you know that that anytime
you move the queen you you drop a dab
for queen isabella yeah yeah she's the
one that made the queen power makes
sense okay um but then the players were
unanimous on one in particular which was
that every two hours into every round
they'll have a now if acquired siesta
well we'll see if any of these rules are
implemented for the tournament uh
especially if somebody plays the spanish
they got some money coming their way
yeah doesn't seem likely but uh i don't
even want to know which players made
these requests but i've got a couple
ideas in my mind yeah well you know and
uh if and anything that gets the players
to play something more than the berlin
right the most exciting draw in the
world now that we have some money on the
line perhaps we see some exciting some
exciting spanish games so i'm i'm
actually excited about that one there
you go you need some alex honold on us
yeah
the alex honold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
like chess parkour
oh did you catch that on camera
can you tell he's a dad of a teenager
[Music]
always move like a night guys i think
i'm gonna go hit a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah okay i'll see you guys in a
couple hours
yeah
it's a long day dan you deserve it buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
up buddy yeah
wanna play chess online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
left quite a legacy on the chess world
changing the rules to the game she
actually did robert that's not a joke
chess was different before queen
isabella made the queen the most
powerful piece on the board
why are you singling me out over here
because you're laughing at me off camera
and i can see you so i was smiling at
you to show camaraderie in our
commentary right uh we do have
camaraderie in our commentary elmira
kripchenko robert hess danny wrench we
also have
confirmation that i was wrong on the
idea that you can leave the board on
your own turn at least not at this
tournament
uh and the feed a rules of chess right
before us cited as 12.2 players are not
allowed to leave the playing venue
okay the venue is a little different
than the board by the way so that's
that's actually an important
important distinction for the team
without permission from the arbiter the
playing venue is defined as the playing
area
restrooms other places
are just designated by the arbiter so
the restroom counts okay it's fine so
you're allowed to go to the restaurant
so he was allowed to go to the
restaurant the player having the move is
not allowed to leave the playing area
without permission of the arbiter but if
the restroom is included as part of that
playing area perhaps he didn't break the
rules so this is in kindergarten so if
anything i'm even more confused than i
was before anyway
you're correct okay i was correct yeah
all right yeah the
the uh it was sudden and you know kind
of like where'd nepo go right but
apparently the restroom is defined as
being a part of the playing area so uh
according to the way the rule read there
but we'll come back to it not a
not a huge issue
we're now being told it does not include
tutorials so we're just being misled
left and right okay
all right we'll we'll dive back into
that in a minute right now we're going
to dive back into the chess
we've got all the resident perugia on
camera we have queens traded
in the game between rajab and report
first game
for the ladies to exit the board
um
we can we can do a number of things it's
funny that of all of all four games the
ferugia car wanna game
is the one that has played the least
amount of moves
yeah and it's also not the spiciest
position not the spiciest position at
all for sure i i would say you know
earlier we were talking about all the
time disparities between the players and
yana pomshi in the bottom right hand
side of the screen he saw is a huge lead
in the clock a car nakamura bottom left
also with the hugely in the clock but
for rajab in particular you know he's
the one with a time deficit
but the worst is behind him i think at
this point in the day the java should be
the happiest of all players
yeah he got got the queens off the board
and his opponent not so happy go ahead
amir no i wanted to say that robert was
completely right about the character of
the position in february's carolina game
because
he's struggling to find an advantage
here and this
clearly doesn't suit his style
yes i
you know i think objectively five
minutes position is very good like
stable solid it's even and for fuji he's
looking somewhere how can i actually get
an advantage there's not one to find
let's go over there we'll take a quick
look there's been a couple moves um
not surprising moves as we said
the knight takes d5
was where we left it white played rook
d1
totally natural bishop of six as
expected one of the other big benefits
to the line uh you said robert this game
variation got rid of that other knight
instead of the knights fighting for
squares where one was still on f6 this
is a huge difference in terms of how
easily black coordinates
the pieces bishop to d7
and after knight d2 queen e7 so bobby
seems to know this position maybe a
little bit better than perusia or at
least a little more comfortable given
the time management and
i think it's also you know there's no
burden on fabiano yeah the burden is
usually in the player with the first
move to prove some kind of advantage for
fabiano he came into today thinking well
if i draw this game that's a very good
result so he's looking to get exactly
what he came in for the position is
really solid for black there's not a
single target right earlier we're
talking the bishop on g2 being so strong
aiming across the board well now that
knight's in its path and we talked
earlier how you don't want to play e4 to
kick knight because that leaves behind
many squares so
i think that fabiano should be very
happy about his position
one interesting thing though on queen e7
is it does allow knight e4 as a chance
to try to get the bishop pair
let me know your thoughts on that it
just that's the only thing i'm nervous
about for black's mission and maybe at
this position you're not worried about
losing that bishop
well you can also keep it i think you
can you could play bishop b5 okay
uh on the other hand you
also you also have a possibility to play
bishop c6 and if you take on f6 you will
play knight f6 with the temple and then
trade
yeah
okay
not a big deal to lose your bishop if
another set comes off the board often
all right so that
yeah it just feels like there's just
nothing really to it right super solid
for black faruja
not playing openings of his style at to
this point in
madrid robert i mean
queen d3 that was his kind of weapon of
choice his unique approach and fabiano
made it seemingly perfectly maybe
there's of course not maybe there of
course underlying preparation a lot of
things to dive into where throughout the
opening stage of chess most of the
positions should be within a small
range of evaluations and it's all about
comfort zones like frigid play queen d3
likely looking for something specific he
clearly didn't get that thing today and
he is a fine position but it's not one
where you look at him like oh i'll
originally he can play for a win from
here i think as we're all saying and
we're being objective about it
this position is like perfectly fine for
fabiano and there's not a single concern
in the world and there are so many lines
uh
that stayed behind the curtain you know
like when chess players prepare of
course especially at this level they
have to memorize a lot of the lines and
this is a very uh pragmatic approach
also on fabiana's behalf
yeah
bruce you're about to reach for a piece
fabiano lurking waiting watching judging
look at the baby look at the baby
[Laughter]
but i think that he has to play knight
f4
94 yes it's a very natural move here but
i like i like i like both your moves
bishop b5 and bishop c6
[Music]
f3
okay different square
and
his idea
is
watch out for e4 e5 okay e45 traps the
bishop okay tactic on the board got it
which i don't even think works
oh okay good job like if you play rook
one of the rooks to d8 they'll probably
work f38 and you play e4 black has the
move e5 ah little discovered little uh
in fact it's funny e4 now backfires
right yeah it's all the reasons all the
reasons you don't want to play this move
in the catalan
blocks the bishop blocks your pressure
the queen side in this case actually
blocks the queen from uh having having
exit squares over here so
some knight of three
maybe he wants to trade the uh dark
square bishops to play bishop g5
and to solve the the problem of this
bishop actually uh which is on c1 yes
because the bishop f6 is much more
active in this position so very often
you want to trade your passive piece
that's how you actually think when you
try to assess the position okay
what are the pieces that i want to
exchange yeah very often you would love
to exchange them against the most like
the more active pieces of your opponent
yeah
that makes sense so
perhaps this is the idea but either way
i mean it just it's reinforcing that
fabiano has equalized right with the
second move doing just fine and maybe
maybe even has the potential for better
but uh all right not many people have
had a better start to their chess
careers though we still got a lot of
chess here in the 2022 feed a candidate
so we're gonna take a second remind
viewers you may have missed one of our
player highlight profiles earlier in the
week right now we're gonna look at the
shooting star that is ali raza perugia
[Music]
considered by most as the rising
superstar in chess ali reza faruja makes
his candidates debut here in madrid
the only teenager in the tournament
furuja is the youngest player ever to
break the 2800 rating barrier
born in iran but representing france
perugia strikes fear in his opponents
with his array of surprising tactical
shots
alireza qualified for the candidates by
taking first place in the fide grand
swiss he also followed up that
performance with a strong finish at the
european team chess championship
coming in with heavy expectations
farouza has a more than reasonable
opportunity here to become the youngest
winner in candidates tournament history
[Music]
with that the teen prodigy would take
one step closer to potentially knocking
magnus carlsen off his championship
perch
lots of expectations on ali reza
coming into this event i think i think
mostly by media obviously partly driven
by magnus carlson's comments himself
i do feel like a lot of chess experts
looking at this knew that this was a
very this is going to be a tough task
and of course he still has plenty of
time to come back and you know we'll see
how he does in these final two rounds
robert but you know
not many people win the candidates when
they first played it i have to correct
myself from yesterday actually gary
kasparov uh did win the candidates the
first time he was in it i was wrong
about that and technically even though
the system was different then karpov
also won the rezonal and then also
became world champion because fisher
wasn't anyway but for the most part it's
a very tough thing to do and
you know what do you what do you think
is going on in his head at this time
based on how he's played so far well
look at the first four rounds in
particular he had the
black pieces and three of the first four
that's a daunting task for anybody but
especially for a player that came in
with as you said the expectations of
everybody else who was saying that this
is the future world champion this might
be the next challenger to magnus and
magnus himself saying i will only play
alireza it's so much for a teenager to
deal with and that's not even
considering what's happening on the
board that's already a lot when you're
playing 2750 2800 opposition round after
round so i think he had a really tough
start he showed he's willing to fight
but i will say that with a two out of
five score with four draws and one loss
he might even be fortunate not to have a
worse score because as early as round
one he took the fight to rajabov but got
a pretty rough position and as we see
you know it's common here by graceful
rooster ferugian ding of the most
pressure coming in i would say no not
fuji ending i think farouja i don't
think there's any compe
comparison competition for who had the
most pressure i mean when the world
champion says i will only play this one
person
there's nobody else in the question
about who has the most pressure
yeah well i think thingyman also had a
lot of
a lot of hype from uh from china uh for
sure no but i but i agree i mean it's
obviously something that
he he has said elmira many times like
hey i enjoy chess like i'm feeling good
right there's no pressure on me and
and
you know maybe that's maybe that's okay
maybe that's the case you hopefully
hopefully certain believe it might be
the case but
what do you think is it still the case
if you end up uh in the in the bottom
half of the standings heading into the
second half of the event well he
certainly realized that uh this
tournament uh
is not going to be easy we saw
his reaction and also he's feeling this
pressure robert uh
he precisely pointed out that the future
of chess is on his shoulders you know
and these shoulders are very young still
and even though this is his first
candidates tournament he needs to gain a
very
important experience of playing those
tournaments yeah
well
uh
right now he still has plenty of fight
in this game plenty of opportunities to
see if something goes wrong we see bobby
has already responded with this move
rook c8
due to the nice tactic you pointed out
robert that e4 isn't possible for white
because of e5 that's kind of important
but um
we'll see i don't know if he really
feels that the future of chess itself is
on his shoulders but he definitely knows
he has a bright future and there's a lot
of eyes looking at him right but if he
doesn't win the cannons and magnus
carlsen doesn't play for the world
championship
that changes the entire future of chess
it's not his fault i don't blame him i
really don't i in fact you know any time
somebody asked me about a young player
and you know is this a future
grandmaster this is a future world
champion yeah it's almost an unfair
question to answer yeah because you're
putting your own expectations on this
person who just wants to focus on chess
who wants to progress you know and wants
to learn right that's what he loves
chess the guy lives and breathes chest
he's 19 years old he doesn't need all
this you know
outside
prognostication of you if you're not
this by this age well then you're not
the success that we thought you were
going to be right and this happens in
any professional sport when there are
eyeballs and media but i think that yeah
in particular for this event alireza
he's dealing with a lot yep
and we know that magnus is watching this
event closely so
we hope that he would reconsider
i think magnus is watching our coverage
closely he usually is hey magnus who
knows you're watching out there buddy
just make sure they don't see on chess
24's broadcast if you've got us on your
phone
um
all right well here we have a uh a quick
view of what's going on all four boards
things have really started to change in
that nakamura dingley run game i see you
shaking your head robert yeah the left
side of the screen i mean the right
bottom right with nepal playing h4 so
young upon she he's going for you know
some kingside play but the left side of
the screen right now that's where my
eyes are because we see that report just
grabbed a pawn on b2 in the top left and
then you know in the bottom left as you
said the nakamura dingley ren game that
d-pawn it was on d5 now let's push up to
d4 don't be surprised when it lands on
d3 and that could be a nuisance for
hikar to deal with
well let's go ahead and check on that
one we haven't looked at it in a little
bit hikaru is uh on the clock his time
advantage slowly dwindling that happens
right he was playing from prep he had an
hour and 52 minutes uh when dingley run
was already under an hour
but in the last few moves black pieces
the black pieces do feel like they're
coming to life right hikaru took the
time to grab the pawn for those of you
who have been with us know that the
position
just a couple of moves ago was right
here
hey carter decided to take
and now he's backing up the pieces to uh
to more aggressive moves from bingley
run
i'm already
liking this which much much more for
dingley run just just the activity and
we said what did we say about that pawn
that it wasn't in the spirit of the
position to take the pawn right just
didn't feel like what the white pieces
were trying to do and now black might be
getting it back very soon
and also look at this knight on this six
knight to five was a perfect
multi-functional move you were keeping
the option of playing knight e4 but then
when white took on a5 and switched to
another plan then dink played 96 and you
want to play here f4 and f5 yeah but you
might not get
have the time to do so
yeah this feels like it's
completely turned around let's let's go
back to that position with rook takes a5
again
the move that i was saying in the spirit
of the position was was with g3
not knowing if it was the best move or
not but this is what we have been
talking about and to point out 96 right
away probably just not a good idea
because the bishop takes h6
so if you're not moving the knight let's
say you play d4 anyway i don't know just
because we're trying to make a move that
for black this felt like what i thought
was gonna happen and i guess i guess the
real issue is you point out robert is
white has also lost firepower so what do
you do next i guess right now now what
are you doing playing queen d3 trying to
blockade yeah so queen e3 looks like a
good move but i think ultimately what
might happen here is even if white wins
this h6 pawn so let's say i make a move
like rook d5 and you play h4 and my
knight has to go oh i guess the h4 is
also hanging this knight on e6 is a
stallion
so i have my king safe because that
knight on e6 and i have a pass pawn and
if a queen is the blockading piece the
queen is the worst blockader because as
soon as i attack the queen it has to
move so if the knight comes to c5 later
and
i'm already liking the look of these
positions for black and in particular in
this one tactically speaking h6 falls so
does h4 so that should hold the balance
materially speaking i just feel like if
we return to the game i mean once that
knight parks itself on e6 like it has
but i would argue even this though still
is more in the spirit of the position if
we go for like a trade on this let me
just can i play rook h3
and you know i've got mate on the brain
here i don't i mean i yeah
i'm not saying it's going to happen but
i still feel like
yeah your bishop actually i could have
just taken g7 right so
yeah if we give away everything okay i'm
not giving white i'm just saying that it
feels like if we're evaluating this
position
this was the direction
of whites of white's plan i was
surprised to see this and again i'm no
i'm no man to criticize the the the god
that is not nakamura i'm just surprised
because it didn't feel like the way you
would the way you would play the
position because
oh wait but elmira said before that
maybe it was just 94. so okay that was
the key point i guess and now
now we're just shuffling
okay yeah although this actually
you know the a5 pawn
really not as important as this d5 pawn
so yeah if you can win the d5 point you
can't play queen e6 because rook takes
e4
a little tactic there definitely are
issues for black to solve here but i
believe that ultimately even if it costs
black upon getting that knight to e6
yeah without getting the king in any
danger like yeah even in that situation
uh it seems that black should be a
knight c5 here right i'll give you the
d5 pawn because i'll take over the d
file myself i'll play knight e6 and i'm
gonna probably win one of your b-pawns
at some point yeah it's a really good i
like even though we're just kind of
going human moves here we don't care
what the engine says but ironically the
engine agrees the point is
this is
this is a position that just shows
everything we're talking about right the
knight on e6 is such such a dominant
blockader the bishop blocks the pawn
okay
if i pound it was a simple lure i think
just take it you know so i could play on
knight d6 and stabilize the position
yeah
well
chat says
naka won't be happy with this
he lost a big opportunity yesterday
we'll see right now he's not thinking
about yesterday i mean right now if this
one gets away with him he'll be happy
for a draw because uh
the difference between this game and
yesterday is that hikari was was
definitely clearly better at some point
yesterday and what what happened we
heard his comments after the game with
dino bell and kaya about this 92 idea
not being as good and
he was probably right so
but if dingley wren can win this game
are we talking about yesterday if he
could beat java with black get right to
it back to an even score be in striking
distance of the leaders that would be
something if he can beat hikaru after
all that preparation and as i look at
this position yeah we see the eva bar
saying black is slightly better but even
if several moves ago when it still said
white was slightly better saying that
this is a position that could really get
out of hand for white because black has
the best single piece on the board in
that pawn on d4 like that's a nice pass
pawn the knight on e6 is better than the
counterpart it's not like counterpart i
guess the opposing minor piece on d2 and
then b5 is under attack e5 could be over
extended and i just like that past pawn
on d4 it just is the best pawn on board
well the prep was was very real but yeah
we said it right in this position elmira
robert was saying we'll go back to that
it was that it was that the foundation
that was the word you used robert right
the foundation of the position
d4
b2 a4
these were things that we were kind of
spying and ultimately black did figure
out the problems of the queen and bishop
being blocked out and
super important right keep the big
picture of what weaknesses could be
there despite the specific prep you're
dealing with and dingley ren did it well
and which car face is this you're the
world's leading expert
i might have to consult the catalog on
this one oh there we go that slipped
into one i knew in car number 19 the
squint of displeasure
danny but you said that you stopped
playing a competitive chess
a while ago but do you still have a
patience of playing a classical game
like this
last time i played classical chess was
2019 last time a lot of people played
classical chess was 2019 before the
pandemic so um yeah i mean i honestly
actually really enjoyed the last uh
tournament i played that was long time
which it was like meditation it was
awesome and i because i hadn't played
since 2015. so um no absolutely uh
people want to go to the duda game it
could be crucial for the tournament okay
good call thank you chat
looks like
due to
dude is dealing with the pawn storm that
we left we'll head over there
we've got it up we said that the h pawn
advanced and
white is about to be rolling forward
and
we surprised about where this has gone
this looks like what we were expecting
right white's advancing the pawns and
black's about to get in trouble
i mean i'm not trying to overstep no no
but that's what the position is right
you know it sounds funny it's just like
this board is just controlled by yon's
pawns right i look at the e5 and g5
pawns here and
i mean
yonder palm machine did something really
wise right we were looking at f5 that
was what we were fixated on he paused
it's what he didn't do yesterday against
hikaru he got himself in trouble by
playing a little too quickly but he
paused and realized f5 isn't the only
pawn push that i can go for he brought
his queen from d1 over to the king side
to e g3 over here and then push his h
and g pawns and i really like his
position again amira what do you think
h6 was played here yawn played queen e1
like robert said right
well i really like john's maneuver
because he's increasing the pressure
once again instead of going for a
concrete line and
well after
white's move g5 you would love to play
bishop f5 and h5 but unfortunately you
cannot do those both two moves in the y
position i mean yeah
here you'd love to play two moves right
is that what you're saying exactly yeah
okay
but here you you have to choose and uh
the threat is imminent i want to take on
h6
it's a really instructive point that all
mirror made if you could if you could
lock up with h5 and bishop five and then
you know maybe even g6 magically
everything is closed and black's
position is fine right it's the work on
c1 that's causing black problems okay
h5 by itself looks like a good move but
white has f5 yeah because you can't take
this pawn e5 your bishop is loose over
there on c5 so uh ever since the rook c1
queen e7 dynamic was first played
it means that the e5 pawn is defended
tactically in many of these positions so
if you can't play h5
you don't want to take on g5 in the live
position that's clear because you take
on g5 and white just takes back with the
h pawn uh hello h file there's probably
gonna be a checkmate that king g3 idea
that you mentioned queen h4 king g3 rook
h1 and bye bye
let's go back to the idea elmira was
looking for earlier was there ever a
chance to play f5 for black that was
like maybe right here
i mean
this was this was kind of on point where
you were saying on mirror that you you
have to slow down the pawns like you
have to stop them and sometimes in order
to slow down a pawn storm it takes your
own pawns to kind of stand in their way
so
was this possible
well when
when black plays a five uh the typical
reaction would be not to take i think
you have to maintain the the tension so
that's where you actually offered king
g3 move yeah
because we were looking at this position
with the king on h1 i'm just going to
play it
i think that you simply have to
to leave the pawn on f5 and
[Music]
find something beautiful
it's not even a bad move it's not the
worst but you know probably probably
something better but
i'm just
because the idea you had on mirror of
playing h5 and bishop five if you could
play two moves is clearly not going to
be possible everyone if you look at the
live position above young christophe
duda here you can't play two moves at
once so i just made me wonder was there
was there an earlier chance to try to
strike back at these pawns i liked
bishop h7 and when
young chistop played that here but maybe
rook aided the eight
is that the because h4 was played okay
and i guess it's now or never with an f
pawn push and i'm not really liking it
with the queen already on g3 so
yeah it's just
the eval bar says it's not that big of a
deal but i think this is super tough i
think the three of us would agree here
that if you're faced with this position
from the black side you're looking this
and you're already like how do i avoid
being lost in a few moves those palms
are just walking up the
king side here and like it's already too
late for an f pump like f6 here for
black or f5 one of these pawn pushes it
just feels like you can even on poisson
that you said the queen is stuck i think
you will play g5
yeah
look at that bishop on each side
uh on that note i was looking for a
defensive idea but let me start with
bishop f5 and then i should take on h6
in the live position yes i would like to
play g6
okay so bishop f5
gh6 and then g6 is it completely loose
in here
keeps it closed at least i mean h5 comes
to mind
oh no bishop h3 comes to mind actually
get rid of this oh bishop hd is really
nice actually
yeah you just cause you can always play
f5 because the bishop on c5 is loot
that's awesome
i'm talking about my king g3 you could
probably even take with the king here
and play
absolutely then i will play king h7 just
okay and i'm gonna and you will continue
with it here we go
yeah i mean you can't take e5 bishop
hangs bishop g5 is coming
i mean at this point even like h5 might
be the next move because the g6 plunges
i mean you have all these options for
white you know this position is becoming
easier to play because i'm having a
problem wondering but but sometimes
really
but something really instructive that
just happened with our mirror here is
the move bishop f5 yeah it's one of
these human reflexes that's like my
position is looking really bad so maybe
let's give some material just to survive
yes and that's the real issue with
yanchisto's position is not that
objectively he's lost but he's in a
position where he may only have one move
for the next like seven turns and he
doesn't find that single move every
single turn
the game will just collapse as we see
the eval go sky high after this pawn
sacrifice so look at his face look at
him studying the board right now that
does not look like a player who's scored
five draws and you know feeling good
about his tournament which he probably
came into the round feeling right now
he's looking like oh goodness these
pawns are rumbling up the king side and
white is just dominating over here and
it's not easy to see how black should
defend
can we try then one last move i think
king h8
probably at a desperation
i think that's a nice move i'm here
because i've tried one of the only other
ways to deal with a pawn storm sometimes
you have to use your pawns to try to do
the shuffle blockade thing the other way
is you just know that you can't stop
open files so you get out of dodge so
that if takes takes you get to use the g
file before you're actually your move
might be the best move
look at that king h8 might be
oh he took young kristoff did not play
king h8 he took g5 and the engine says
uh milaiki and i think just as we say in
the announcement just for a quick second
white should not release the tension too
soon because your point is a really good
one danny that after ghgh black is the
first of the file but if we leave the
tension there right you're not really
going to play h5 too soon so uh you can
kind of keep that tension there the
status quo yeah if i could play the
moves we were you could try to build up
you could even you know what you could
try to do at some point is play e3 so
that you could play book g1 very true
but
right now hg5 was played and h takes g5
right back from yon napomnishi and
i'm looking at this position danny i'm
looking the eval bar it's just going up
and up for white this he's about to put
on his running shoes he's going to move
the queen bring the bishop up and get
the king to e7 but the bishop and c5 is
loose he'd spend another turn okay yeah
so you
you can't even do that right away
you can move the bishop right away
and then what if i use a queen h4 like
what if i just go for the danny wrench
queen h4 king g3 rook h1 and just
deliver a checkmate down the open age
file
i like it wow bishop that's a good move
that's a really really good move
yeah and but it goes for solving the
problem we keep highlighting the queen
was stuck to the defense of the bishop
for how many moves now too many moves
right so this is how you take care of
that problem if you can get a trade in
i think that king f8 king e7 idea is in
his mind honestly but you solved one
problem it's the hanging bishop but now
when i take on b4 i drag your queen away
from where it sits hitting the e5 pawn
now i have f5
and g6 is about to trap that bishop on
h7
i can always start with e6 and then play
f6 if i want to
bust the king side open and just
barrel down at your king this is i mean
danny this is
not a position i think anyone would ever
want elmira as we look here right that
just
just looks like it should be an easy win
for white and yet the the tournament
leader about to get a win everybody
let's take a second and take that in
uh almirah said a couple of rounds ago
it becomes a game of catch me if you can
if he wins this one he might be you know
challenging leonardo dicaprio for the
role in the sequel
and this is not the position that you
want to get against jan once again he is
in his element and uh
he's seen uh all the tactical shots you
know even after bishop before what i was
thinking that uh young sister has to go
all in like uh bishop before queen
before f5 you have to take on b2 and to
to go for a very concrete line which is
probably losing but right then
you have to do something maybe here you
could sacrifice the bishop take only
five and uh to have some drawing chances
what do you say yeah no that's actually
from a practical point of view that's
probably what he has to do but you know
when you make these decisions
you're like i'm probably going to lose
but i'm going to go for that and so i i
guess here you don't have to rush g6
maybe e6 first actually just to keep
that rook on e8 out of the game but the
point is i'm just sending you know
sending things towards your king and
the the engine right has no emotion it's
just saying yeah it's bad for black but
perhaps you can hold this whereas when
you do this as a human you're like oh
gosh i'm probably going to lose but i
might as well try this because otherwise
i think i'm just going to get
steamrolled you know i had this crazy
thought because even if you take all the
pounds but you managed to keep the a
pound and the bishop on g2 somehow in
the long run you will still win this
game wow
my way a commentator after your own
heart right there robert already
thinking ahead about the end and we we
joke robert does that earlier than
anybody but
oh man
what a game human beings have a hard
time keeping up with the engine eval and
these crazy positions and we know that
yon had a feel for these positions
coming in clearly better than young
christoph duda did based on the time
management
speaking of human beings commentating on
these chess games right now our own
vishy anand is uh commentating on chess
com india's channel right now and he
applauded he applauded nepo's h4 said it
was very tricky very clever and uh
thinks that thinks that nepo is going to
go on to win this game and it showed a
good deal of restraint yeah instead of
going for f5 he decides let me go h4 g5
and open up a new avenue for attack so i
think that
right now jana palmashi he's fixed the
problem he had yesterday so what a
difference a day makes and this is the
player who won the previous candidates
this is the player who's leading this
one and he might be able to start
ballooning that lead if he can win his
game
that's massive let's bring up the
standings real quick remind everybody
you know we won't stay there long
because we've got four games to get to
but yeah i mean i just i feel like you
know we're commentating on the chess
believe it or not not just a bad joke so
we get lost in the moment of the
specific x's and o's
but this is a massive result here this
this could be a four and a half score
and if you know if the most likely
result happens
in the game between ferrous and carbon
which is a draw most likely just because
chess that means you were looking at a
full point advantage for yon de palmashi
above the entire field and he just took
a glance up there he's like i hear you
dan i know what's at stake buddy you
don't got to tell me if i win this game
i could be a full point ahead of
everybody
and talk about being in the driver's
seat heading into the back half and he
would be on plus three score after six
rounds this is absolutely impressive and
that would be
deja vu because he did that last time
and then he got stopped by maxine bashir
lagrav in round seven so he actually
started i believe this four and a half
of the six and that's been
both the
biggest praise of beyond apostrophe he's
a streaky player and he gets off the hot
starts
but what people also say is wait a
second when you play 14 games you know
in a row the second half of the
tournament i think is where people start
to worry about him and it's too early to
be like oh well he's going to stumble
down the street of course not we have no
idea but i think that nobody will be
that surprised
i guess except for all the uh the
betting markets who said yonder palmer
had no chance but you know take that
vegas he often gets off to really good
starts in tournaments well there's
there's another game that uh got off to
a crazy start we thought it was slowing
down when the queens came off but we
have to get back over to it whose turn
oh it's check so it's white's turn
yeah it's white's turn
there's
wait no there's black
it's black black stern no white stroke
is white isn't it
okay
[Laughter]
the rook is hanging but the king is in
check legal legal chess moves for the
win yeah by the way if nepo wins and
maggots changes his mind to play it
would save everyone a lot of time and
resources we could just use the same
graphics you know the same templates we
had and just send them back to dubai too
the one unhappy person is if fabian i
don't want to commentate with us again i
think he'd be a little bit bobby comes
back to the chess.com couch the sofa
boys return we just we rinse and repeat
that thing oh no
no we'll we'll
we'll get lots of calm don't worry about
it anyway but all right let's see i
think nipple got scolded yesterday that
was the question the nipple got scolded
do you think he got scolded by his team
of seconds who were saying you know
don't play so fast really
well this is a question yes
i don't know i mean we know that you
know magnus made comments that like
maybe maybe netball should have kept
playing on that thought that maybe
because hikaru had kind of lost the
threat a little bit there was time
pressure ensuing and and nepo being
happy for the draw maybe that's another
reason to scold yourself say hey like if
you've got an opportunity
like take it you know and so maybe maybe
he really doesn't want to miss this one
but okay we've moved on we'll come back
to netball don't worry we know what is
the biggest game wait
a night is on e3 for free oh my goodness
because after bishop takes e3 check
free piece right okay let's give me that
yep king h2
now if your rook moves you lose your
bishop on e3
it's a self pin double kill but
you take on g4
so that you can win the bishop back on
g6 although
in this position exactly you're back
here in your book is trap yeah you can
give a check first maybe on d1 but the
point is that uh rook hd one and then go
to the b file and put a bishop on g5
what's the material count two extra
pawns for black this this is such a
weird obstacle bishop position too
because the danger is very real even
though the queens are off right you've
got this weird
position where i'm like look i'm looking
at bishop a7 bishop b8 mate
just like crazy stuff right like
absolutely nutty all right
report's about to move i want to quickly
see how we got here because we
we left the position right here
oh that okay so raja did find the only
move remember we said this was the best
elmira spotted it actually very nice
queen c3 was best
the queens came off
natural developing occurs rook takes on
b2 knight c4
okay bishop to b4 check knight g4 okay
wow now we're already in
just
funny territory
black is up a pawn if you're keeping
score at home threatening to just win
the game the rook on b2 is hanging yep
but if you take that rook on b2 then
rook takes f2 check the king has to go
g1 you get to uh scoop up that knight on
b2 first and then bishop c5 is like a
check meeting yeah because there was
knight d3 if you play this immediately
you know yeah
yeah okay
so you don't take instead
f3 was played by raja rook f2 shift c5
gosh
takes and then rook f4 that makes it i
was wondering how we got here now i get
it
bishop c5 discovered check but
a sacrifice of a piece
black says i'm going to win the piece
back
so why wasn't king h2 a move why why do
you oh wait you're losing tonight anyway
so he purposely brings the bishop
to e3
that was part of the plan
and report has captured so we are all
caught up in the leg position i
apologize for not doing justice to what
was likely just like crazy tactics but i
wanted to get caught up and elmira what
do you think here we've got one other
big thing that we haven't talked about
yet only 25 minutes for raja
no increment but that's why he went for
a knight e3 and not king h2 first
because he wants to to transpose into an
opposite color bishops yeah and even now
he's too well his two pounds down uh he
has a more active bishop here and this
gives him uh more than sufficient
compensation and he might be even better
yeah
he's limited the downside by doing what
he's done because opposite colored
bishops even down two pawns in that
position look at black's pawn okay a6 c6
e6 all those palms are isolated so white
will be able to block them on the dark
squares and after rook takes g4 in this
whole sequence black will be up two
pawns but as you were pointing out and
we were laughing about it the black king
actually isn't that safe so
the game probably will not result in
checkmate but there are all these
threats that there's another idea we
keep assuming that rook takes you
forward i'm looking at it and because
the king's not that safe i already have
one pawn
is h64 possible
sacrifice the exchange
i mean this was the line i calculated in
my head i thought maybe i come back and
i don't know maybe it's just not enough
white can just challenge but okay
your bishops are not
active it would be possible if for
example if you would have your bishop on
b7
yeah if you were a couple tempe ahead
yeah okay so sacrificing the exchange
probably
not necessary so
rook takes g4 most likely but on the
other hand if i would be able to regroup
to to put a rook on d5
you know to play c5 and bishop b7 then i
could claim a small advantage for black
what a position what a game every
rapport game yeah the sport has been the
he gets the
the a for effort so far in the event not
that uh not that you know the ribbon
matters we say
good good but it has been entertaining
it's fighting chess every single bout
every single game so would you say that
he's the most subversive player
your favorite word
aggressive and subversive if i try to
sound
he he broke free from the system
he broke free from the system he's neo
you know i actually kind of like your
exchange sacrifice yeah yeah i would do
if you go around let me just go back
just right here yeah after king h2 hg4
bishop f4 check out the rook on f4
and the problem is that if i can get
bishop f2 next and get my pawn in g3 i'm
feeling really good about it and if you
play rook to
f1
i'll need to move my rook away i don't
really i think i don't really want to
trade rooks but even if i do trade rooks
black has like these past pawns that are
about to front the board so you can't
play this maybe because bishop five
first you definitely don't want to trade
too many pieces that's
for sure the case but a position like
this yeah maybe it's
not ideal for black but i could see the
temptation here yeah chad agrees with us
report
has the most fun games i swear i also
swear by the moon and the stars in the
sky that'll be there
einstein
great name report is the coolest guy in
the tournament easy
but given the tournament situation
robert would you opt for
rook g4
or bishop like given the in exchange
here it's kind of the farouza report
question when you're defending and black
will be up two pawns in the opposite
bishop position but he may feel like i
have no chance to win that game and
maybe i could go wrong and something you
know will be a problem because i'm my
opponent's active and i'm just trying to
find a way to get some counter play if
you feel like oh here i have activity
and i have really good chances to hold
the game and i don't feel like there's
too much risk then this would be the
option but that's why i think rapport is
doing an excellent demonstration for
everybody at home
he knows he has two different options
here both of which according to the
evaluation bar are you completely even
by the engines assessment but they're
very different types of moves so you
look to me and just like set it in a way
to make fun of me it's completely even
but
it's not even it's it's not easy that's
the point right it's not easy and you
know how i feel about the e-bike so
report's about to move but okay we got
to back up a little bit because the line
we predicted in the napomnishi game
versus duda
is actually on the board look at dude's
face with this e6 and it's not just his
face it's the position it's the time
rook takes g4 was played by report but
we got to head over here
to
yon napomnishi's game versus young
christophe duda
it's uh
it's yon's game
it's maybe yawn's tournament
right now the man cannot be stopped and
uh
judah is feeling it by the way this is
16 more moves to make as well in 31
minutes which when you're facing a
position like this is quite the uphill
battle
he has to take on the sixth here i think
that's the only move yeah he has no
choice but i'm just looking at his face
it feels like he's already resigned
right yeah like remember yesterday's
game and this is very different type of
position so it's not a fair comparison
but after yon made that mistake with
queenie for queen g fallout he looked
really upset but you could see him like
regaining some life but that's because
that position wasn't as clear-cut he's
about to lose a piece if yon napalm she
wants it and then he's gonna have to
grovel for a draw forever so uh
this looks really tough for him but he
needs to like
it's easy to say while i'm sitting in
this chair and not his chair he's very
very tall chair i mean but he needs to
like calm down
and then think about the position be
like you know what i still have a chance
here this game is not over i'm getting
you're the first one to call us out
after queen's b2 black gets all these
pawns so there is hope to survive this
game it's not over based on the material
count and i also had a thought uh that
after g6 maybe i should leave the spawn
on h7 i will not take it and it will be
a perfect shield for my king i like that
let's let's show that g6 e takes f5 and
then king h8 by elmira this is the we
call the umbrella method you use your
opponent's pawn to provide shelter to
your own king from the rain
this is actually this is not so simple
right objectively white should be
winning maybe you have to start with
some of like
e2's hanging
but this is not an easy position you
know rook b1 takes b7 all that kind of
stuff but okay white is running out of
pawns yeah so if you can get those last
pawns off the board even if it costs
black all of his pawns assuming a queen
trade then black has a good chance to
survive but it's a long story and
jana pomshi he's clearly unhappy about
this
dynamic
so how we got here was
what we anticipated right h6 g5 was
played
although remember again probably
probably king h8 was that was the best
defense but he he goes he goes for this
main line
yawn's all in on f5
queen takes b2
g6 and e6 both look good
after
e6 yeah i mean
it's not over but it looks like it's
like a very straightforward advantage
right now for an epo i have to give yon
credit again he hasn't played g6 yet he
is looking do i throw rook b1 in first
maybe that's important because instead
of ever allowing rook takes e2 maybe the
queen will already fill the square and
that could be some difference so g6 he
has in his back pocket and instead of
playing that instantly he sells 46
minutes left he's thinking oh do i play
g6 do i play rook b1 do play f6 i mean
you want to just trap a bishop that's
trapped there but f6 carries the threat
of g6 to follow it also threatens f7
check with the fork it also you know
with rook b1 in the mix and all these
places it's just a
a good moment to sit and calculate and
we know that yondu palmashi is one of
the best tacticians in the world
take a moment this was such a great
explanations like explain once again why
you stopped playing
yeah robert what's wrong with it it's a
lot easier to explain things to
everybody else when you have no
responsibility than to have the
repercussions sitting in the chair but
this this position i mean there are just
so many options here for yon de palmashi
and maybe yesterday he would have played
g6 in a second but today after that
experience he's saying
let's let's go like hey
you got this slow down
and you know after rook b1 black's next
move probably is queen takes e2 but that
could be an essential difference in the
position it might be as well as a
transposition if you if you take on f5
like after g6 then b1 queen e2 and b7 or
something like this is possible then you
take on h7 then take one b7
because there's queen h5 and queen g6 if
you don't take immediately as well so
although uh such a trans position has
already forced that queen to take on e2
so maybe if you took when you take this
bishop on h7 here and after king h8
maybe if you'd played rook b1 and a pawn
with slant e2
then black can make a different move
like queen takes a2 so you kind of force
black's hand into taking on e2
especially if you like the variation
black does have queen h5 check at the
end of a lot of these
lines
but still very dangerous for black
this looks yeah you even see the
evaluation part is going up a bit
the more depth it gets the more it likes
white's position because the a7 pawn is
falling and the a2 pawn survives yeah
elmira we were talking earlier in the
event before robert got here like you
said he should have been off playing
chess but he wasn't wherever he was um
but
we were talking about the same thing
about how it's super important when
you're winning and you're better and
you're up on the clock but you don't
spoil the edge right so talk a little
bit about why it's so important that jan
like slows down and does exactly what
robert was applauding him for doing here
well first of all there's so much at
stake but once again we all know that
how difficult it is to win a winning
position because
so many things could go wrong and uh we
know that
jan
sometimes makes impulsive moves so this
time i we definitely see a more poised
young you know he
he's he's very confident uh let's say
yesterday's game was more of an
exception in this tournament and uh
well he's he needs to win this game and
to increase his advantage because
plus three score even though we're still
at the first leg of this tournament is
an impressive result
it's very difficult to win one game so
he
he won three games and yeah
well you might be about to win three
games might be yes let's bring up his
head-to-head remind everybody he has
already won two games he started off the
event with the most impressive victory
of all not just because he beating lee
ren the highest rate of play on the
field because he won with black that was
a tone setter
he was able to get his second w against
ali raza perugia in round four and as
both robert and elmira were saying it's
the positions that are suiting yon style
right another very sharp attacking game
different different roads to get there
not e4 tons of the night or theory but a
knight f3 approach that maybe threw
younger stuff off
here we go we i mean this this is
absolutely massive after this we if yon
wins this and we see a full point
separation between him and the field
you're gonna start to see the uh the
gloves come off a little bit you're
gonna have to see more aggressive chests
from the other players right robert
because you're running out of time to
catch someone
yes and no because every single player
gets a shot at john napoli so
head-to-head battles really kind of save
right because like for someone like five
on a car wanna instead of thinking right
now against alareza frugia i need to win
because john's winning actually i get
the white pieces against him in the
second half of the tournament so i can
not just chip at his lead i can bring
him down or bring myself up to his score
right and that way you don't have to put
all the pressure on a single game or a
single moment but um you know one big
difference between today's game and
yesterday's game for yondu palm shape
besides like he's in the better side of
the position is this is more his style
he loves these fun
energetic tactical positions so he's
more likely to like want to think
and that happens for a lot of players
right i think we harp on yon apomish in
particular but it makes a lot of sense
when you think about the types of games
he much prefers some people actually
prefer the slow grinds where they're
really invested in the position you
mentioned vladimir kromnic earlier you
know at some points in his career he was
like a wildly tactical player but then
he became this catalan player who just
liked to squeeze you so i think right
now if you know in this game gianna
pompson is much better but he's also
probably having more fun because the
game is really tactical it fits a style
it's certain if it's his style it's also
one of those positions which he would
play by hand you know i would say that's
why it's important to think now yes
right and he played e6 right instincts
right e6 is good and then after he says
okay step one let's calm down for step
two
i like that phrase playing playing by
hand one because the position and
sometimes you feel the position is
easier than it is right you have to be
careful you don't ever want to play by
hand totally right because your brain
makes the decision it's not not your
hand for most people anyway um
but no it's a really important point
that you have to be careful thinking the
position is playing itself when there
may still be opportunities for your
opponent so and actually we got word
from our
production team behind the scenes that
if we go back before e6
that apparently rook c3 instead
was like a
winning move by plus a million
if you let the i guess if we let it sit
and think for a while but it makes a lot
of sense why it's so good but that is
like a very difficult move to pledge
like to show the restraint to not play
e6 right away and i guess
you just move and then
that looks like you said as a computer
movie yeah look at this rook c3 d4 e6
what
are you kidding me no way just take on
f7 i guess
and you just have g6 f6 like just throw
all your pawns up with this king
or oh no queen c7 first i guess look i
mean this is
okay
this is how humans play right
that's how me and robert catch cheaters
on chess.com i'm actually not kidding
i won't name names but we have gotten
more than a few grandmasters and one of
the funny ways we catch grandmasters
elmira this is this is the only way you
can get to grand master cheating because
like
there's so many other ways they try to
throw you off but in positions like this
when there's multiple plus one plus two
plus even one and a half right robert
but then but then in like three seconds
they play rook c3 we go
no human being
ever plays that move and goes for a line
that looks like like this
when you when e6 was just winning right
so
we'll approach it for all you out there
that's how we catch cheaters right there
that's right three is not a move one of
the reasons why i haven't played the
online events because i i don't even
want to be in the position where i would
suspect my opponent i think from the
ethical points like if you i really
don't like this situation
i hope that uh now the the measures that
you have taken ensure a very secure
environment plain environment
online chess is more secure than it's
ever been that's the truth and uh
amount of amount of amount of very
strong players we've caught cheating
with shock you but we can't talk about
that yeah you've already said a lot i'm
like you know you're the boss so you can
say what you want i tend to keep
i'm not gonna make it personal
so we did in fact have okay where are we
at and okay so he did indeed go for this
main line he is no no no he is not sorry
okay sorry this is where we stand that
was my analysis apologies
oh man brooks e3 rook c3
real shout out to the production team
for getting the information to us but
that's just
keep feeling it all day but that was
crazy i would understand if you would
play rook c3 with the idea of playing
after d4 with b3 then queen h4 and
rocket h3 that's you that's why i
figured it was rook c3d4 move the rook
and the i was i was actually about to go
on a tangent before it went there i was
going to say oh it's instructive because
it cuts the queen off and stops that's
the communication thing you're doing but
actually it's an insane like sacrifice
of rook line for he takes up seven
okay um
let's back up and take a look at where
all four games stand this one is the one
with the most at stake uh just because
if the guy leading the tournament wins
we gotta we got story lines changing but
fabiano wait a second
fabiano carwana
has gotten a better position as black
and
and a big part of it was because exactly
the idea we were
saying that through shouldn't go for
with e4 yeah no for that idea and look
at the clock by the way 11 and a half
minutes for farouja and nearly an hour
for five minute car one and it's only
moved 21 bishop h3
let's go to there we shall we shall go
to there
in this game we should haste
wow i mean this is a how did so what
just happened in the last few moves how
did we get to this position
well e4 was played
after after work aca right as we were
saying that shouldn't be the idea so if
you're just tuning in we were talking
about
you know a lot of things one is this the
right style for all the reservoirs we
were even speculating he's working with
kramnik right maybe the repertoire here
this is didn't seem to be a position
where ali reza was comfortable and as
evidence look at the time management
just to kind of level set the storyline
and we were saying hey
even though knight f3
threatens e4 and e5 to trap the bishop
robert and elmira pointed out a nice
idea that you can make some move like
fabi did and there's no threat of e4
because black has the inner miso e5 very
key you gain a tempo you stop e5 and
that actually e4 is a bad move because
it does all the things you don't want in
the catalan it blocks your bishop
it it actually it actually cuts off the
communication the queen has in the open
board but that's exactly what alireza
did he plays e4 bobby plays eve and by
the way the engine agrees engine is like
e4 not so great i'm giving giving black
an edge bobby doesn't miss his chance
now knight to b4
which this just immediately looks better
for black yeah look at the rook on the c
file this a2 pawn could be a target at
some point if you ever play a3 you're
welcoming in more black's pieces on
those light squares and the queen side
so as you go to the game bishop g5 but
this was the idea just to you know get
your bishop out to g5 that's what elmira
was saying is that was one of the one of
the ideas of the knight coming to f3 is
it unleashed the bishop here right amir
yes but you needed to well i wanted to
keep the pawn on uh
i didn't want you wanted to do it with
the pawn on e2 no i wasn't saying you
were endorsing the idea i was saying but
that that is one idea but h6 was played
knight backs up and we're already in a
position that looks very different by
the way if you don't take d7 i think
black is just like better right you move
the bishop you put a rook on d8 here
comes d4
what move does white even play like rook
d2 would be the
other move that i could consider but
after rook to d2 that you see the
position black just puts a rook on d and
the queen on h5 is out of play so you're
in huge danger of being left without the
most important piece to help your queen
side because at some point black will
have a queen b4 and just go after all
your pawns so the yeah i mean but just
look at the at the pieces the
bishop on d7 is much better than its
counterpart on
g2 then the knight of c6 is much better
and much more active than the knight on
f3
and the queen on the 7 of course is
has much better perspective so this
position is clearly better for black and
rook takes d7
this is important actually he's trying
to solve his problems tactically right
as we see here in the position but black
can throw in this move f5 and that's
what fabiano's thinking about f5 just
looks bad because why would you give up
a pawn and after bishop takes f5 it's in
the same diagonal but this is move queen
to e8
offering the queen trade so if you take
my queen my c8 rook gets to recapture
and now you're not getting your exchange
back
but i'm not sure he would go for this
line because uh
you can still play on by queen g4 and
exploit the weakness of the of the white
squares sorry
the light's closed my mouse
my mouse is jerking around but yeah this
is this is very good or
for sure and that's what others would
have to do but that's why 500 was paused
right now and i'm sure there's a saw f5
and now they're trying to assess do i
keep the extra rook for bishop and pawn
but my king is perhaps a bit vulnerable
or if instead of
f5 in the live position he can make a
queen move and let's say goes to protect
the e56 right keep control the d file
protect e5 bishop c8 rook c8 black is
still slightly better here it's even
material doesn't look like it's the end
of the world but if he feels like f5
actually carries legitimate risk to lose
then he'll go for this variation where
there's no risk whatsoever but if he's
sensing a moment especially with ali
raisin's clock
yep then he's going to play that f5 move
and he is going to say you know yonder
palm she might have a chance to win but
what about me i was only a half point
behind and i have the upper hand
19 moves to make
in 11
and a half minutes if you're ollie rosa
perugia so
and we see the jacket coming off you
know why he's like i might need a little
more extra freedom for these arms to fly
around the room because if uh if bobby
plays f5 and we head to a time scramble
you better watch out but we got plenty
more to watch out for here in round six
we're going to take our last break
before we get to these time scrambles
and time pressure don't you worry we're
not going anywhere and let's remind you
that the chess is going nowhere right
after the candidates we got more events
coming up for all you fans
of american football i say that out of
respect to our international sports fan
around the world the nfl uh has many
superstars larry fitzgerald the hall of
famer amari cooper pro bowl wide
receiver k von thibodeau just taken in
top five in the nfl draft micah parsons
so many more it's blitzchamps it's july
9th and 10th on chess.com john urschel
celebrating a birthday tomorrow i love
you john happy birthday early everyone
knows his birthday is public information
he has a wikipedia page robert don't
judge me i'm allowed to say that don't
go anywhere uh we we have blitz champs
coming up we have more coverage of round
six of the 2022 feet day candidates when
we return
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
the feed day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss ali reza faruja won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world he was joined by
gm richard report the hungarian number
one is one of the most creative and
dangerous minds in the game today and
nobody is looking forward to facing him
in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamora
jabba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covert concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers
pick out tournament the absolutely
grueling
world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one
sting none other than world champion
magnus carlson in the semi-finals of
that event
judah would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karyakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingley wren takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 feed a rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more try it for
yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
we are back here in madrid
looking at the beautiful plaza mayor
on a beautiful beautiful day
here for the 2022 feeding candidates
and uh speaking of uh a beautiful day
some some players might be might be very
very happy with their day at the end of
the chess going to the recipe and some
others might not be so happy uh we're
looking at we're looking at a uh former
challenger to the world title there
playing with the black pieces who has a
very good position against ali reza
farouja after a surprising choice to
take on f5 with the pawn you can see he
took on fi with the pawn right before
you instead of the bishop like the line
we were looking at
computer no likey we got to dive into
this right now we don't we don't have a
lot of time let's figure it out
what is what is he trying to do by
taking with the pawn here robert
i'm trying to figure that out myself i
think that he wants an additional piece
controlling the king side right with the
pawn and f5 yeah maybe eventually your
bishop can wrap around and you can use
the knight h4 bring all your pieces into
the game
but i actually really don't like this
for several reasons one of them is can i
not play
queen f7 just to offer a queen trade
then bring my rook from c8 to d8 to the
open file
i'm not buying this at all that night on
f3 it takes a while for it to get to g6
and in the meantime black's knight can
enter d4 and things like that so
the knight on g6 by itself isn't going
to deliver some kind of fatal blow
amir you said coming in we were asking
you know how much fire should perusal be
bringing to the board here right we know
he's desperate for a win but we kind of
were fortunate like hey
if if you played two feisty against a
guy like caron it could have backfired
here what what do you think is going on
with farrugia at this point is he just
is he trying a little bit too hard to
get his first w uh that's exactly the um
the point i was trying to make before
the run started that uh he needs to be
careful not to crash and that's what
happened in here it looks like one of
those blitz game where this bluff might
have worked out but here fabiano has
enough time to calculate everything
we have 18 moves to make in 11 minutes
shout out to the very observant twitch
users that's right
black haired eight
uh
11 minutes for 18 moves not very much
time let's dive into the analysis board
here as we see bobby play the move rook
to e8
rather than
queen f7
and again let's back up just a couple
moves to show that what we we thought
this might happen right the option to
just move the queen would have been a
way for black to be have a tiny edge but
maybe not great winning chances so bobby
he smells blood in the water and says no
i'm going for it i'm going to try to
keep my rook but the idea we thought was
going to be bishop f5
queen e8 and queen g4 and this looked
like all right maybe you don't go for
this because yes black's a little better
here but this looks a little more scary
a little more logical for white i guess
i mean it's also you're still hitting
the rook
so in the game though
he takes
with the pawn
to try to get a discovery to try to
bring more pieces in i think your move
queen of seven might even have been the
best move robert uh bobby
bobby plays rook
i like his move c e8 it over protects
the e pawn okay now you're threatening
knight d4 okay i'm coming around it
makes a lot of sense it doesn't just
protect the pawn he might want to play
e4 and e3 it's like white has too many
pieces in front of the king black hat
[Laughter]
uh but yeah e4 becomes an idea and it
just feels like this is a situation
where already kind of has to play knight
h4 and on the king side but
everything is under control from fabiano
and it looks like he did play knight h4
just now so he's you're getting closer
to the time control but e4 i think is
fabiano's intended response
how important is not to lose your
objectivity yeah and to keep a cool head
it's
you're asking me i've never had a cool
head in my life ask robert i don't know
how important
i think it's something we've talked
about with respect to fabiano quite a
lot this event yeah and this is only my
second day here you know unfortunately
only my second day but yesterday we
talked about the position between report
and uh caruana where there was the
repetition bishop of faith bishop e7 and
so on and we said that fabiano he he
keeps his objectivity he doesn't do
speculative decisions just to keep the
game going so fabiano does keep us cool
ahead and brother is this a difficult
situation and we have dingley wren on
cameron
danny what the is that a pawn on d2
we got to give respect to both naka and
dingley ren in that game because of how
nutty that position is yet the eval bar
says it's equal meaning they're probably
both just like consistently finding best
engine moves look at the bishop is on h6
the queen is on h5 for hikaru the rook
is zombie ding ding looking a little
frustrated despite the past pawn what
happened with the players yesterday you
know like i was like did everybody drink
too much water last night or something i
don't know this is this is arguably the
most unbalanced day we've had so far in
madrid by the way for java only has six
minutes oh my gosh all right let's
quickly dive in to the dingly ren game
just to kind of see what's going on it's
it's completely nuts
um
wow even material
even pawn count right yeah both sides of
the four pawns the knight on e6 proving
to be a very nice defender here and i
wouldn't be surprised if there's some
kind of bishop takes g7 for white
this is one that says equals robert but
like if you make like one move like are
you just you're just like losing to
bishop takes g7 i think i don't think
you're
losing because you always have you can't
pile up pressure on the piece because
queen takes e5 the queen can take back
and defend okay so it's not just
winning
if you make a if you make a bad move
here but it feels very scary yeah that's
why even rook g7 doesn't work because
you you would want to play it with the
temple rook g7 97 queen g5 but then
queen e5 protects everything and black
is winning right
but i think there could be a bailout
word that results in a draw that you
keep taking on g7 and give the king uh a
bunch of checks i don't know in some
variations that the king will be able to
escape funny because the king probably
escapes actually yeah in this line let's
bring up the analysis board to quickly
show the line because we're we're doing
the shadow disservice by calculating our
head we were talking about whether
there's some
some draw here
based on this but
i think we were saying that black gets
out now queen h6
queen f6 and if you're king d7 e6 ah
okay wait but if i play queen g5 e6 e6
after king d7
e6
oh you win the queen and i don't even
win the game
it's good for black takes with the rook
and gets ricky
[Laughter]
that's ridiculous
no i wanted to play queen g5 and rook d2
check you know but this is a different
variation which position here like when
your king is on the seven if you go to
the g file i wanted to play queen g5 and
then d2 yes so
but here it loses apparently
no instead of you know don't play king
to d7 oh you can just play king e6 kingy
six
and after queen of six oh king d5 and my
king you run oh my gosh putting on those
running shoes well probably when we saw
dean kind of shaking his head and
looking over the clock like he's
probably knee-deep in weird variations
like this because it's also a try to win
for black right it's not like kekaro has
to go for this but if he can figure out
a way to escape the onslaught of checks
black will win in a lot of these
complicated variations
uh
my gosh by the way also napalm rishi
maybe maybe moments away from beating
young christopher duda
let's go back to the bird's eye view
here and just take in for a moment so
that no one yells at us when we're not
able to catch it
it's not easy to follow all the action
right now going on this is
we just looked at this crazy king walk
in nakamura dingley ren
we've got napomnishi bringing the heat
against duda up a piece still attacking
father carwana with an edge against
farouja there's so much going on and the
game that we're not even talking about
where java only has six minutes over
there
against richard report
and that's a dangerous position for
rijaba because the opposite colored
bishop space down two pawns and with the
time the way it is at some point black
plays c5 and that bishop gets free this
could turn into a position where rapport
is pressing to win so
i'm nervous about java's chances right
now and rapport look at him i mean he he
may be slouched a bit but his eyes are
just looking it's like the slouch of a
very devious like five-year-old like i
wonder if mom and dad know what i did
you know i'm gonna
i i know that slouch too well i have too
many kids okay look he's like wait he's
actually knee-deep in his head
calculating
c5
is the move that uh likely coming to the
board let's jump into that game real
quick and just show what robert said
because even oh he plays
rook g4
okay
attacking h4 but as soon as c5 comes in
even if you lose that pawn but if you
can like put the bishop on d5 and start
to slowly unwind you'll still have
chances especially if you maybe win
some other pawns along the way but i
don't like this move because you can
even sacrifice this pawn and to play
rook f1 look f7 that was my idea
what do you think oh my gosh wait rook
g4 i just
give another pawn rook f1 look at seven
and what do you do
because rook f8 precisely it was a very
precise move because you needed to
control the f file
wow that's a huge that's a huge
point element oh my gosh i was
wait roger looks over he's thinking in
his head he's like wait a second i'm
surprised to see that move
he was about to grab his rook the same
exact situation
he had in his game against ding he's
given a chance in a very tough position
yeah
he was down against dingley wren also
with the white pieces but given a chance
and he didn't miss it and raja looks
like he sees rook f1
like he's about to not miss his chance
here
wow what a huge mistake that might have
been from report the
the move c5 was what we were looking at
because of threat in g2 but also rook f8
might have been the best move in
hindsight because of what elmira is
saying and look at that rajava does not
miss his chance he finds work f1
and all of a sudden white is better
there goes my prediction
the report look at that brook f1 rook c7
the game is like over
if c5 rook f7 if you take g2
king h3
and how do you deal with the threats of
rook c7 rook takes b7 the rook is
hanging
oh my god
okay i'll mirror i guess black has
rookie two here maybe
like
it doesn't make any sense but if
something like this happens my point is
like i'm not getting mated
and maybe it's not over
well maybe this is a draw maybe this is
like
we've seen in report failure uh
that you simply give checks on the
seventh rank and then
might as well be a draw
but still what a
what a huge
i guess just like
gap or miss it's like one of the
positions where it's such a subtle
threat to put the work on f1 robert that
it's kind of easy i guess to
underestimate just how powerful it is if
this rook lands on this square
but
a huge a huge move by report and raja
doesn't miss the chance to hop to the
file and it just goes to show what they
say about opposite colored bishop
positions the king safety is paramount
and you're giving up another pawn
black's already up two with rook takes
h4 check that could be a third but the
point is that i'm just getting my rook
to f7 and your king is in harm's way
your bishop is really a big pawn over
there so that's a big miss by reporting
he's up a lot of time so to allow rook
f1 in that position uh that's
unfortunate for him it was a complicated
position it remains complicated but now
it's rajab of despite having limited
time he's the one who's in the driver's
seat and only a few moves to make for
the time control yeah and this is such a
powerful also illustration of how
important it is to
um
to identify your opponent's threats you
know to counter them yes
well
yeah identifying your opponent's next
move is is sometimes sounds like the
easiest thing to do but it's
it's where mistakes happen gregory
kaidonov used to always say that every
move you just have to ask before you
move like if my if it was my opponent's
move what would they play on this turn
and it's a simple question but like just
not putting yourself in those shoes is
how you miss moves like rook f1 and how
important it is not to give any counter
play to your opponent yeah
wow no actually at the rook f1
it's not easy to spy what black should
do because
you want to play c5 you've wanted to
play c5 yeah it's feeling slow with that
rook coming to f7
all right we're gonna we're gonna head
back over to our bird's eye view
check-in we might be heading over to a
game that's ending
soon if yonda pomnishi
can put away young kristoff due duda
it's looking
looking more and more imminent
that he'll do so there's a threat of
rook f8
oh goodness and if and if this bishop
can find this diagonal
it's rover and if king takes h7 the move
rook h5 looks pretty nice oh
very nice
overload the queen checkmate on g7
that's why you do your tactics trainer
maybe rook g5 is also that's right if
you can take on h7 yeah that's the
that's the simple way i didn't want to
exchange folks yeah rook g5 is the next
move for sure
but you said it earlier the body
language of duda very different than a
person who who thinks they still have
fighting chances right there's almost no
nerves there's just a
sort of a submission
to what's happening around the point
when
napoleon played g5 yeah that early you
could sense that duda felt like this
game was out of hand yeah and he did
play some good moves right bishop b4 was
a good effort he was able to
gain some pawns for the piece that he
was about to drop
but it's just not a position that's for
a human you know easy to play right
you're just down a piece for some pawns
your king is still unsafe and then
white's rooks just
barreled down the board and went after
pawns on the queen side the f5 pawn and
then the g7 pawn at long last
yeah just showing everybody we'll be uh
the same rook h5 jacket what we're
catching up to uh because we were away
looking at the other action we might
have multiple decisive results by the
way who said he was picking all draws
today at the start to try to
jinx you
i thought you were going to make me
fight harder for that
i was saying it as a compliment that i
did it on purpose yeah i was okay yeah i
was i was trying to jokes aside
everybody was giving me the credit so i
never know when positivity is coming
from you i feel like i'm a beaten down
commentator
no but yesterday i picked three wins and
the opposite happened it was all draws
today i was i was predicting peace maybe
as a
little reverse psychology to the players
it might be working out with so much
action on the board
go ahead elmira no that's that's a
perfect rational explanation for
always trying to provide the
commentators curse that's my goal which
is if i say something the opposite will
happen
anyway
this position is the opposite of what
young christophe duda wanted to happen
in this game
and rook h5 a very strong threat whether
you take h7 or not
and that's why he went d4 because now
for the rook h5 there's queen e3 check
so you can escape by trading the queens
and all of a sudden i'm not so sure that
black is losing this game yeah actually
that would be fascinating if we saw a
blender like that um
it's actually
yeah if you like go now you have to stop
the e pawn i can even just take and
everything is unclear so
d4 a nice defensive threat to try to get
the queens off the board
okay almira's g5 now comes to mind as an
easier solution
it's very unfortunate because it blocks
the queen's check on e3
and yeah you're running out of ideas
here for you know just up due to
by the way the other three games outside
this one are still in progress here in
round six for the 2022 feet of cannabis
there's a lot going on today
the potential for for multiple decisive
results by the way the craziness of
nakamura dingley red is going for the
line we potentially talked about oh is
rook g7 coming
he he played rook g7 queen g5 okay that
might be one of the crazy ones that ends
in a draw we'll see
but
just don't play okay we were talking to
before can you play king to d7 remember
with the queen coming to no he's going
back to g8 your idea
your idea of
of queen f6 and e6 is more effective
there and in fact the f7 pawn would be
hanging with devastating effects so he
just all right we're gonna we're gonna
go see that one finish before we catch
another possible finish
uh between
yonder pomnishi and young christoph duda
but um
looks like we're about to see just a
repetition and the reason again is that
if if the king moves to e7 queen f6
check and when the king moves again so
it's probably not e6 actually this queen
takes up seven it's queen takes up seven
which is
oh caro is
doing the hikaru thing
taking a sip of water which means he's
confident
checks out
yeah at this point there's not much for
either player to calculate right it's uh
king g8 or king d7 the queen f6 will be
the response between e7 queen g5 to king
jaden you're just gonna follow the king
yeah if king e7
queen of six
again if the king moves
because your both rooks are hanging
that's the point that's the big deal
after the movement rook d5 because you
play queen f7 and you cannot
play king c6 because i will take the
rook on e8
right
and it goes to e7 but still let's let's
see the finish here i think that we're
likely to see
king f8 and then
and then a draw although they did they
did just reach move 40 so perhaps
dingley rent pauses
pauses a moment
oh you know what he's thinking about
what so king d7 here yeah
let's bring up the analysis board so we
can show this line real quick e6 check
loses for white yeah like you were
saying before because you take the queen
but then rookie one check at the end is
yep and all of a sudden black is
black is
winning take the rook and then pre-move
rook h-1 chip
zach get a queen so you can't you can't
play e6 check but you can't take he
wants to play on and so king c6 queen
takes the a-check i i don't know how to
evaluate this but this is what ding is
gonna sit and think about for the next
small time he's going to be down two
pawns but with the best most imposing
pawn on the board on d2 yeah white has a
two pawn advantage but this pawn is a
little scarier than everything else
and uh
okay well there there are a million
things happening on a million boards and
we have more than 32 000 of you with us
on twitch lots of viewers on youtube
fabiano is winning as black against
ferugia
oh and report report
is falling apart
he went from plus one to maybe losing by
force
we're probably going to have one game
end that we may not even see because if
dingley rent doesn't go for king d7
we're just gonna get a draw and also the
tournament leader oh by the way is about
to extend his lead over everybody
welcome to madrid
round six of the few i knew we were
going to have liftoff today decisive
results and this is timor java if he can
convert this it'll be his first victory
since 2019 in classical chess and
remember yesterday when you were saying
oh what's your game of the day for
tomorrow and i said this mismatch of
styles i actually thought you know my
job's chances were pretty good
his channels aren't good right now he's
about to go but he just played a move
that might have offered a draw he just
blundered he didn't realize he was
winning in that position and it's
actually a line i saw we have to go to
that game we must go to there
let's go to there
um whoa commentators curse
the
the the line i actually saw it earlier
while you were going uh with elmira the
move is you keep the bishop on the
diagonal and there's still no way to
stop rook f7 oh my goodness and he
misses that he was winning
oh my goodness but that tells you the
psychology amir you were talking about
that like he was already resigned to the
fact that a draw was a good result so he
wasn't even looking for bishop h2 he
played rook f7 instantly oh he thought
yeah he thought he was the one he
thought it was just a draw to prove the
draw but this this move is
and you sorry no one knows robert was
off camera i just spoiled the beans
robert took a quick break it was me and
i'll mirror for a minute but in this
when it first happened i saw this idea
and then it actually it was possible wow
and by the way rookie 7 to stop rook f7
doesn't work because you check and win
the bish actually
i'm sorry
so
well the position was a bit different
because we analyzed the line with c5 and
rook g2
slightly different
variation but i think that their
white had a chance of playing bishop d6
yeah same idea keep the bishop on the
board
i guess when you're down three pawns
you're you know worried yeah you're like
oh it's a draw okay but rajab looking at
his clock thinking that he doesn't
really have any more to play for instead
of bishop h2 keeping the potential to
win
he settles on rook f7
and now
we are likely going to have a draw in
this game so we're gonna we're gonna
back up and go to a game that may not
have a draw and that is
fabiano's
chances to get a win against ferocious
seem to be increasing
so bishop h5 is the threat okay that's
why bishop came to g4 so fabiano does
need to keep an eye out for that he's up
on the clock
very complicated position
what is he going to do
well he wants to play three but bishop
h5
yeah i know that works
that works yeah
because e3 bishop h5 you take enough 2
with check which means the rook on d1 is
loose so after queen takes f2 you can
play with your rook on f7 move it to f5
right
okay i was kind of kidding but okay
because you take e8 you lose d1 yeah
it works okay
so e3 is a viable option and e3 is
available i think you should probably
play it
well
what's becoming less and less available
is time on the clock for all heroes of
peru he has 12 moves to make in eight
minutes
and fabi's kitchen up is all here it has
only oh
how many
24 minutes left yeah
that's true even 23 minutes not a ton of
time
but fabiano he's got that what do we
always say
make fun of him
he's got a perch to him when he when
he's winning you see the perch
it's like he sits up in his chair
crosses his arm this is a very typical
fabiano is on the prowl kind of perch
right there
and he's looking for a direct knockout
yeah because
he knows that he has the advantage but
it's the type of position where if you
let white squirm right you get to
get out of the immediate danger if you
look at the material it is a bishop for
rook but the king for white is much
safer for now so you could be in a
position where that knight lands on e6
or the bishop comes to h5 at the right
moment the e4 pawn
and he pushes through he goes for it
yeah this is where he's
arguably at his best over anyone in the
world like hicario has said it he's he's
so technical and accurate and and as you
said like he just
he doesn't speculate right he doesn't go
for for stuff he doesn't need to go for
but when he's when he's challenged to
find a concrete line and put games away
he just
he doesn't miss because i was looking
also at 96 uh
lyrizal almost immediately played king
g2 but then you could take on f2 and if
you take with the queen then there is
rookie six i think
ah which is immediately yeah
nice nice
nice spot almirah and if you took with
the king on f2 there was take on e6
anyway because the pin is
yeah okay yeah
so what does black do now then if you
can't take f2 whoa we have a draw
hicario and dingley wren do settle on
repetition
i don't even know if we need to bring
the board back up if you see everybody
it was clearly ding chose to put the
king back on g8 and queen g5 queen h6 he
decided to not go for the king run
ultimately doesn't believe in his deep
on enough
robert to uh to give hikaru too many
pawns so understandable great game by
dingley rand yeah great he withstood
pressure from the preparation hikara was
moving instantly up an hour on the clock
yep and dingle wren kind of played a
perfect game from the black side yeah
held on and then even at some point was
maybe pushing we know that ding
ding's really good we've been we've been
sitting here talking about our favorite
dingly rain games now for a couple days
we might even be showing one to you
later on the telestrator and we fixed
the glare
oh
twist ending now now you're tarantino
that movie you're not going anywhere now
uh by the way if her job up draws this
that extends his non-winning streak to
35 straight classical games he's lost
games but he hasn't won in 35
draws yeah and i spoke at the exact
incorrect moment you know when he made
the move of rook f7 right away and he is
going to draw that game so he's walking
around just
with his last few moments in the playing
hall but fabiana carwana he's up from
the board he went rook d8
yeah let's head back to fabiano and
perugia
as the 19 year old
youngest player in the event
uses
the little time he has eight minutes for
11 moves to try to come up with a way to
keep this complicated
is it just you go nuts now at this point
it's like uh desperation uh let's hit
carl allen didn't see that move coming
he's shaking his head yeah so rook d8 it
loses side the e3 pawn but fabiano is
okay giving up that pawn if it means
trades because he is up in exchange he's
a rook for just the bishop if you take
on e3 here that rook is going to enter
the game and look at the queen side by
the way right at some point those pawns
are just going to march up the board for
black and white's not getting an attack
anytime soon
f takes e3 played
almira sits up over there nervously go
ahead no but i i i wanted to bring my
rook into play and i simply looked at
rook c7 here because that's the idea
behind the e3 move because trades in the
rooks
first of all he wanted to play rogue d2
that's why white was forced to play
rogue date and now rook c7
and rook c2 you know looks fantastic
actually it looks devastating if you try
to run away with your king to h3 in
comes the knight knight f7 knight g5 and
your king is running out of squares
stop using all your pieces oh we have
another draw
in agreement
oh you just said bishop h2 yes and he
said you had bishop h2 and his job's
like what
oh my god for job i was thinking
what did i do like literally that was
the
it's funny because i'm almost you know
watching like we can hear them but i
remember that yeah there's no sound no
job of giving the face of like wait a
second what
yeah he just never thought that report
would miss something like that either
there's part that's probably part of it
if somebody's making these moves against
you and it's richard rapport and he's
one of the top 10 players in the world
you don't expect him to blunder in your
time trouble so maybe there's a little
bit too much belief in the opponent but
bishop h2 obviously was something that
rajaba with a little bit more time
and
but but yeah
he had just kind of made up his mind i
mean
it's obviously not one that you know
we're going to dive a lot into right now
just arguably just because of where raj
just sits in the standings right so
we're not talking about him leading the
tournament but if he was in a different
spot we would be all over that i mean
that was a
huge miss
so all right we're back to this game
here and we might be breaking down
bishop h2 a little later
uh but
here comes that knight
bobby finds rook c7 if he finds knight
f7
you're freaking out if you're only reza
for rouge and the thing is you want to
play rook c2 but rook c2 runs into queen
d1 type of things and you're pinned on
the diagonal your knight in d8 is
hanging it just gets a little bit
uncomfortable here so that's why knight
f7 is such a good move to start with
because you don't give white any
flexibility knight g5 check is coming
and you're going to play rook c2 in
which case you don't have to worry about
your knight being loose
and when the king's nh4 you win the h2
yeah just with checkmate so uh
this is just
knight f7 is the one move that fabio
needs to play and then it's essentially
game over
yeah if knight f7 comes first
white also can't really make any useful
moves right you're just like what next i
mean you think about pushing pawns oh
and fabiano finds knight f7
and that might be fabiano's most
important move in the candidates if
yonda palmer she goes on to win as we
expect this would allow him to keep pace
with the tournament leader and not fall
another half point behind
what a move fabiano like we said he's
just so precise when it comes to
technique putting games away e3 and rook
d8 there yeah chef's kiss
so what is that again
the chef's kid oh no no one saw it yeah
yeah okay well
huge huge moment though also for ollie
rosa perugia unfortunately this one got
away from him at some point in the
middle game of this catalan
we see a very distressed
ali reza there's there's there's almost
no moves as we just said like what do
you do against knight g5 the moment the
king isn't protecting h2 rook c2 comes
with devastating effects and it's over
yeah and you sorry
i just wanted to say that knight f7 is
also
a very strong defensive resource
curiously because i wanted to play
bishop f3 and bishop d5 to activate my
bishop this is a very important idea
because this bishop on g4 is doing
nothing right and after bishop f3 you
could still play knight g5 and even take
this bishop but bishop d5 is no longer a
threat that's right
and i mean the idea is very clear rook
c2 coming down yep no no no night loose
on d8 that's really the one thing that
fabian had to avoid and so with rook c2
if all that queen takes b2
the second rank is fabiano's and you
have to feel for
the youngster who just turned 19 the
other day you know a lot of pressure on
him in the world of chess and
you know when you drop down to minus two
two out of six your tournament isn't
over but
if we're being realistic i think he
feels his chances at his first candidate
slipping away yeah
maybe that's where he would feel
liberated from all this burden like
phoenix you know he will
start playing differently you know he
would uh
he would not feel
this kind of pressure at least right
and maybe that allows him to relax a
little bit whatever whatever's not going
well uh jan is observing what's not
going well over the shoulder of ali
russo perugia probably a little
disappointed that the person in second
behind him will get a victory and
maintain pace because yawn yawn also
close to the w if you just got here
versus young christoph duda
here we see ali raza perugia
not sure what to do about the looming
knight to g5 check
and yeah napoli over there he was you're
right he was looking at the game
definitely disappointed that famine was
on his way to a victory because he
wanted to distance himself from the
field but fabiano i mean people have
counted him out as he lost i think
nearly 40 rating points over the last
couple years
but he shows time and time again when
he's in the toughest events when he
needs to play his best he's ready to
step up to that challenge
well
quite the day today we almost have we
could have had three decisive results if
her java was aware of this potential
resource that's four
we could have had four you're right
nakamura dingley wren also did not
disappoint
ended in a a perpetual check where white
is actually down a rook in the final
position so it was it was a fun one
uh let let i mean
both of these games are on the verge of
ending i don't know where to go ollie
rosa perugia only has three minutes for
eight moves
but yawn
is is uh
just kind of corralling the king i mean
young christopher judo looks like he's
about to resign just body language any
second
um
it does seem that way yeah just it looks
like we're about yeah it looks like
we're about to see the hand extent i've
got the uh
the game
napalm to she versus
young christophe duda pulled up here
let's quickly flash over there
and just show what could be the final
moment nice
rook g3 was a really nice move because
he keeps an eye on the e3 square so he
wants to play quincy one but then you
you could play rook f8
very nice
yeah it also it stops any of these queen
trades we were talking about g7 is still
falling i think john kristoff wiping the
sweat off his brow he has four minutes
to make five moves but if i had to guess
he will not reach mu 40 in this game
no
yeah he
sees rook g3 as you're pointing out the
queen moves away from f8 or the queen
can't come to e3 and g7 pawn is just
falling
all sorts of
problems for that black king on h8 yeah
and if the like yeah the queen
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
do we have paramedics
we need can we give danny some help
upstairs
all right yeah you highlighted it really
well the queen's trying to guard f8 he
was trying to threaten to go to e3
g7 is still falling jan has found a ton
of accurate moves to put jkd in an
impossible spot
he's about to win and for a moment we'll
maybe be a point and a half up on the
field depending on what happens uh in
faviano's game versus ferruccia so
what a tournament yondapan yonda
palmishi is having so far here in madrid
we're gonna have our shortest round of
the day knock on wood because it looks
like both these games might end before
time control yeah they're a few moves
away from victory for
the leaders of the tournament and
honestly janna pomeshi and five under
caruana they've been playing the best
chess yep there have been some scary
moments yesterday for yanupomnichi
hikaru nakamura he just made a really
bad move with queen e4 and then for
fabiano he was worse against dingley ren
but never in
too much trouble so i think that fabiano
carwana has been very steady throughout
this event and he's looking to move to
plus two four to six and he will be
playing jan with white pieces in the
second half of the tournament i wanted
to remind you that we would not have the
exact same pairings because if you would
continue the same way some of the
players would have three whites in a row
or three blacks in a row
but um
and right there it is
over
jkd
resigns
young giving a quick opinion on where
the game went wrong
um but uh
young kristoff clearly just dejected
frustrated
uh wow i don't think he ever wants to
think about this game again yeah this is
a game you want to throw away and just
know that it got away from you early
yawn takes a big deep breath looks up at
the sky he is going to be happy headed
into our second rest day
and on the other hand yanchez of duda
who had five draws at this point very
solid player you know showing that he
can hang with all of the highest rated
players in the world he has never quite
cracked the top 10 despite winning the
world cup and other big events but
it came to a head here with yonda
palmishi the last winner of the
candidates last challenger to magnus
carlson it was just too much to bear
with those pawns storming up the king
side john crystal couldn't get out of
there fast enough right he was like
time to go shake this one off head to
the rest day
i i don't even want to talk about where
that went wrong you can always tell when
like you know you've lost a game super
frustrated your opponent wants to give
an opinion you're like look man i just i
need to get out of here
like i can't i can't take another
opinion of how this went wrong but
all right fabiano as we said the fobby
perch
the uh
he knows that he's close
farousha did indeed play bishop of three
spotting elmira's idea that d5
if you give white one move by the way
white's doing okay
i also wanted you know why i wanted to
play bishop f3 because i was thinking
about a position where my king would be
safe you know
would it be safe on g4 then i can play
h4 you know and somehow hold
for some moves
it no it looks interesting i mean the
bishop comes to f3
threatening to go to d5 you let the king
come to g4 of course we look at the eval
bar and know that bobby is moments away
if you can find the right sequence but i
mean this is actually not so simple like
what the right what the best move is
right now he's probably thinking from
fabiano's perspective do i play knight
g5 just take the bishop yeah you can get
rid of it right um and
the problem is going to be that white's
kind of running out of pieces yeah and
black is in exchange that said because
there aren't that many pieces of me the
king on g8 it's not entirely safe
because if you just start trying to win
pawns and the white queen can enter the
last rank especially with a knight on f4
poised to jump into a g6 or e6 square
that does leave white some chances but
we've talked about fabiano and how you
know he's sitting and calculating he's
not rushing just because farrugia has
two minutes and 46 seconds he wants to
deliver the final over the board not
rely on the clock
yeah yes and after knight g5 king g4
that's what because you you shouldn't
rush into king g4 because knight e5 is
also an option and now this threat of
bishop d5 is still in the air because
you would want to play rookie 7 right
like that's why you need to take this
bishop right that's why you got to take
it right and then if queen shakes f3
and maybe still rookie 7 here what do
you think
yes
because the problem for white is you
can't stabilize the knight on a square
like d5 and if you play knight e6
actually this is just very forcing
rookie seven yeah 96 can i just take it
and force the player to go to the go to
the end game oh but i'm not up a pawn i
thought i was up a pawn but yeah
actually
okay that's a
i thought i've taken the pawn like okay
i went ahead no no no you can't rush
that
well you said fabi is taking his time
here because he knows
he knows there may be an opportunity to
end this game
ferrugen will not have the same luxury
the moment he's on the clock he has two
minutes and 46 seconds to play seven
moves
which is uh but as you said i think
probably just showing the maturity we
keep applauding how the players manage
and use their time as a weapon right
when you get an edge on the clock that
doesn't mean you have to play speed
chess with your opponent when they have
to play speech yes like ferus is playing
speed chess right now by the way with no
increment we don't even do that to
people in the scc we give them increment
in the speech chess championship this is
brutal
i think i found
a concrete line that gets rid of all the
reason's chances okay
so rook c2
queen d1 right you're just trying to
play bishop d5 and close queen takes b2
okay and if you play bishop d5 because
i'm gonna take on h2 with check and i
think after changing from h5 95 is not i
can't we can't make that move h5
h5 check and if knight takes i go queen
e2 get the queen's up get those queens
off the board and okay i have the a pawn
that's just gonna run and if you run to
f2 you run into mate
oh no it's not right but king for queen
c2 i also can trade the queens okay but
rook f2 is better but doesn't matter
either way i'm getting the queens off
and once the queens are off i know for a
fact that i'd be winning the game so
okay so if
five now is looking for something like
this rook c2
queen d1
note that there's no discovery on the
queen because she's defended queen takes
b2 threatens rookie rook takes h2
if bishop d5 we go for this line again
there's no mate because the knight is
pinned but this looks good enough can i
go for queen z5 then okay elmira trying
to defend white's position
says that instead of bishop d5 i'll play
queen d5
okay so i take and then bring my queen
back to f6 and
threatening cringey five minutes
even just ask someone to queen trade
into mate
that's cool
if my opponent ever gave me a chance to
queen trade into mate i would i would i
would do it
just
to say it was done
okay
for ruja
is eagerly awaiting his next move
fabiano only has 11 minutes for the
remaining seven moves too so we should
note that
right it's
he can't just think forever
this is the only game remaining in round
six of the 2022 feed a candidates the
drama has been real today maybe peak
drama so far from madrid we've already
had one decisive game
yonda pomnishi currently has a one and a
half point lead over the field fabiano
trying to win to keep pace with the
tournament leader
which would mean it's maybe becoming a
two horse race and on that note he finds
rook c2
likes robert's
idea um they grew up together in new
york these two and uh says yeah it's not
a bad idea robert go ahead out mirror
no i and he keeps the steady hand you
know he's yeah it's it's
such an important quality it's like i'm
always panicking
uh
and truck c2 queen d1 after queen b2
there is
ooh he plays knight g5 first okay
interesting
not
not as straightforward
as uh queen takes b2 was
what's the idea maybe now he's
worried about queen d8 chef now yes but
he wants to take on f3 oh okay
[Music]
but if but if queen d8 check king h8
knight g6 for rouge's threatening check
made on h8
well
even if i want to give it back i can
still play a knight e5 check you know
okay just 95 you get out of it maybe
there's something even better okay
that's fair
but he goes for it okay farouja all in
on queen d8
king h7 is uh
the move and then
two minutes to play four moves
for ali reza so he can take a second to
think nope he says i don't need it
oh he's threatening knight g6 and 96
yeah
but his king is also in danger i mean at
this point bobby could maybe just take
the pawn and get the mating net going
yeah because you're queenie two check to
follow which is very important cause
when the knight goes to g6
it looks like queen h mate is happening
after king g4
where the checks coming from mcqueen e2
is uh important rook takes h2 is
sufficient but yeah anything at this
point with the king
just being hounded by black's pieces
wow
can he keep his knight on f4 in order to
protect those squares and to go for a
perpetual maybe queen eight with the
idea of playing queen g6 grenade
yeah you might need to do something like
that right
but queen takes b2 yeah i like that idea
it probably loses like everything else
but
setting up a chance for a perpetual
check might be perugia's last chance
oh man this is i feel like the wind is
floating out of our seals sails but this
is uh
this will be the first day where we've
had two decisive results if it had no no
day one we also had i apologize
fabiano caruana vita cara nakamura and
yonder palmer she won with the black
pieces over dingley wren but okay he
goes for this perpetual idea and those
are the same players and the same two
players might be delivering
yet again in the same realm
it's no wonder they're the only two
players in the field that have ever
challenged for a world championship
title experience pays off apparently
when you know how to win the candidates
tournament certainly helps and here
queen g6 to e8 just pointed out put that
queen on a yo-yo string it's going to be
a draw by repetition and that's why this
queen on b2 likely is about to go back
to f6 near the king attacking the f5
pawn stopping the queen from going to g6
and also throwing queen c6 check to
trade those queens yeah i like it
queen f6 i would
i would have to play e4
first of all protecting the f5 phone uh
and then uh i want to play knight g6
that's my only chance yeah it's only
you somehow need to get that knight to
g6 i don't think fabiano is going to be
so friendly about it though yeah
i mean you can try queen f6 i mean try
something like g4 no no i i need to play
e4 because
six is a very important threat
but now you've opened up more problems
i'm already thinking about bringing the
queen back although the king runs so
unnecessary check should not be given
um
but okay what exactly is white
threatening in this spot right away
knight g6 can i can i do something else
first so but this this could be a
possible line so it's not it's not
useless looking at if queen f6 e4 will
likely be played quickly by ferruja
given he only has a minute and a half
for two moves
it's now or never so what is what is
black's move here this is
so i think your white's king gets made
at first so after rook takes h2 okay
knight g6 i have queen c3 check okay
and your king is just gonna be hunted so
you go king to g4 and i only have one
check h5 yeah but the problem is it's a
good enough check rook f2 and queen
takes g3 okay so
one of those just super scary positions
for both sides okay queen of six played
ali reza has 90 seconds for two moves he
plays e4 as we predicted that line would
be on the board
we are moments away potentially
from
the fourth game of the day ending two
decisive results
potentially in store here
and five nano has plenty of time right
this is move 39 so instead of rushing
this move to get to mu 40 this is an
important moment because you know as
elmira was hoping for and as we were
just illustrating that with the knight
coming to g6 there are some ideas for
white to survive this game and threaten
checkmate so right now fabiano he
doesn't want to let this advantage slip
and that's why he's going to use a bunch
of time before ultimately making his
final two move to the time patrol
i'm so absorbed by the game you know i
cannot breathe
this is
just proving that you you can breathe
holding my breath i'm excited this is
this is why we this is why we came right
this is why we play the game as they say
we got 33 000 people on twitch thanks
for being with us no matter where you're
tuning in from
this has been a hype day we've got our
second rest day ahead as we said a
couple of players are headed to that day
very very happy and they are the only
two players who've ever played magnus
carlsen for a world championship match
assuming fabiano puts away the game here
but looks like he is a move or two away
from doing so
and ali reza ferrucci this is not a
welcome rest day for the young man right
now
the candidates is grueling
someone said that in a pre-show hype
video
i wonder who
miss amigos
[Laughter]
the challenger to the world champion of
chess must come through madrid
just proving that you can do it live
i still remember that script
this guy has a legacy we'll say that and
uh he would love for his legacy to be
that he played for the world title not
once but twice
and it might uh
might be something we're talking about
in hindsight a win with the black pieces
is the kind of thing you need to have
happen to get that job done but remember
what happened yesterday when dingley
wren was on move 39 against timor ajabov
true that's why he's not over yet okay
he does take h2
fabiano has one more
move to make
sorry for rouge has one more move to
make i was looking at ferruja thinking
pavianna go ahead it's how important to
be precise in your calculations and to
not
see a ghost you know yeah what happened
what exactly happened to dingle ryan
yesterday and fabi goes for rook h2 and
i'm pretty sure that he saw well he
calculated it till the very end yeah
most likely he did meaning that line
that robert was looking at knight g6
queen c3 check h5 right more than likely
yeah
and you can see on through his face you
saw that he just put his hands like
there's nothing left here what more can
i do i've you know tried and he has this
just last few seconds right 37 seconds
and counting down he needs to play a
move
unfortunately for him we can see in the
evaluation where no moves are good
enough but sometimes you feel like you
still have a chance right you just
pose a question to your opponent i think
he feels as if he's out of questions
yeah he has 20 seconds he's gonna have
more than a game of 20 questions
after after this one because he's got
he's got to go back to the drawing board
with whoever his team of seconds are
yeah no no but if he plays 96 that's the
same mate yeah
seven seconds five seconds it's gotta go
gotta move gotta move queen d7 he does
with three seconds on the clock
unfortunately it's probably the same
fate no now he can meet h5 with knight
takes h5 at least
in those positions yeah but i think
fabiano yeah fabiano still has to make
his 40th move
and uh
there's a good thing for fabiano there's
no threat like if white had a turn here
there's no like checkmating thread so he
can bring his queen back in with queen
c3 check yeah and after king g4 he can
even bring his queen into more like
queen d2 off for a queen trade
threatened queen d1 mate right and then
actually after queen to d2 there i i
don't see a way you avoid the queen
trade as white and if you trade queens
you
obviously are done for
yeah that makes sense so queen
no longer threatening the yo-yo
as uh robert said so now you're back to
many options right not just he doesn't
have to be force made anymore you can go
for the line robert just said offer the
queen trade if she goes right back
now you've got new options queen d1
check is uh
well the computer says it's made in 31.
so i saw
whatever computer
uh anyway but yeah the the idea is the
queen improves herself
against the white king and
again bobby being patient he has three
and a half minutes i don't need to rush
my 40th move
takes poise under pressure to get the
job done he's been here before
and he knows how to do it
you just need to remember that he has
not made his for him yes he needs to
remember that he takes a sip of water
you know that uh looking um
the
book that we were talking before looking
through the glass like uh what is the
translation at least in the wonderland
yeah the looking glass or the looking
glass actually starts with the a strange
position where uh
there is carol announces may 11 you know
so
that's the computer evaluation
bobby looks like he's about to move
two minutes to get this last one on the
board but uh
queen c3 just fine queen c3 check and
indeed it's it
sometimes it feels like the silence is
deafening right right at the end
i'm just talking about the oxygen has
been sucked out of the building by
fabiano caruana
silence are the sounds of lamps
that's
first of all a great movie i know shout
out to you jody foster
anthony hopkins
all right king g4 played quickly there
by ellie reza ferrugia despite having
extra time on the clock but he shakes
his head he knows that
it's it's not a question of uh it's not
within his control anymore he gets back
into this game if fabiano gives it away
and uh and only that is is is a way for
him back in it so
and bobby's just kind of hanging he's
looking the position he knows it's over
you can see by his body language yeah
this is just a matter of a couple moves
and then i get the victory yeah and
queen d2 looks just
ko on the spot
well one of the most experienced players
in the field
playing in his fourth candidates is
fabiano carwana
and
showing that experience pays off in a
game like today
and again he we we expect him to
to move quickly here go ahead elmira now
i had a very strange question do you
think that both of these players for
example nepal and uh
fabi
they hope that magnus will not play
and then they will then they'll play a
match then they will play a match well
if they finish first and second
we will ask him that we will ask both of
them then um
i i don't think either of them actually
wants that i mean no they would love to
become the world champion but becoming
the world champion because magnus
abdicates his throne is very strange so
right i think that they want to beat the
best and they would like to beat magnus
carlsen for world champion rather than
play each other
that feels uh i i think we can say for
sure neither of them would like that
they'd much rather play magnus carlsen
the world would rather see magnus
carlsen play um queen to d2 is played by
fabiano carwana in this game
and i i don't expect it i don't expect
it to be much more
oh man after this game everybody we will
quickly remind you of what the results
were on the day and show you where the
standings are and probably break down
some of these wild critical moments
right after a very very short break so
don't go anywhere we don't want to miss
this final huge moment we've got some
exciting chess to bring you
because we didn't get to catch all the
critical moments of this of this amazing
round the two games that ended in a draw
had just as much fireworks on the board
that we couldn't quite follow as closely
as we wanted
show you the final moments of
napomnishi's victory over duda
as well as add anything more to this one
should we need to do so
i'm just that's that's me just telling
everybody why they shouldn't go anywhere
in case you're wondering that's just me
doing my job i've got 33 000 people and
a lot of people on other platforms as
well besides twitch this is a lot this
has been awesome this is where we're
excited i've just been looking for
checkmates and i found a few you've got
a few yeah tell me in your head only
only in my head okay so telepathy
[Laughter]
this might happen yeah h5 check here
okay because if the knight takes on h5
you go queen e2 and very least you win
the knight and the king goes to g5
instead of taking the uh pawn on h5 your
queen d8
yeah still cold you have to look at
those backwards moves those are the
easiest ones to miss actually
let's actually bring up the analysis
board joking we won't make the chat do
it because it's actually just over if
fabiano plays h5 i think we actually
will see perusal resign
um
king f3 the only mate that robert didn't
point out is mate for both queen f2 and
rook f2 for the record
knight takes h5 allows queen to d1 no no
no no no oops sorry i might meet you
that was a kidding that was a kidding
it was so funny okay that was a joke for
danny oh so funny for me oh it was
robert's attempted sportsmanship
it's like
king g5
queen of d8 is checkmate
indeed
never too late to never late well you
said the backward moves aren't the moves
that are the hardest to see and i i
wasn't really paying attention to be
fair at that point um
just resigns as favi returns to the
table doesn't even make him play h5
and
we officially have a two-horse race here
in madrid ladies and gentlemen and
that's not counting any of the other
players out but right now
the players on a different level are the
the only two guys to win on the same day
twice round one now round six
faviano caruana says hey anything yonda
palmer she can do i can do better i can
move with the black pieces too and he
takes down all the reza perugia here
today
what a big moment for five under carwana
and a very sad one for alireza frugia he
has now lost two games he goes to the
bottom of the standings he's alone down
there and it's gonna feel lonely because
he came here to win he didn't come here
to just do okay to get second place he
wanted to win this event
before we bring up the standings we'll
remind you of how it all went down
a draw between rajab and rapport but not
one with not crazy drama we will show
you that literally right before that
game finished it could have been a
different result so if you missed it you
don't want to go anywhere
obviously as we just saw ali reza
perugia goes down
we just added a lot of drama to that so
i'll jump to the nakamura dingley ren
another draw that was exciting
full of craziness
and napomnishi dominant yet again with
the white pieces uh beating
the second youngest player in the field
versus vidalia rising ferrugia now young
christopher dude he's beating up on the
kids yawn you're beating up on the kids
here um
but okay let's talk about where that
where that puts everybody in the
standings
what can we say elmira
two people at the top separated by a
full point over third place
oh that's a very close race of course
but uh look at the bottom of the
standings uh
alireza is
all alone there at the bottom of this
thing is such a different trajectory
that everyone has predicted at the
beginning of the event
yep
so
well everything is still possible for
hikaru nakamura and richard airport so
we will see yeah your thoughts on that
what what does hikaru nakamura and
richard report take with them into the
rest day they see their two competitors
win
what's their mindset to make sure they
don't feel like this is getting out of
hand well reported six draws and today
he can count his blessings because he
was
on the verge of losing yeah for the
first time all event but
it has become a two-player race right
now because ghana palm shield is a point
and a half ahead of everyone not named
fabiano caruana so
right now the difference is huge and
that's a really
a lot because look at the win column
right
three wins for yan two for fabiano and
then only hikaru has the other victory
players aren't just beating each other
here yeah so who's going to be able to
catch up to yon if you're looking at
this from rajab of dingley ren duda's
perspective were you two full points
behind yep you need to not only win
games yourself but hope that yon keeps
losing from the top so
i'm not counting anybody out it's still
early but that gap is widening and
that's a problem for everybody that's
not fabiano carwana and it's really
looking like a two-player race yeah
okay well uh as promised we're not
ending the show we're gonna take a very
quick break because we just feel that we
have to do justice to what went down
here in round six we're going to give
you some instructive takeaways talk
about the critical moments maybe even
show an immortal game or two because a
queen sack is what dingley wren would do
more for chess.com coverage from the
2022 feed a candidates in madrid in just
a moment
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
[Music]
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players
customize the arena with any time
control with standard chests or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches
signing up is free and easy so what are
you waiting for
[Music]
do
we are back
in madrid
after a an absolutely wild wild day
and you guys are both looking at me like
what just happened right alvirah's gonna
go robert
what just happened there those were some
incredible games today hats off to all
eight players we know that obviously it
didn't go the way of a couple players in
particular uh so not everyone is feeling
fantastic about their chess but the live
audience down there is feeling fantastic
about the show that they got
as you can see before you we had two
draws and two decisive games
and uh and wow we're gonna
we're gonna make our way quickly through
all four games and just show what you
know the critical moment was talk a
little bit about you know how it went
down and uh
what it might be mean for the for the
players regardless of the result and on
that note we're gonna go right back to
the game that took us to the break
uh which was of course ollie rosa for
rouge's
uh just
it didn't go his way his his catalan i
was about to say his game against father
carwana and we went back to this moment
to show that this really was the moment
that reflected that he had clearly kind
of lost the threat on the position and
with time pressure creeping in he went
for an exchange stack that didn't work
out and i feel like i even misled you
because when we're talking about what
position we should look at maybe it's
even earlier i hate to put his back when
he went knight d2 and out of a queen e7
right here when he went knight f3 like
trying to go for e4 e5 yeah it felt like
he didn't want to accept this position
might just be even right and we were
talking during the round about knight e4
yeah alberto was calling for 94. and it
just looks like a level game but then he
goes for this knight f3 e4 push and that
e4 push started to get him in trouble
and then as we continue just the next
couple moves he plays this
rook takes d7 idea hoping that okay i'll
get the bishop then i'll play bishop h3
but as we saw instead of queen d6 which
just leaves black slightly better bobby
said you know what i'll keep that
material i will play f5 and after e
takes f5 that was really the move that
kind of lost all the risen most of his
chances but he already was in a bad
position but then i also think at the
the opening yeah and
now that we know what was the outcome of
the game and yeah i
think that he should have played knight
c3 you know because fabi had
such powerful pieces and especially the
knight on d5 then maybe the trouble
started with d3 no like a little bit
later oh okay
instead of rook g1
yeah instead of rook g1 here
maybe knight c3 a simple move yeah and
then
let's go
after bishop f6 you simply go somewhere
but you need to exchange this night
well it's just and again it shows you
how far we're going back because we just
i think just psychologically emotionally
we all feel like something never felt
right for ali reza in this game and
we're all saying that as fans of him
right we're watching this kid's meteoric
rise and
his time management said he didn't feel
comfortable right and the position just
with every
it's like little mistakes lead to big
mistakes you can't argue that any of
these moves really was the blunder that
went wrong probably until until the
exchange sack with f5 and even then you
could say like maybe if he takes with
the bishop but it's just afterwards the
story is like it just didn't feel right
for perugia it was slipping from the
very beginning yeah that's actually a
great summary is that from the start of
this game when he chose the catalan
position an opening that we were
surprised by he plays it and he never
felt like he was comfortable and he
doesn't have the experience to just on
the fly
take down
fabiana caruana that doesn't mean he has
to lose the game but he was clearly
playing for an advantage like he wanted
to win this game you could sense the
hunger and that served him very well
throughout his chess career to this
point but that's actually one of the
storylines we talked about yesterday and
then even today you need to be objective
against 500 karwana because he might be
the most objective chess player on the
planet yeah where he doesn't risk things
if it's unnecessary he doesn't do
speculative sacrifices or ideas he just
plays the position and he was able to
play a position where he was given some
material and he never let that advantage
slip and i'm just gonna finish it off
with that because this is when we we
were all now saying okay this is bobby
at his best right like the best engine
line is like you play this e3 move and
then what you said for rouge or missed
of course is based on this rook d8 idea
you unpin the pawn from the queen so
that you're threatening to take these
things are just
gonna happen very very quickly now the
pieces start coming off the board and
okay like you could argue different ways
but every time it felt like there was a
key critical move otherwise this could
get messier than the eval bar says it is
fabi would find those moves with knight
f7
then bringing the rook in
ultimately he went for this knight g5
idea maybe here there was queen b2 rook
h2 but we're not we're not splitting
hairs over that and uh as we said this
was just a matter of technique fabiano
plays
perfect chess when he's winning a lot of
the time uh and which is not an easy
thing to do we say it like it's easy but
it's not an easy thing to do and bobby
gets the job done there so okay we gotta
go to the other winner because we had to
come back to that it was the one that
had all our viewers right at the end
but the guy who went first and the guy
who was in first is yonda pomneshi he
took down young christophe duda
the final moment here elmira as you said
rook to g3 is just
what what a retreating move right to win
on because you stopped the queen from
not only trying to to trade queens but
you also forced the queen off of the f8
square it's a very elegant solution you
know to use the terms for mathematics
because you
you need to
to play rook f8 or to take on g7 but you
simply need to deflect black's queen
yeah so rook just three is a very simple
move but it's very beautiful
and if you played d3 just die we didn't
know this in the game but if you play d3
to stop the queen and push your d pawn
now that you don't have queen e3 anymore
we're back to just taking g7 and it's
just it's just simple so
the only other thing i want to show in
this one just to highlight that it was
really out of control from the very
beginning is the move that uh vishyanan
on our india coverage just said he
called it elegant in a position that was
good for white but maybe it wasn't
totally clear how to proceed john played
this really nice h4 kind of patiently
building for the attack he doesn't rush
forward with the move f5 that would have
actually let the advantage slip a little
bit not because black could take the
pawn and then lose the the bishop but
actually because of this move bishop d4
which would have been a really nice way
to expose extending too fast so what can
we say about yon playing h4 and also the
body language we were already seeing
from duda at this point yeah jan looked
like he was in charge yeah under promise
she was playing moves with confidence he
brought his queen over to the king's
side he pushes the h-pawn and a lot of
our focus and i'm sure young stuff dude
his focus was on the move f5 yeah but
what yonda palmicide did is he showed
tremendous understanding and restraint
to play for g5 instead because he has an
extra pawn on the king side in fact he
has two extra pawns because they're
double e pawns yeah we just look at the
front four pawns that's more important
so they're four on three and he's like
let's go for that attack we want to push
that pawn forward to g5 and the way he
handled himself was really excellent
yeah he he uh goes forward we're not
even going to talk about the move rook
c3 because that's how cheaters get
caught
but it was a very nice solution
and uh as elmira said
already
so elegantly yawn's finish was elegant
with the retreating movement g3 so
that's how the two winners got the job
done if you missed it
someone had an opportunity to get the
job done
and
completely changed their fate so to
speak right i don't know how to say it
like with more more drama behind it
right because
take us through it robert taylor drive
up is not one in a lot of games
classical chess how hard is it though
when you've made up your mind that you
you were losing so now you're just happy
with the draw to spot what could have
been this move bishop to h2 for the win
the move by itself if this were a tactic
is very easy yeah java would have found
it in
five seconds right if given the position
and said white to play and win yes yeah
just you know white's playing move when
there's just like a position throwing
you but with the weight of the game
behind him the fact that he was down now
he's not three pawns but before that he
was down two pawns and he was finding
ways to just to survive remember there
was a point where rajav only had one
move that queen c3 moved yeah if he
didn't find queen c3 he would have just
lost the game so he had so much stress
from earlier in the game where rapport
was doing all this preparation and then
played really energetically and then to
like turn it around in your own time
trouble to find bishop h2 i think
flipping that switch in your head is
difficult rajabov is more than capable
of doing so
but maybe there's a reason he hasn't won
a classical game of chess since 2019.
he needs to he needs to think about that
on the no think about robert hess's
words on the wrestling no kidding but
almira part of the reason we were saying
psychologically he wasn't thinking about
the wind is because of what robert just
said you found queen c3 when we were
going it was the only move
and it led us to this line where roger
was just defending defending but under
so much look how crazy this game was
this the rook being sacrificed for a
remaining attack roger can't even take
it this position was just unreal walks
into a discovered check
anyway this game was awesome
but i wanted to go to a point you made
in real time elmerick because i think it
was huge that
really report gave raja that chance we
just saw gave him the chance for the
miss win and you made you made a really
important comment which is that you have
to be aware of your opponent's next move
the opponent's threats and when you're
up so much material and the queens are
off the board maybe you don't have a
right sense of danger how lucky do you
feel richard report feels
on the rest day that he didn't lose this
game when he blundered this move rook g4
allowing rook f1
well he's certainly singing now because
i saw already a small smile you know in
his face when he was leaving the plane
hole yeah the thing is that
if we come back to the position where uh
rajab played rook f7 okay he what i had
a glance at their time to the third
o'clock so he still has five minutes
left
and the thing is he knows that the joy
is inevitable after rook f7 simply
because black has nothing to do that's
the only chance to go for this perpetual
so basically i think that it was a very
impulsive move yeah so you're saying the
criticism for him not getting a victory
for the first opportunity he would have
in 35 games right
you got to think right you just
i think america's points a great one
that you can make that draw with four
seconds on your clock f7 there's nothing
that black can do yeah so if you use the
remaining times think maybe there's
something better he would have found the
bishop retreat and i think it's it was a
very tense game as i mentioned yeah and
well if we're gonna criticize for java
we should criticize report because he
had plenty of time just go before
rook g4 right here he has
45 minutes remaining yeah and white's
idea is to bring that rook in the game
so he himself could have played with
like c5 or rook to f8 just to keep the
rook out of the f-file and yes it's easy
to be in this chair and look at the
evaluation bar but he had a lot of time
mistakes happen and that's okay but he
could have spent more time at this
moment and i think that maybe he lost
his sense of danger
it seems like both players i mean he
lost his sense of danger and then raja
didn't realize how much danger the
report was in by the way because the
best move to maintain the advantage for
black is just
is to play rook f8 thinking what is my
opponent's threat and to stop it it's a
hard move to see if you don't respect
respect the file right that how
it's a weird game right but amazing
maybe one explanation to it is that
sometimes while you're calculating the
variation you almost convince your
opponent that something doesn't work in
this line and you have the same kind of
blindness right
so yeah the same square your mutual
blindness okay well as we said though
one more time a reminder the final
position okay not the final position to
move before the final position white is
winning
if you just bring the bishop to safety
because you still can't stop the threat
rather than playing the
el mira described impulsive move rook to
f7 so quickly at least
and uh and taking the draw so
okay unfortunately for job off the story
line continues to haunt him and chase
him the monkey is not off of his back
yet as they say he has not won a
classical game and more than 35
classical games played over the last
three years so
he may not get another opportunity
better than that all right last game we
haven't looked at real quick from this
epic epic round six was a really fun
rook sack i guess to end with a
perpetual
we should probably back up though
because it doesn't do the story full
justice i think if we go back really to
where nakamura's prep i think started to
slow down a little bit because it was
bishop takes b5 right the first move
that dingley run found that put icaru on
the clock talk a little bit about this
decision to play bishop takes p5 and how
ding's effort had gotten him this
opportunity to squelch nakamura's prep
yeah if it weren't for those other two
players who won their games we might be
just praising ding as the best game of
the year
yeah he was facing
engine preparation very deep preparation
and you see from this position he was
down nearly an hour on the clock and he
plays bishop takes b5 but it wasn't just
a you know let's trade pieces idea it
was let me bring my knight to e6 he saw
the critical idea is that that knight on
e6 was
stabilizing his position making sure he
wouldn't get checkmated and also led him
to a position where he could even play
for a win we saw that d-pawn running up
the board and we also saw ding's face
where he was kind of upset that the game
was going to result in a draw yeah well
robert talks about the 96 that was
really the key piece right i mean the
defensive position of the pony is the
reason
hikaru had to bail out for the draw
right so tell me amira given that hikaru
it does feel like he bailed out for the
draw and not dingley wren how do you
think hikaru was feeling about the fact
that this game ended peacefully well
actually there was a very important
psychological moment first of all after
knight g5 because ding was absolutely
sure that hikaru would not go for bishop
g5 you know because he needs to keep his
bishops on the board in order to play
all the attacking moves you know rg3
then bishop h6 and
that's why this move is so um strong
perfectly timed perfectly timed so
hikaru wouldn't go for bishop g5 uh he
wanted to launch an attack and then at
the end
i want to expand on that because that's
such a good point because actually
objectively bishopric g5 might be the
best move objectively right to take and
then go for
what is it likely a draw but that's a
really good point because it's because
hikaru is still feeling like he should
be better because he's still remembering
that prep that he had that he want to
get the w that ding takes advantage of
that psychological moment to put himself
in a spot where suddenly
he was maybe playing for a win so i just
i love that point elmira that's a great
point and now now we get to the end
where you said that knight was so great
at defending the attack
and takara had to bail out and here i
think once again has sensed uh perfectly
that he needs to sacrifice all his
pieces and to go for the perpetual yeah
so that's a good thing for ricardo i
guess to sense that it's getting away
from me don't let it get all the way
away
and go for the draw and that's why i
think ding was so upset because when he
went d2 like you're told when your pawn
is that far up the board you should play
that pawn push like at least 20 of the
time right you are looking to it do that
but this is around the moment where it
felt like dingly wren you know he was
feeling confident maybe i can play for a
win because if there's no checkmate on
the king side well we have a d-pawn and
a c-pawn that will be happy to join it
eventually so at this moment we see off
to the side the evaluation bars is
slightly better for black d2 kind of
forced this drawing sequence but if he
brought his queen back to b4 very easy
to say in hindsight but this queen helps
defend the king and you look at the
evaluation it is better for black
because the past pawns are so strong
that knight on e6 is holding everything
together that's a really key point queen
to b4 is actually maybe the only move
that keeps the edge for kingly iran
right a hard one to see so hard to hold
against him but a really good point
that's why he was maybe shaking his head
because you do it with tempo you hit the
rook you can defend at a moment's notice
and you still have chances to push the
d-pawn later on so okay well dignity may
have missed that opportunity either way
it ends peacefully um and we wanted to
bring this show to a close with we don't
want to miss our opportunity to show one
of one of all three of us one of our
favorite games of all time i don't know
why everyone just loves dingley wren we
get one more shout out for daily random
would love them we know everyone loves a
car he's got more fans on twitch than
everybody so but everyone loves dingley
wren and we wanted to show if you
haven't seen this game
dings magnum opus dings immortal
let's do it
oh hi
i didn't see you there everybody i was
just heading for a stroll and well
wouldn't you know it look at this game
on the board here an amazing game jin
shibai playing the white pieces versus
dingley ren and so because dingley runs
black we should definitely flip this
thing around and show you this game if
you haven't seen it you're in for a
treat so this is ding's
one of the games that i guess arguably
put dingley wren on the map he was
already of course
an up-and-coming player maybe people
already predicting he would become
china's first ever 2800 player first and
only still at this time but this game
literally turned heads and is still
arguably the best queen sack we've seen
in the last uh last few years at least
at the highest level just maybe ever so
e5 starts with this idea that knight
takes e5
is uh looks like white is is is opening
the center maybe things are going to
collapse but because the king is in so
much danger dingley wren has the right
sense of danger and this is the move
that starts everything d takes c3
sacrificing the queen on d8
to go on an epic king hunt that will not
disappoint it's not over yet you're down
a queen the eval bar says oh yeah black
was winning but no this was this was not
an easy one to put away and tons of fun
ahead so after queen takes b2 we are
going to see what makes dingley ren so
dangerous kind of like fabiano caruana i
think robert would agree that when he's
winning the dude is just ding is the
dude when he's winning he's super
precise never fails an opportunity most
of the time oh man as i say that i'm
remembering where java's game yesterday
okay we're not talking about that we're
celebrating ding's victory right now one
temple move after another knight a4 hits
the queen knight c3 hits the king and
then the move that if you haven't seen
this game
pause the stream and try to find it then
you'll catch up in real time one of my
favorite chess moves i've ever seen
rook to d4 he's already down a queen
and now he's sacrificing a rook to
continue the mating attack but the most
important thing is that white cannot
take this rook black would win back the
material with interest as the attack
isn't even over it so
h3 is played instead and here we go h5
threatening g4 g4 would be checkmate by
the way takes takes knight takes
bishop takes to end the game
so the bishop runs to h2 to free the
king
g4 check king g3
rook to d2
every time i see this game i just want
to pause and take it in
queen runs away oh by the way okay if
the queen takes it we have knight e4
check and black's position just
continues to roll after the king moves
we'll win back the queen and as we set
with interest because the attack is
going to continue
so instead the queen ran
and dingley wren continues the mating
net king h4 bishop e7 check
king takes h5 and then
this game just never stops disappointing
like
it's b takes c3 it's rook d4
right and now it's king g7 he's down a
queen and the game is just continuing
now the threat is you move the bishop
anywhere the rook is coming into h8 with
mate there's really only one
disappointing aspect to this entire game
and it happens in a few moments after
bishop before bishop f5
threatening rook h8 mate as we said
bishop h6
king h7 again so many different mates
threatened here
queen takes b7 rook takes f2
absolutely crazy
bishop to g5 and after rook h8
the most disappointing thing about this
game is that after knight takes f7
bishop g6 takes a 95 check
is that jin shibai didn't let dingley
run checkmate him what kind of a person
doesn't let you checkmate you when you
play a game like this
who is gg by
no i'm just going off the rails here but
i'm
i'm unhappy that this game did not end
in a checkmate look at it the only move
after 95 check is king h4 and the
checkmate is forced on king g7 knight to
8.
what happened
it wasn't oh king g8 okay sorry king g8
because you have to unpin the bishop my
bad okay and after knight h6 rook takes
h6 and it's over okay there we go so
lots of fun for dingley ran one of our
favorite games
keep talking
we're having a great time over here yeah
we're just enjoying that and uh we we
just had a great time going over this
hold on why was king g7 wrong
what did i do on kg7
because you can't oh yeah because you
take the rook bishop's pin
dude what are you doing man we need we
need a professional to do this
this is not your role within micah are
you guys playing this the whole time
what is
um what happened was um
i texted you i texted you and then you
didn't get back to me and so i had to do
it myself by the way that sure looks
great on you
yeah looking good looking good thank you
you should always have this role i
appreciate that i'm going to do it you
guys hear that mauricio i should always
have this role he's calling me what's up
robert what's up maurice man you're
supposed to call me back for dinner
what's the deal what do you mean
then danny would know you're here
ruin the whole picture and keep it
secret okay
oh my gosh maurice actually in studio
ladies and gentlemen this is the guy
that made the monitor breaks happen in
chess you all know that i don't even
tell you but dude
anyway we just showed dingley runs
immortal and we showed mike blunt this
is why the pros do it because i make
blunders when i'm on the monitor with
king to g7 instead of king g8 but that's
what that's what dingley ren would have
played the game would have been over but
look at us couple of guys dressed in
salmon it's ridiculous that's ridiculous
it looks pretty good i'd say appreciate
you having me on the show hey great job
thank you sir amazing that you're here
and uh maybe we will catch up with
maurice later i don't know yeah and this
is already shocking i had no idea this
was happening i had no idea this was
happening so all right man great to see
you i mean i would invite you to come
sit down but we're good you got it you
guys got it
bye everybody oh my god what is going on
maurice ashley everybody you were so did
you know they were doing that i had no
idea oh my god
oh well we do know that yonder palm she
is atop the standings after six rounds
of action he's trailed by fabiano
carwana with four out of six and after
that it's quite the distance between the
rest of the field so danny you okay over
there
i'm still freaking out
at first that maurice was like coming
through to like confront me about being
on the monitor i was like i was like oh
my god
wait well you don't want to have a fight
with maurice
we should start with this maurice
actually is a great boxer for those who
don't know well they say no yeah okay so
yeah i don't want it yeah it's just no
idea assistant if chris wants to take
over the monitor he can come at any time
my sister's a champion box yeah yeah
yeah so
anyway that was awesome maurice ashley
showing up in the studio a legend walked
in a legend walks in the studio a guy
that uh seriously made made highlight
moments on the monitor that content that
st louis started doing years ago just
amazing stuff and we're having maurice
ashley here as we as we tried to do our
best to emulate it and i even blundered
king to g7 what was i thinking okay
awesome stuff so anyway this has been
quite the day a lot of fun
the uh the stage is set will any
challenger step to the step to the plate
and slow down yonda pandashi and fabio
karwana or is that going to be the rest
of the story we're going to find out
after the second rest day but um
anyway i got nothing else to say
maybe you should have a look at the
pairings we do let's look at the
pairings for for
for the back half if we have the
pairings for the back half of the rest
day maybe remind everybody of what's
coming up
yeah we we get the day off so the
players so you know they're
gonna prepare
i have dina asked uh fabiano i remember
in the interview i was like oh what are
you doing your rest day it wasn't too
fun i just you know prepare but that's
what the players have to do and there's
a reason why a player like fabiano and
yana palmishi they're using their days
off to recuperate win tournaments to win
tournaments and win this one yep
well um
jan upon she
is still the guy to beat um one of the
things that uh
what we'll see here when we got the
matchups is colors in the last round
remember who have they not played yet
because i don't have the pairing in
front of me and it's been a long day um
it has been a long day
now i'm trying to think about the talk
about who have they not played yet
so much pressure now as fabiano played
for java let's see if we can guess it
bob yano has not played for java got one
of those i think young should play every
church
reporter and report
okay the first one
that was
quite a while ago
we're not the worst in the world no
you said dude and report
no no no no no
yes yes because jan is young
sister i was the one who made it before
i should swallow my words it's
interesting
report has a winning record against upon
machine now only one game but they've
played nine games so it's not like they
haven't played so there's a little bit
of a little bit of a story line there
report as you said counting his lucky
stars that he still hasn't lost in this
tournament
uh after after today's game
due to nakamura also an interesting one
another one where hikaru has a one game
lead but they've only played once a
little bit hard to draw too much there
look at i wasn't saying that's a very
dangerous game for ikaru okay because
duda just lost so you might think let me
try to beat the guy who's you know lower
than me in the standings and he's won
their only game head to head but dude
with the white pieces i mean that guy is
a menace and so if you're thinking about
this from a results oriented perspective
that can really backfire yeah agreed
ding and farouza they've only played
twice a couple of draws between them uh
also a very dangerous game probably mr
purusha we'll see
how he how he deals with the rest day
but if dingley ring gets the white
pieces after having two very good games
as black by the way almost beat rajab
off great game against ikaro today if
ding is slowly finding his form that
could be that could be a very tough game
for ollie rosa perugia and then you've
got caron i mean if there was an
opportunity i hate to say it because i
don't disrespect your job offer right
but he has a 4-0 score against raja
he's a half a point behind napoli he has
the white pieces we know that favi is
going to bring it on saturday after the
rest day so okay so we'll just say that
the table's been set we know that we're
going to have really exciting chess on
the back half
of this event we're not even quite there
yet but after this rest day it's round
seven and we of course will see you then
on saturday uh but there is chess on
friday so as we bring this show to a
close let's remind people that while we
will be enjoying a break all of you
still have events to watch it's the
women's speed chess championship
last year's quarterfinal quarter
finalists excuse me and katarina lagno
now the two seed in this event plays the
rising star women's grand master of
antiqua agrawal qualified her way in
she's playing fantastic chess that
starts at 5 a.m pacific time
right after that we have the i'm not a
gm speed chess championship
that matchup will decide who plays eric
rosen in the final james canty just got
past shubalova taking on lawrence tren
who i also saw wandering around madrid
shout out to lawrence so right after the
wscc we have the i'm not a gm speeches
championship
if you're never tuned into those events
they are a ton of fun lots of excitement
and they are in back to back fashion on
friday so tune in check them both out
that second event obviously begins at
9am pacific as you can see so all right
we'll bring this thing to a close here
yeah i'm waiting to play against you in
this that's next year next year we'll
maybe make that a first round pairing
just
go for it uh but okay this has been an
awesome day so much fun the players
delivered this was a blast maurice
ashley delivered thank you so much to
him for coming us in studio shout out to
the team working super hard we will see
you all over the weekend elmira
kripchenko robert hess danny wrench
enjoy the day off everybody
the pala belicio de centonia waits for
you on the other side of the second rest
day
[Music]
do